AND WELCOME. THIS IS OUR
SOMEONE HEARING ON MARCH
ELEVENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY TODAY
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
AGING AREA AND THE PROGRAMS FOR
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. THIS IS A
PROMISING TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
AS THE GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN
EXTRAORDINARY STEPS LAST YEAR
TO BEGIN A MASTER PLAN OF AGING
PROCESS WHICH HAS BEEN VERY
OPEN DELIBERATIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE. WE'RE EXCITED TO
SEE WHERE THIS WILL LEAD AND
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE AND
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA'S AGING
POPULATION. WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS A DIRECT NEXUS BETWEEN THE
FORCES OF A THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND BEAT
HOW ARE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
WORK TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME AND IN
NEED. AND SEE THE DISK THE
DISGRACE OF RACING HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND STREET
HOMELESSNESS AFFECTING ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. IT IS MY HOPE
THAT WE CAN PURSUE IMPROVEMENTS
AND INVESTMENTS THAT FORTIFY
THE SAFETY NET COUNTERACTS
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS AND TO
PREVENT THE CRISES FROM
SPENDING EVEN FURTHER.
BURGEONING HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS
WITH SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND CHILDREN IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AND UNDER OUR
COLLECTIVE MORAL LEADERSHIP.
THE PROGRAMS WE WILL DISCUSS
TODAY THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES SS I SS P. AND THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES ARE
PART OF OUR FRONTLINE DEFENSES
AGAINST SENIOR POVERTY AND
POVERTY AT LARGE IN OUR STATE.
TODAY IT WILL HEAR MANY
ADVOCACY PROPOSALS THAT SHARE
THE THEME OF FORTIFYING THE
SAFETY NET I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
PLEASE BE PREPARED TO OFFER
TECHNICAL AND SUBSTANTIVE
FEEDBACK TO AID US AS WE WILL
ALL TOGETHER CONSIDER THESE
INVESTMENTS. IN THE ENTRANCE OF
STRENGTHENING THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICE APPROACH TO COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS. HUMAN SERVICE
INVESTMENTS ARE ABSOLUTELY PART
OF THE ANSWER. IF THE
INVESTMENTS ARE GENUINE AND
GENEROUS. I HOPE WE CAN PLACE
OUR COLLECTIVE INTENTION IN
THAT DIRECTION AS WE HEAR ABOUT
WAYS TO BUILD UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR FIRST
PANEL TO PLEASE COME TO THE
WITNESS TABLE FOR ISSUE ONE THE
UPDATE ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AND THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
SUBCOMMITTEE REPORT. THANK YOU.
AND IF I CAN I DON'T KNOW IF
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO FORMALLY CAN
GRADUALLY YOU IN YOUR NEW ROLE
AS DIRECTOR OF. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING BUT IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
YOU CAN GOING AWAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOMEONE NUMBER. CHECK
AGAIN WITH AN UPDATE ON THE
MASTER PLAN PROJECT YES PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT WARM
INTRODUCTION BOTH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND FOR THE MASTER
PLAN. I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE OUR PROGRESS WHICH
WAS JUST RELEASED IN A PROGRESS
REPORT FOR THE SPRING- LAST
WEEK AND CONTINUES TO BE
UPDATED AS WE GET MORE FEEDBACK
FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS. BUT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL WE BEGAN IN JUNE
WITH THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
HAD BOTH ARE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN OUR
CABINET WORK GROUP IN OUR
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGN
TOGETHER WE ENGAGE LAUNCH.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING AND
LISTENING AND COMMUNITY ROUND
TABLING. AND WEDNESDAY WHETHER
DURING- FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND
WE JUST HAD OUR FIRST MILESTONE
OF OUR FIRST SET OF STAKEHOLDER
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ABOUT TO BE
FORMALLY SUBMITTED- HAVING TO
DO WITH OUR FIRST GOAL. THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ALLOW US
ALL TO LIVE IN THE HOMES OF OUR
CHOICE. AS LONG AS WE CAN. AND
MAY WILL BE A SECOND SET. UP
EVEN MORE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HEALTHY AGING. WILL DOUBLE
COMMUNITIES PURPOSE. ECONOMIC
SECURITY SAFETY. AND DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. AND THEN. WILL
HELP FIND BIG PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
ON HALL VERGE ON HALL. GUEST
GET THE ANTI A FINE AND-
TOWARDS TOBER WE SAID. THE
EMERGENCE YOUR SECOND SAYS.
I'LL FOCUS NOT JUST ON. FIRST
SET THEIR MORE OF AGING AND
LIVING LAW. BUT HOW MUCH AGING
CHANGING. ARE BOTH OF THE-
NATURE OF A IS MORE. UP
RACIALLY NOT DIVERSE CAN ARE
OUR AGE. THE GROWING POVERTY
AND RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. THE A
LIVING ALONE MORE OF US ARE
LIVING ALONE FOR A VARIETY. OF
REASONS AS WE AGE. IN ORDER TO
LIVE. MANY MAY YEARS A AGING
SIXTY SEVENTY A NINETY. ALL
LOOKS DIFFERENT FOR OURSELVES
AND OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. SO WE'RE LEARNING
A LOT WE'RE HEARING ABOUT
PRIORITY TOPICS GOD NO SURPRISE
HERE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ARE AMONG THE TOP PRIORITY.
THIS IS WHEN THE FASTEST
GROWING POPULATIONS
EXPERIENCING HOUSING IN
SECURITY AND IN FACT
HOMELESSNESS. LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
ISOLATION RECENTLY A PROBLEM-
LEADING TO DEPRESSION AND
ROUTED ALSO IN AGEISM EXCLUSION
ISM. HOW DO YOU CYNICAL ACT
SADLY FINANCIAL EXPLOITATION-
AS WELL AS WHAT'S- BEEN CALLED
SELF NEGLECT BUT REALLY IS
ABOUT A LACK OF ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT. AND THEN
OF COURSE UNFORTUNATELY
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS THAT WITH THE
PANDEMIC WORK EXPERIENCING SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES AS WELL. THAT'S
SAID LOTS OF CALIFORNIA VALUES
AND STRENGTH COMING THROUGH OUR
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY. OF A LOT
OF EXCITEMENT AROUND
INTERGENERATIONAL OF THIS
MORNING I WAS ON A CALL ABOUT
GRANDPARENT CAMPING TRIP SALUTE
THE WORD CRAMPING WHICH IS MY
FAVORITE WORD OF THE DAY-
TECHNOLOGY- LOTS A LOTS OF
OPTIONS FOR HOW TECHNOLOGIES
DISRUPTING AGING. AND BIG
IMPACTS ON- OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
WORK FORCE TO SO MANY CROSS
SECTOR CONVERSATIONS I WOULDN'T
WANT TO ALSO JUST SAY A REALLY
IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIP IS THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON HOUSE
MEMBERS IN ALL DIMENSIONS.
GIVEN THAT COGNITIVE HEALTH
WHETHER IT IS. DEMENTIA RELATED
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
INCREASING AND REALLY
DEVASTATING- SITUATION FOR SO
MANY OF US IN OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. ABOUT TO KEEP
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL- FINALLY
I'LL JUST SAY THAT ALL OF THIS
REDUCE REQUIRED US. CD IN OUR
NETWORK OF YOUR PLACE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT OURSELVES AND TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE READY FOR THE FUTURE
AND DO SOME TRANSFORMATION SO
CDA IS. ALMOST FINISHED WITH
OUR OWN STRATEGIC PLAN
INCLUDING. BROADENING OUR
VISION OUR PARTNERSHIPS ARE
LEADERSHIP- AND OUR- ON OUR
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS IT
WILL BE KICKING OFF WITH THEM
VERY SOON WHAT WORK.
TENTATIVELY CALLING TRIPLE A
TWO POINT NO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR TRIPLE A.'S ARE SUPPORTED
AND NETWORKED AND STRENGTHENED
INALL THE WAYS NECESSARY TO
LEAD THIS WORK FOR THE NEXT
DECADE AND TO COME. GREAT THANK
YOU- NEXT WE HAVE THE SKIN
FOUNDATION. IT'S INTRODUCED
HERSELF AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY
NAME IS SERRA STEEN HAUSEN I'M
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER WITH THE
SCAN FOUNDATION AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF THE L. TSS SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS AND OF THE REPORT. THE
OUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS
REPRESENTED BY A VERY DIVERSE
GROUP OF CONSUMERS L. TSS
PROVIDERS ADVOCATES IN CARE
GIVERS. AND OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE BEEN
TASKED WITH DEVELOPING A ROOF
REPORT THAT REFLECTS THE VIEWS
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND EXAMINES THE CHALLENGES
WHILE IDENTIFYING THE POLICY
OPPORTUNITIES RELATIVE TO OUR
STATES L. TSS SYSTEM. THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THE SUB COMMITTEE
EXAMINED HOW THE SYSTEM IS AND
ISN'T WORKING FOR OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES CARE
GIVERS AND FAMILIES AND HOW WE
MIGHT BUILD A STRONG FOUNDATION
PURPOSE FOR A PERSON CENTERED
SYSTEM OF CARE THAT ENSURES
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN LIVE
WHERE THEY CHOOSE AND WITH THE
NECESSARY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THEY NEED. IN SO DOING ALL OF
THAT THE REPORT IDENTIFIES FIVE
KEY OBJECTIVES. THE FIRST
OBJECTIVES AND ALL OF THESE CAN
BE FOUND ON PAGE TWELVE TO
THIRTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA- THE
FIRST OBJECTIVE IS A SYSTEM
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
EASILY NAVIGATE. THE SECOND
OBJECTIVE IS ACCESS TO L. T. S.
AS IN EVERY COMMUNITY. THE
THIRD OBJECTIVE IS
AFFORDABILITY AND AFFORDABLE L.
TSS CHOICES WITH A FUNDING
STREAM THAT ENSURES THOSE
CHOICES ARE MATT. FOURTH A
HIGHLY VALUED AND HIGH QUALITY
WORK FORCE. AND THE FIFTH
OBJECTIVE IS STREAMLINED STATE
AND LOCAL ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURES. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FEELS THAT THESE FIVE
OBJECTIVES ARE ALL CRITICAL TO
MEETING THE POPULATIONS L. TSS
NEEDS SO EACH OBJECTIVE IS
INTERDEPENDENT AND NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S VISION. THE
REPORT PROVIDES A BROAD TEN
YOUR VISION FOR L. TSS IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE MAKING CONCUR
CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD WITH TO
LOOK TO THAT VISION. AND WHILE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS REPRESENT
LONGER START TERM STRATEGIES-
OTHERS CAN BE ACTED UPON IN THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE. SO
RECOGNIZING THE M. URGENCY FOR
ACTION AND THE NEED TO START
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES NOW THE
SUBCOMMITTEE EIGHT IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
ARE RIGHT FOR ACTION. AND
SYSTEM WIDE INVESTMENTS WHICH
WE HOPE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONSIDER
FOR THIS YEAR. THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HELLO. HELLO HAN ONE TO PUT IN
THE FINANCE- NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD THANK. CHECK YOUR BREASTS
ALLEGE THE BALLAST OFFICE- WE
HAVE BEEN ATTENDING THE VARIOUS
MEETINGS FOR THE MASTER PLAN
ON- FOR AGING AND AS MORE
INFORMATION- IS BEING RELEASED
LIKE THE LTO SO SUBCOMMITTEE
REPORT THAT SHOULD BE RELEASED-
SOMETIME THIS MONTH WILL MAKE
SURE TO MONITOR REVIEW THAT. TO
HOPEFULLY THEN GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CURRENT
AND POSSIBLY FUTURE BUDGET
PROPOSALS LIKE KELLY THE
OTHERS- A LINE AND WILL
ULTIMATELY FURTHER ON THE
VISION ARTICULATED IN THE
MASTER PLAN. THANK YOU OF WITH
THAT E WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE. JEFF
HARDY KIA- ADVOCATE- KERA OWL
OTHER ISSUES THROUGH HERE AS I
SAID AT THE FIRST MEETING AND
ARE YOU JUST MISSED THE LAST
MASTER PLAN MEETING- THROUGH
THE IN MAINTAINING A WATCHING
THESE THINGS THE THING I WILL
OFFER TO YOU IS THIS IS IT'S
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW THAT YOU
NEED TO KNOW AND WITH A LESS
THAN BASICALLY HAPPEN MILLION
SENIORS. THAT ARE YOU USING
SERVICES WHEN YOU HAVE MORE
THAN TWO OR THREE YOU HAVE NO
TEN MILLION THAT YOU'RE LIKELY
TO EXPECT WITHIN TEN YEARS- YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT THE OTHER
THINGS CLIMATE AND OTHER
INVOLVEMENTS- THINGS THAT ARE
NOT CONSIDERED WITH THESE
PEOPLE THIRTY FIVE PEOPLE IN
THE OTHERS HAVE DONE IS LIKE A
SURGEON AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
THEY CAN RECOMMEND YOU DO THE
THINGS THAT THEY KNOW. BUT IF
YOU'VE TALKED TO A CONSUMER
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE TINGS
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW WHY CALL
HAVING TO RELOCATE BECAUSE OF
HOUSING COSTS TO GET CARE
GIVERS AND OTHER THINGS TO HELP
THEM OUT BECAUSE THEY CAN NO
LONGER LIVE IN THE SITUATION
CURRENT LIVING. AND GET THE
SERVICES THAT THEY- MUCH LESS
WHAT TEMPERATURE GO. FIVE OR
TEN DEGREES. THE OTHER FACTORS
THAT WILL INVERSELY IMPACT
SENIORS. THANK YOU SIR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FRED MADE ON
BEHALF OF CAL PACE UP PACE HAS-
REPRESENTATIVES ON BOTH THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND ON THE
LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
ADVISORY COMMISSION HI AND
WE'RE- QUITE IMPRESSED WITH
WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION- AND
THAT TASK FORCE HAVE BEEN GOING
FOR PARTICULARLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE LONG TERM
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES- SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS OF WHICH WE'VE
BEEN VERY. INVOLVED IN AND
THINK THAT THEY WILL BE A VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US SENIORS IN THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTY EMOTO
FAMILY MEMBER MY OLDER SISTER
LANA HAD DEVELOPMENT- AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES RECEIVE
MEDICAL HOME CARE REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES SO MY FAMILY
KNOWS WHAT IT MEANS- WHEN THE
STATE ACTUALLY REACHES OUT. AND
ENGAGES WITH WITH THE FAMILIES
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND OTHERS. IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE MASTER PLAN HAS DONE THAT
AND IT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT THE LEADERSHIP OF
DIRECTOR MCCOY WAIT. AND I I'M
A MEMBER OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ACTION THE RESEARCH AND LONG
TERM SERVICES- SUBCOMMITTEE
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN MY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS WORKING AS A
STATEWIDE ADVOCATE WORK ON
ANYTHING LIKE THIS THAT HAS
BEEN IS FAST PACED. BEEN
INCLUSIVE AND ACTUALLY FOCUSED-
ON MAKING THE FINAL WORK
PRODUCT THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
BE PERSON CENTERED TO BE
MEANINGFUL TO THE FAMILIES TO
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED DESPERATELY
NEED TO SERVICES AND THE
PROVIDERS. SO UP I GUESS THE
KEY QUESTION NOW IS THAT THIS
IS A MOVIE IS JUST A BEGINNING
MIDDLE BUT IS DEFINITELY NOT
THE END THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THAT COUNTIES HAVE A VERY
CRITICAL ROLE IN CARING FOR
AGING POPULATION FROM THE
MINISTRY IN PROGRAMS ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE TO COORDINATING
SERVICES TO PLANNING AGE
FRIENDLY COMMUNITIES AND JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES
COUNTIES HAVE HAD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS
FROM MEMBERSHIP ON THE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES TO. A PRESENTATIONS
AT MEETINGS ANTICIPATION THE
WEAPON ARE WEDNESDAY'S- I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND THE DIRECTOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP OF THIS
EFFORT IN THE LCS AS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR. ME SOME VERY
AMBITIOUS DEADLINES- IT'S BEEN
GREAT TO BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE TO COME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU HI CHRISTINE
ABBAS HAMILTON WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS APPS BE
REPRESENTING I JUST AS
PROVIDERS. TOTALLY REITERATING
EVERY ACCOMMODATION THAT HAS
BEEN SAID SO FAR DIRECTOR
MCCAULEY WEIGHT HAS JUST BEEN
STELLAR. US STARE CERRO- STEEN
HOUSING WITH THE SKIN
FOUNDATION I'VE BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR MANY YEARS THIS
HAS BEEN A VERY LEGITIMATE AND
MEANINGFUL PROCESS AND SOON THE
TIME WILL COME WHERE THE BURDEN
WILL FALL ON THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO ITS- DUTY TO TELL THE
GOVERNOR THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
NEED TO BE ENACTED YOU KNOW WE
HAVE DONE OUR SIDE OF PUTTING
THEM TOGETHER. AND THEN WE GOT
TO DO THE HARD WORK OF ACTUALLY
GETTING THEM FUNDED AND
ENACTED- BUT I WAS ASKED BY
SOME A SENIOR'S GROUP THAT
DIDN'T WANT TO SEND FOLKS HERE
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE COLOR RED-
IT. SITUATION I WAS ASKED TO
SHARE STORIES BUT I'M JUST
GONNA PICK ONE- THIS IS ISABEL
FROM BOULDER CREEK CALIFORNIA
WHO IS A FAMILY CARE GIVER FOR
HER FATHER. MY LOVE IS MY
GARDEN BUT I DON'T SPEND MUCH
TIME THERE THESE DAYS SAYS
ISABEL WHO HAS BEEN THE MAIN
PERSON PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR
HER FATHER JACK. DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S FOUR YEARS AGO.
ISABEL COOKS CLEANS TRACKS
FINANCES DRIVES IN A COMPANIES
JACK TO MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS.
JACK'S MIDDLE CLASS SAVINGS ARE
ALL BUT DEPLETED BY MEDICAL
COSTS TO THE POINT WHERE HE NOW
QUALIFIES FOR MEDI CAL AND I
JUST US. IN SPITE OF THIS
SUPPORT ISABEL AND HER TWO
SIBLINGS ARE STILL CONTRIBUTING
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED A MONTH EACH
TO HELP COVER JACK'S HOUSE
PAYMENTS FOOD MEDICINE AND
OTHER COSTS. BEING HIS PRIMARY
CARE MANAGER ISABEL HAS LOST
HER FULL TIME JOB AND IS NOW
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW SHE'S
GOING TO SAVE FOR HER OWN
RETIREMENT. WITHOUT THE
INCREASE WITH THE INCREASED
COST CARING FOR HER FATHER
ISABEL SHARES MY HUSBAND SAYS I
WORRY ABOUT YOU ISABEL BECAUSE
HE SEES HOW MUCH TIME. I PUT
INTO CARING FOR MY FATHER AND
HOW LITTLE TIME I GIVE TO
MYSELF. A UNIVERSAL LONG TERM
CARE SOCIAL INSURANCE PROGRAM
WOULD HELP COVER JACK'S DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND FREE IS A
BILL UP. TO HOLD A FULL TIME
JOB AND START SAVING FOR HER
RETIREMENT THAT'S ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN IN THE
REPORT THAT IS GOING TO BE
ISSUED- SOON. AND SO WE HAVE
STORIES OF MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BECOMING
IMPOVERISHED BY THE SYSTEM AND
WE JUST WANT TO RAISE THESE TO
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON IN A WIDER
HARD WELL WITH A. R. P.
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN HONORED
AND PRIVILEGED TO BE PART OF
THE MASTER PLAN PROCESS. I'M ON
BOTH THE- TSS SUBCOMMITTEE THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
SO I WANT TO ECHO. THE COMMENTS
OF SOME OF OUR PARTNERS THIS
NOT ONLY HAS BEEN INCLUSIVE.
THE LISTENING. AND THE ABILITY
TO TAKE FEEDBACK ON THE FLY
LIKE ON TODAY'S WEAPON ON
WEDNESDAY. HAS BEEN BEYOND
ABOVE AND BEYOND ANYTHING THAT
I'VE EVER OBSERVED IN MY TWENTY
OR SO YEARS HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
SO THANK YOU DIRECTOR WAYNE AND
I ALSO WANT TO ECHO- WITH
CHRISTINA SAID. ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THIS REPORT WHICH YOU
ALL WILL SEE. WAS A TREMENDOUS
LABOR OF LOVE PUT TOGETHER BY.
SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS. THAT
THESE. RECOMMENDATIONS REALLY
COME TO FRUITION THAT WE FIND A
WAY TO BE CREATIVE. AND ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AND GET THIS DONE
AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES. AS LONG AS NECESSARY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BECOMES
TRULY A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. MY
NAME IS FRANCIS SMITH I'M ONE
OF THE BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR SCHEDULING THIS
HEARING AND LISTENING TO IS AND
IT'S TRUE CHEMICALLY WAY IS A
BLESSING TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA
FOR HOW SHE CARES FOR ALL OF US
AND SIR WE'VE WORKED WITH YOU
FOR MANY YEARS. I WANT TO TELL
YOU WHY I THINK LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT WE ALL HAVE OUR
PERSONAL STORIES MY FIRST CHILD
WAS BORN WITH A LOT OF CEREBRAL
PALSY MY THIRD CHILD WAS BORN
WITH A MODERATE AMOUNT OF
CEREBRAL PALSY I DIDN'T WANT
PITY I DIDN'T WANT ANYBODY TO
PITY THEM I WANTED THEM TO GROW
UP AND BE AS INDEPENDENT AS
POSSIBLE. AND WE WERE ON A PATH
TO THAT. AND THEN POWER
WHEELCHAIRS CAME INTO VOGUE IN
WHEN THEY WERE TEENAGERS. THEY
COULD TAKE THEMSELVES WHERE
THEY WANTED TO GO. WHEN THEY
WERE OLDER ADULTS THEY COULD
LIVE WHERE THEY WANTED TO WITH
AYE HSS SUPPORT. THEY HAD. THE
CARE PROVIDERS THEY HIRED. THE
I. H. AS THE SYSTEM WORKED VERY
WELL FOR THEM WE NEED IT TO
WORK WELL FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABOVE- LOW INCOME NOW. I ALSO
HAVE A PROFESSIONAL SIDE TO
THIS FOR SEVEN YEARS. EXCUSE ME
FOR EIGHT YEARS I WAS THE
MANAGER OF THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND FOR
NINE YEARS I WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY IN YOLO
COUNTY SO I KNOW FIRST HAND.
WHAT THE PROVIDERS DO FOR
PEOPLE. I KNOW THE LIMITED
WAGES THEY HAVE WE NEED MORE
PROVIDERS THEY NEED DECENT
INCOMES AND WE HAVE THIS HUGE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ABOVE
THE LOW INCOME WHO NEED THESE
SAME SERVICES AND SUPPORTS SO I
URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THEM IN
YOUR MASTER PLAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
LISA COLEMAN WITH CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION CHALCO AYE HAS HAD
THE FORTUNATE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE ON
MORE THAN A FEW YEARS IN A ROW.
AND WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS EFFORTS WE ARE. WE ARE IN
COURAGE AND EXCITED BY THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- GAS THE
DIRECTOR IS THE ENERGIZER BUNNY
SHE IS EVERYWHERE MEETING WITH
EVERYONE AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU NEEDED- FOR A LONG
TIME I'VE- REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. AS THAT
DEPARTMENT THAT CARRIES THE
CROWN IT'S AN AMAZING TITLE.
ALL PROGRAMS RELATING TO THOSE
THAT ARE AGING AND DISABLED AND
YET WITHOUT BUDGET THAT'S A
CROWN THAT HAS NO SCEPTER. AND
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU. WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE CREATIVE. I
KNOW- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY IT BEFORE WE
PAY FOR THE SERVICES ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER LET'S GET CREATIVE AND
PAY FOR DIGNITY AND CARE UP
FRONT INSTEAD OF PREVENTION
AND- PUTTING PEOPLE BACK
TOGETHER AT THE END AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS PLAN CAN DO
IT. GO TEAM. THANK YOU MA'AM.
CAROL SOURCE CENTER CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING I ECHO WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE SAYS ABOUT
COMMENDATIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT I ALSO WANT TO
COMMENDED LAW L. TSST COLORED
VISOR COMMITTEE WHO DID THE
MOST AMAZING WORK OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS- THE
COMMISSION'S BEEN VERY INVOLVED
IN THE MASTER PLAN WORK WE HAVE
MEMBERS ON BOTH THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE L. TSS SUBCOMMITTEE WE'RE
VERY PLEASED THAT MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE PUT FORTH
WERE ADOPTED IN THE L. TSS
REPORT. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU MA'AM. MR CHECKER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
TO HAD- REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER- GROUP AND-
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WHERE- I WILL
PILE ON AS WELL AND RECOGNIZE-
THE DIRECTOR AND HER TEAM FOR
ALL OF THE EFFORTS THAT THEY
DID LEADING THIS THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE NEXT STEPS ON
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. HI MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- FIRST OF ALL THIS
CHAIR ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. THAT I
WOULD NOT NOW NOT JUST NOW BUT
IN THE IN THE PAST- AND I GUESS
THE MESSAGE WE WOULD LIKE TO
DELIVER IS THAT DURING THIS
COURSE OF THIS BUDGET YEAR. YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND SO
THIS IS LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN TO
ENACT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT TO THE FALL. WE CAN
START DOING SOME OF THIS NOW
AND WE WOULD URGE YOU TO HAVE
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE. THANK
YOU SIR. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
HAVE ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA. I'M REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST AND
ENGAGE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS-
DEFINITELY ONE LIKE TO THINK
THE DIRECTOR FOR ALL YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED WORKING
WITH YOU OFF. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROBERT COLLIDE LONG TO THAT
DOCTOR. THIS BILL IF YOU'RE
RIGHTS GROUP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND THE POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN
WITH MORE NATIONAL GROUP. YOU
CAN HAVE THE BEST PLAN THE
WORLD. BUT IF YOU DON'T
PROPERLY FUND THAT WOULD COULD.
BURN THE PROGRAM THEN THE
FUNDING THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
SUB COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. I'M I'M A START
IF I CAN WITH YOU DIRECTOR
MCCOY WADE- JUST GENERALLY WHAT
KINDS OF SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS
ARE RISING AS A HIGHER
PRIORITY. GIVEN THAT THERE ARE
PRESSURES WITHIN THE AGING
COMMUNITY AND OUR DEMOGRAPHIC
PROJECTIONS. THE BOOK THANK YOU
ARE THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN- WHAT ONE OF
OUR RULES OF DATING APARTMENTS
TO BE THAT PERSON CENTERED
FOCUS ACROSS MULTIPLE SYSTEMS
SO IS CLEARLY THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR- UP ALL OF US AS
WE AGE WHICH ARE AT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES AND SOCIAL SERVICES AN
AGING. OF THE NEED FOR MORE
PERSON CENTERED CARE SO THAT
THOSE SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
EVERY COUNTY AND THEY'RE
AFFORDABLE- IS CLEARLY. IN PART
BECAUSE THIS REPORT WAS DUE
FIRST HAS COME UP LOUD AND
CLEAR BUT IN PART BECAUSE IT'S
A REAL CRISIS WE HEAR IT EVERY
FORUM OF PEOPLE WITH A TERRIBLE
CHOICES IN TERRIBLE OUTCOMES
AND SO THAT NO DOUBT I'D SAY ON
THE THREE OTHER ONES THAT ARE.
VERY STRIKING OR AGAIN THE VIEW
CYNICAL ACT- BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE FINANCIAL EXPLOITATION
OFTEN- FAMILY OFTEN ONLINE
OFTEN HOME IMPROVEMENT AND THEN
AGAIN I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
THIS TERM OF SELF NEGLECT
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS THAT
SOUNDS LIKE THE PERSON'S
HARMING THEMSELVES WHEN IN FACT
WHAT IT IS A LACK OF RESOURCES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RESOURCES
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. SO THOSE
ARE VERY CONCERNING TO ME THOSE
URGENT CASES- WERE ALWAYS
KEEPING OUR MIND ON EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE FOR
ACCESSAND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
WHETHER ITS FIRES EARTHQUAKES
POWERSHOT OFFICE I'M WORKING
WITH YES THERE'S MORE WE NEED
TO DO TO HELP US ALL PREPARED-
YOU KNOW IMAGINING HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE ACTIVATION ORDER
WHEN YOU NO LONGER CAN DRIVE
WHAT IS A REAL PLAN FOR THAT
AND GIVEN THE RISK OF FIDELITY
IS WITH OLDER ADULTS. AND THEN
I THINK WE'RE ALL WRESTLING
WITH THIS NOTION OF WHAT YOU
CALL ISOLATION OR AGEISM. BUT
THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOT FULLY
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WE AGE AND WE ARE EXCLUDED FROM
WORK OR FROM PUBLIC SPACES ARE
LEADS TO ALL KINDS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. IMPACT AND
SO. RANGING FROM THE PRESS ALL
THROUGH TO. RISING SO. RATES
AMONG OLDER ADULTS. AND SO WHEN
YOU THOSE ARE ALL. PERSON
CENTERED- CRISES THAT REQUIRE
ALL OF US TO COME TOGETHER IN
NEW WAYS SO WE HAVE NEW EFFORTS
ON L. TSS WE HAVE NEW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TASK FORCE WE
HAVE. BETTER THAN EVER
EMERGENCY COORDINATION. I'LL
BUT CLEARLY THERE'S MORE TO DO
SO ALL OF THOSE POINTS. AND
THEN AND I WOULD JUST A CROSS
CUTTING. IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
INCREASING COGNITIVE ISSUES IS
STRAINING ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS.
THE NONE OF OUR SYSTEMS WELL
WE'RE REALLY BUILT FOR HIGH
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA
IS AND COGNITIVE HEALTH. AND SO
HOW ARE WE GOING TO- HAVE THE
SPACES IN THE PLACES ON THE
WORK FORCE AND THE CARE GIVING
AND THE AND THE MONEY. TO CARE
FOR ALL OF US AS WE AGE AND
EXPERIENCE- AND OF COURSE
pWELL. BUT I THINK THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE MOST- HEARTBREAKING
AN URGENT ISSUES THAT I HEAR
WHEN I'M AROUND THE STATE-
DIRECTOR MCCOY WAY DO YOU SEE
ANY CHANGES TO AYE HSS WITH THE
MASTER PLAN. UPDATE WELL I
WOULD CERTAINLY DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT CDS OUT TO RUN
THAT PROGRAM AND CONDUCTED. A
REALLY WONDERFUL SO ASSET OF
LISTENING SESSIONS AROUND THE
STATE AND HEARD LOTS AND LOTS
OF. YOU KNOW STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS CROWN JEWEL OF OUR HOME
CAN BE BASED SERVICES- AND THEN
ALSO SOME OF THE SAME PRESSURES
PRESSURES ON THE WORK FORCE.
PRESSURES ON THE CHANGING%
POPULATION- YOU KNOW I THINK
WAS SO INTERESTING THAT WHAT
SESSIONS WITH A NUMBER THE
GROWTH OF CHILDREN. I TEST
PROGRAM. PROGRAM HAS BECOME. TO
SUCH PERSON. PEOPLE THAT WAS
DEFINITELY HOW TOPIC IN A- AM
GLAD I JUST IS ON THE IN THE
LATER FOR CDS US. ADDRESS WELL
I WOULD BE REMISS NOT TO. THANK
pOF OUR SENIORS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AS THAT
WILL. ALSO HAVE AN EFFECT
WITHIN OUR HSS POPULATIONS AND-
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED FOR MANY OF OUR
SUCCESSES WILL HAVE. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CARED FOR AS
WELL WHERE THEY STAND SO- WITH
THAT IF I CAN FOR- SERRA. SERRA
PLEASE. ANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OR OBJECTIONS
WITHIN YOUR L. TSS REPORT WHICH
NEED TO BE FAST TRACKED- GIVEN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM GAPS. SO I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
GIVEN A LOT OF THOUGHT ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT HOW THEY
NEED TO REALLY LOOK ACROSS THE
FIVE OBJECTIVES AND- ADDRESS
THE PRIORITIES AND THE MORE THE
IMMEDIATE ACTION ITEMS WITH IN
EACH OF THOSE SO. MORE
SPECIFICALLY THERE IS A CHART
HERE THIRTY SEVEN IMMEDIATE
ACTION ITEMS THAT CAN BE ACTED
ON AND- I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S REALLY NOT A LEVEL OF
IMPORTANCE THAT HAS BEEN SUCH A
SIGN TO EACH BUT THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUES IS RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
GET THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO MAKE DECISIONS. THAT'S WHAT
THE ISSUE BUT ONE IF THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT INFORMATION THEY
CAN'T ACCESS THE SUPPORTS THEY
NEED SO WE HAVE MANY AREAS IN
THE STATE WE A LACK OF
SERVICES. SO PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN
GET WHAT THEY NEED IF THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT INFORMATION BUT THEN
THIRD AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED AS
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO. THERE
RUSHED AND IF WE ARE FOURTH WE
A TRUE WORK FORCE CHALLENGE
WITH THE WE FOCUSED ON THE
DIRECT CARE WORK FORCE SO WAYS
TO INCREASE THE LABOR SUPPLY
AND HOT WITH HIGH QUALITY JOBS
BUT THEN ALSO IMPORTANTLY I'M
KIND OF OVER ARCHING ALL THIS
IS THE NEED FOR LEADERSHIP AND
THAT ALIGNS WITH KIND OF
LOOKING AT BETTER WAYS TO
STREAMLINE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL- AND A LOT OF WITH
THOSE CATEGORIES THERE ARE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CAN BE ACTED ON NOW EITHER
THROUGH THE BUDGET OR THROUGH
LEGISLATION. OR THROUGH
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION. SO WELL
TO. ANY OF THOSE WITH YOU AND-
AS YOU NEED- I BELIEVE WE WILL
FOLLOW UP SPECIFICALLY AS THEY
REGARD TO THE BUDGET AND I KNOW
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR A NUMBER
OF THE PROPOSALS LATER TODAY
AND SO. INPUT YOU CAN GIVE FORM
WHAT IS LIMITED RESOURCES
ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
WONDERFUL- AGAIN NO IT'S NICE
HAVING A NEW DIRECTOR AND AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT'S LEANING
AND ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE-
AND REALLY WAS. FINE THIS AS A
VERY HELPFUL UPDATE- AS IT
OFFERS US AN IMPORTANT CONTEXT.
AS WE HEAR WHAT IS THE BALANCE
OF THE AGENDA FOR THE REMAINDER
OF TODAY. I DO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION THE PLEASE KEEP
US ABREAST AND INCLUDED. AS WE
PROGRESS AND MOVE FORWARD OR
TALKED OVER FOR. REPORT HAS.
CHANGED OUR- ALMOST DAILY NOW
WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT OF AGING
SO. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE WILL OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TOO AT THAT SEE
PROPOSALS. AND I MATH THE
SERGEANTS THE CALLED MEMBERS
TO. I'M ARE PRESENT PLEASE
PROPOSALS. SINCE WE HAVE A
MOMENT I WILL ALSO ASK THAT WAS
TERRIBLE SCORN. DR RABIL
PRESENT FRAZIER. MATHIS
PATTERSON. RAMOS. RUBIO DOCTOR
WOULD.
WE MAY CALL WENDY
PETERSON FORWARD IF SHE'S HERE.
THANK. OUT OF ALL NOW THAT
SHE'S COMMISSION. CAN HEARING
IS ON ITS WAY RIGHT NOW. MISS
PETERSON I LEAVE IT UP TO YOU-
WE CAN EITHER HAVE YOU PRESENT
AND JOINED BY POWER CAN OR WE
MAY HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY AND PRESENT NOW
WHICHEVER YOU FEEL. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO DO. I BEAT- THANKS- I'D
BE REALLY HAPPY TO LET ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MYSTERIANS GO- WE HAVE
SUCH A CHAMPION IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. REBEKAH BAUER CAME HOME
THAT WE WOULD I WOULD LOVE TO
BE SITTING HERE WITH HER
PERFECT SO. TO COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON.
SO WE'RE STARTING
OUT WITH. LETTERS BY EIGHTY ARE
SEIZE YES OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- EIGHTY RC
MODEL IS SOMETHING I'VE
CHAMPION AND IS ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES RECOMMENDED IN THE
DRAFT MASTER PLAN FOR AGING ADR
SEES ALLOW OLDER CALIFORNIANS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THEY NEED WHEN NEEDED- THIS
FUNDING ALLOW SKI WHITE
EXPANSION OF THE E. D. R. C.
PROGRAM GETTING TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION IS
CRITICAL TO. AVOIDING COSTLY
INSTITUTIONAL CARE THIS FUNDING
ALLOWS THE EXPANSION OF THE
EIGHT YEARS HE TO ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES- THE REQUEST
PROVIDES FOR A THREE PHASE AND
WITH ME IS CLAY C<c.cyan> SECULAR</c>
DIRECTOR OF SENIOR. A CASTLE OF
SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES. SIR JUST A INTO THAT-
I ALSO THANKS FOR LETTING ME BE
HERE- IN ADDITION TO MY ROLE
I'M ALSO- LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR
FOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING. AND A
MEMBER OF THE- MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY.
COMMITTEE SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT SERRA STEAM HOUSING
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
LOW HANGING FRUIT AN IMMEDIATE
ACTION IS. THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
AND THE STORY I LIKE TO TELL
ABOUT THIS IS YOU KNOW WE
REALLY NEED A RIDE NO WRONG
DOOR SYSTEM IN OUR STATE WE
NEED A WAY FOR PEOPLE TO FIND
WHERE TO GET SERVICES WHEN THEY
NEED THEM IF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GET THE SERVICES THEY
REALLY DON'T EXIST. SO THE GOAL
BEHIND A. B. R. C.'S IS TO DO A
NO WRONG DOOR APPROACH WHERE
YOU TYPICALLY HAVE A
DESIGNATED. MAIN ENTRANCE POINT
BUT YOU PARTNER REALLY CLOSELY
WITH THE KEY ORGANIZATIONS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY SO EACH AND KNOW
ABOUT EACH OTHER AND CAN DO
EASY REFERRAL AND IMPROVE
TOWARD. TREMENDOUS PLUS THE
MOST IMPORTANT. SAID IN.
MULTIPLE THIS IS INSURED PEOPLE
SIR CAN. GET TO THEM. SO LAST
YEAR WE HAD A BILL WHICH
STARTED THIS PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND RIGHT NOW AS A
RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE SIX
FULLY OPERATIONAL- A. B. R.
C.'S IN OUR STATE AND THEN
THERE'S TEN THAT ARE EMERGING
OUR GOAL WITH THIS COMING
REQUEST IS. AS STATED TO GET
EIGHTY ARE SEIZE ALL AROUND THE
STATE SO IT'S A THREE YEAR-
PROCESS TO GET US UP TO THAT
LEVEL- YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBERS
ON HERE NINETEEN MILLION.
THIRTY MILLION AND FIFTY ONE
GOING TO GET THERE AND IF WE
DON'T DO THIS WE JUST END UP
STOP WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW SO
WE'LL HAVE TEN ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE MERGING TO BE EIGHTY
R. C.'S. BUT WITH FLAT FUNDING
BILL NEVER BECOME FULLY
OPERATIONAL OR THEY WILL BE
UNDER FUNDED WHEN THEY'RE
PERFORMING THAT ROLE SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE THOSE TAN INTO
COMPLETE OPERATING AB R. SEES.
AND THEN BRING ON ADDITIONAL
AGENCIES EACH YEAR WITH THE
PLAN TO HAVE THEM TRANSITION
FROM NOT BEING ANY PLACE AND
THEN HAVING YOU KNOW THE
EMERGING STATUS AND THEN FOR
THE- FUNDING ON. THESE PROGRAMS
ARE I REGULATION PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS AND AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING SO WE HAVE A REAL NICE
PROSPER NURSE SHIP THERE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
OLDER ADULTS. AND I JUST THINK
IT'S A MODEL PROGRAM AND HOPE
YOU CAN SUPPORT. USER ARE
DIRECTOR CALL WAY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LA ON. JUST CHECK
KNOWLEDGE EIGHTY C. IS A
PROGRAM THAT CITY A WORKS ON
MUCH VERY MUCH A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE TRIPLE A IS AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
ARE PREPARED BY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON SUCH AN EXPANSION.
THANK YOU. PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE BE. MR CHECKER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE SHE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU SIR
MARTY MOTO FAMILY MEMBERS CITY
CAN STRONG SUPPORT. THE JORDANS
OF THE OUR COMMUNITY TO PROPOSE
A CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PLEASE A COMMON WITH CAO CAO IN
SUPPORT. HYSTERICAL AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING OBVIOUSLY.
VERY SUPPORTIVE THIS IS A MAN A
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE THAT
SUPPORTIVE OF FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. THANK YOU SIR. CAROL
SOURCE LETTER CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT TOM
BRING IT UP TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS THAT WE MAY
HAVE- I DON'T SEE ANY NOW- I
WILL JUST BRIEFLY ASK YOU IF I
CAN THE LOGIC BETWEEN GOING
FROM SIX TO FIFTY EIGHT OUR IS
FIFTY EIGHT THE- APPROPRIATE
NUMBER FOR US TO BE LOOKING AT
IS THAT BASED OFF OF. THE
NUMBER OF COUNTIES THAT WE HAVE
HOW DID YOU DECIDE AND WHAT IS
THE RIGHT NUMBER AND IT IS
BASED OFF THE NUMBER OF
COUNTIES WE HAVE AND PART OF
THAT IS THE REALIZATION THAT
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE IN
OPTIONS COUNSELING. IT'S A
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT CONSUMERS BE
ABLE TO- GET HELP FROM A
TRUSTED ENTITY ONE THE NOW AND
THEN THE OTHER PART OF THAT. A
LOCAL MAN CITY HAS MUCH BETTER
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THEIR COMMUNITY INCLUDING
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE ACT TO PASS
TO BE THAT IT'S KIND OF FEUDAL
TO MAKE REFERRALS TO. I'M JUST
OUT OF MY HAND CURIOSITY AND I
CAN'T HELP MYSELF SOMETIMES
BUT- DOES ONLINE WORK IS THERE
AN ADVANTAGE TO. HAVING SOURCES
FLOW THROUGH AN ONLINE PORTAL
THAT COULD ALSO TOO SIMILAR
FUNCTIONS. ONLINE IS CERTAINLY
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF IT
BUT IT'S NOT ALL INCLUSIVE I
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS IS THE INTERACTIVE
DIALOGUE THAT A CONSUMER WILL
HAVE WITH SOMEBODY WHO'S
ASSESSING WHAT OPTIONS THEY
HAVE- WHEN NEEDS THEY HAVE FOR
CARE SO ONLINE GREAT RESOURCE
BUT LACKS THAT INTERACTIVE
COMPONENT AND OFTEN IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WE FIND WHAT THE
PERSON IS CALLING ABOUT. IS
ONLY A VERY SMALL PORTION OF
WHAT THEY REALLY NEED. GREAT
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE BE
OPEN AND IF WE MAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NECESSARY AND WE
CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. ISSUED TO SEE
EXTEND FALLS PREVENTION PROGRAM
ALSO. ALSO A SPONSORED BY C.
FOUR EIGHT. AT THE FUNDING
PROVIDES FOR A COMMUNITY BASED
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THAT
ADDRESSES CRITICAL ISSUES OF
SENIORS FALLING FUNDING
ESTABLISHED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET BECOMES ON GOING THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL- THE FUNDING
ALLOWS THE PROGRAM TO BE
EXPANDED TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES- THE PROGRAM IS BEING
CONSIDERED AS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING. AND AGAIN CLAY
KEMPF FOR MORE DETAILS. THIS
ONE IS PRETTY SELF EXPLANATORY
YOU KNOW I'M FALLS PREVENTION
AS A AS A SIMPLE CONCEPT BUT
DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT. SO IT'S
BRAND NEW FOR US RIGHT NOW BUT
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME NICE EMERGING
PARTNERS FIRST RESPONDERS FOR
EXAMPLE. OFTEN GO OUT ON CALLS
IN FACT IN SOME FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THE MAJORITY THEIR
CALLS ARE TO PICK SOMEBODY UP
WHO DOESN'T NEED TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
WORK WITH THEM TO FIND WHO THE
FREQUENT FOLLOWERS ARE AND
ASSESS WHAT'S GOING ON AN
EXAMPLE OF A SIMPLE STE GEN.
I'M YEARS AGO- WE USED TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE GRAB BARS IN
BATHROOMS HOME MODIFICATION-
THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE AS PART OF
A OUR USE OF FELT DOLLAR. THAT
AN OLD PASSED. FEDERAL FUNDS
CAN'T BE USED FOR THAT AT THIS
TIME SO WE'RE HAVING TO YOU
KNOW DEVELOP OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES AND OTHER SYSTEMS AND
THIS IS A PERFECT USE OF THAT
AND- I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
OBVIOUS HOW EFFECTIVE A GRAB
BAR CAN BE IN JUST. A FALL IN
HOSPITALS AND BROKE IT THE-
THANK YOU. PARTMINER FINAL LA
ANY COMMENTS A PUBLIC COMMEN
ON TO SEE. ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY AND MS IS A CHRONIC AND
OFTEN DISABLING DISEASE AND
OVER 50% OF PEOPLE LIVING WITH
THEM MASS FALL- BETWEEN IN A
THREE TO SIX MONTH PERIOD AND
OVER THIRTY PERCENT. ALL
MULTIPLE TIMES AT PERIOD HI
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP PROVIDE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE LIVING
WITH EN MASSE AND KEEP THEM
SAFE IN THEIR HOME AND WE URGE
YOU TO INCLUDE THIS AND BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
JEFF HARDY KIA. AND TO YOUR
PREVIOUS ONE I WOULD OFFER SAY
IS THIS YOU NEED A SOLID
INTERNET CONNECTION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR SENIORS. PUT TO
THIS AS AN EXAMPLE IS THIS I
FELT THE DATE JUST OUTSIDE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING. AND
BECAUSE OF HAVING A KAISER
PROGRAM THAT DID WITH ABOUT
FALL WOULD JUST DIDN'T PREVENT
I FELL. BUT SHOWING WHAT YOU DO
SO YOU DON'T HURT YOURSELF WHEN
THIS OCCURS IS EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT IN FALL PREVENTING
FALLS FROM OCCURRING. THANK YOU
SIR AND I'M GLAD YOU'RE OKAY.
YES KEEP THE MODEL CALIFORNIA
LINES FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
WHEN THEY CONSIDERING SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS I THINK IT'S REAL
IMPORTANT TO. TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHAT YOU'RE
SAVING BY. IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM AND WHAT YOU MAY DO
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THAT
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SIDE IS. SCORE THE
SAVINGS THERE AND FUND THE
PROGRAM SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT KIND OF RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE THESE THESE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO SAVE A
LOT A- LOT OF THE PROGRAMS
WERE- LOOK AT A SAVE A LOT OF
DOLLARS ON ONE END. MY HOPE.
WHEN YOU TO THE BUT TERRY
PROCESS YOU THINK LET'S
AUGMENTATION NO IT'S A SAVING
BECAUSE YOU LIKE WITH WHAT WAS
INDICATED BEFORE- IF- OBJECTED
TO GO THROUGH THE PROGRAM AT
KAISER UP PROBABLY A BROKE LEG
HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
WOULD HAVE COST JUST A- GO TO
THE HOSPITAL AND GO THROUGH ALL
THE TREATMENT NECESSARY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. HERE THEIR
ACCOUNT YOU CAN RECEIVE SEE FOR
A- HAVE FALLS IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE WITH OUR OLDER PEOPLE-
THE- FOLLOWING OFTEN RESULTS IN
BROKEN HIPS. PRO CAN HELP FIX-
AND THESE PEOPLE THEN HAVE TO
GO TO A NURSING HOME. AND IN
SOME CASES THEY NEVER RETURNED
BACK HOME SO PREVENTING FALLS
FOR OUR OLDER A CALIFORNIANS I
THINK IS. A REAL ISSUE FOR US
AND ONE WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU SIR. HOW MONEY
WITHDRAW RECALL MY COMPLEX HAS
ONE OF THOSE THAT BARS IN THE
BATHROOM BUT WE ALSO GOT A PULL
CHAIN THAT ALERTS THEIR
NEIGHBORS ONE DEFINITELY DOES
HAVE A BALL OR SOME OTHER KIND
OF EMERGENCY. AND THE ONLY
KNOCK ON THE DOOR DID UP THERE
STAFF WAR WE CALL NINE ONE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. HI
LISA COLEMAN WITH CHALCO WE
LOOK AT THIS IS A WORK
DETERRENT- PEOPLE THAT ARE ABLE
TO IT TO REMAIN LIVING SAFELY
IN THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
SKILLS THEY'VE LEARNED. THIS IS
YOUR OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS
WORTH A POUND OF. SOMEWHERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM SEEING
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT UP TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS- I MAY WANT TO.
ASK JUST. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
MUCH OF THE FIVE MILLION. ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM LAST YEAR IS
ALREADY GONE OUT IS THIS
PROGRAM. OVER PRESCRIBED IS
THIS. SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
AN ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDING.
FOR IS A ONE TIME APPROACH
ASIAN. IT TOO HOW MUCH IS USE
LAST YEAR. I CAN START THE
ANSWERING CLAY CAN ADD ON THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS JUST
COMPLETED ISSUING THE MONEY TO
ALL THE LOCAL PROVIDER SO I
BELIEVE LOCAL PROVIDERS ARE
JUST BEGINNING TO SPEND. SET
RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT- SO THE
FULL FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION HAS BEEN- RECALL
YESTERDAY. DO DO WE HAVE A
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MUCH ROAD
HOW MANY REQUESTS THERE WERE
AND WHETHER WHAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE NEXT STEPS THAT
TRYING TO. WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
HANDLE ON THAT BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM'S ROLLING OUT BUT I CAN
GIVE ONE EXAMPLE WHICH I
TOUCHED ON BEFORE- WE HAVE A- A
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM THAT INSTALLS
GRAB BARS LABORS FREE THEY JUST
NEED TO MATERIALS. AND THEY'RE
ALREADY- HAVE DOCUMENTED THEY
NEED A FIFTEEN THOUSAND NOW
JUST TO PURCHASE TO GRAB BARS
AND LONGER RAILS SO IT'S ONLY
ONE SMALL COMPONENT OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING BUT THE DEMAND IS
CERTAINLY THERE. WITH THAT WE
HOLD THIS CHAIR CO. AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE A DE. TO THE
INCREASING THE BASELINE
ALLOCATION FOR AREA AGENCIES-
ON AGING THERE'S SPENT MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S BEEN NO
ADJUSTMENT TO BASED ON FUNDING
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF AREA
AGENCIES FIFTY YEARS AGO.
CURRENTLY BASED ON FUNDING IS
FIFTY THOUSAND PER YEAR AND ALL
FEDERAL DOLLARS THERE IS KNOWS
THE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS FOR
BASELINE FUNDING TO ASSIST THE-
TRIPOLI'S IN ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES. I THINK THE REQUEST
WOULD BE FOR. OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. FOR EACH OF THE
THIRTY THREE TRIPLE A LOCATIONS
CENTERS. SO AN ANNUAL THREE
POINT THREE MILLION REQUEST.
THANK YOU- MR KEMP HAS A TRIPLE
A DIRECTOR- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
I'M BIASED BUT IT'S REALLY
CRITICALLY NEEDED MONEY I'M
GOING BACK FORTY YEARS I DIDN'T
GO BACK FIFTY BUT- IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY WITH FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOU COULD BUY A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF TODAY'S SERVICES. USING BY
FIGURES USING CALIFORNIA
FIGURES IT'S MORE LIKE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND SO TRYING TO PROVIDE
WHAT WE DID FORTY OR FIFTY
YEARS AGO WITH LESS THAN A
THIRD OF ACTUAL BUYING POWER
PUTS TRIPLE A.'S IN AN EXTREME-
BIND- WE'VE WE KNOW WE NEED AT
A MINIMUM TO HAVE A FISCAL
OFFICER- PLANNER CONTRACTOR- IN
MY **** PERSON AND PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WEAR MULTIPLE HATS TO DO THAT.
SO IF FIFTY THOUSAND WE CAN
MAKE A DENT IN IT- I THINK ALL
THE GREAT THINGS THAT RE
COMING OUT TO WITH MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING AND BY THE WAY ALL
JOINED THE GROUP AT GOING YOU
KNOW KIM'S PRAISES IN TERMS OF
HOW INCREDIBLE THAT HAS BEEN
BUT THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
HOW MUCH WE NEED TO DO. AND HOW
AN AGENCY DOES THAT WITH ABOUT
THIRTY PER OF THE RE TO THE A
THE OUT IT NOW VERY REALISTIC.
AND THEN IF WE HAVE UNEXPECTED
CHRIST COME BY PERHAPS THE
CORONA VIRUS WHERE WERE YOU
KNOW CHIU TO HOW IMMEDIATE TO A
CRISIS THAT ALL OUR SERVICES
ARE FACE ING THERE'S NO
RESEARCH AS WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW
STAFF THAT PORTS SO WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT MAKING THAT
TRIPLE A SYSTEM JETZT. NOT A
STRONG BUT SERVICE. AS HOW IT
WORKS DOLLARS THANK YOU SIR
DEPARTMENT OF ANSEL. COMMENTS
PUBLIC COM ON. TO I'M WENDY
PETERSON MY DIRECT THE SENIOR
SERVICES COALITION OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT OUR OF OUR CUNY IS HIGHLY
COLLABORATIVE AND THE- TRIPLE A
IS ONE OF OUR COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERS AND IF THEY ARE. IT
TAKES MONEY TO BE ABLE TO PUT
ENERGY INTO COLLABORATION- AND
WE EXPECT MORE COLLABORATION
COMING IN THE FUTURE FROM THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EATING SO WE
HIGHLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BUT QUEST. GOOD AFTERNOON THEN
LEASE A COMMON WITH CALCUTTA.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS- ARE EITHER HOUSED IN
THE TRIPLE A.'S OR CONTRACTS
WITH THE TRIPLE LAYS AND SO
HAVING THAT- CONTRACTING
EXPERTISE IN THAT BUILDING. IN
THAT ENTITY MEANS THAT THE
NUMBERS GET THAT MONEY THE
RESOURCES THAT MUCH FASTER TO
GET THE FEEL THAT MUCH FASTER
SO WE DEFINITELY NEED STRONG
TRIPOLI'S IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MA'AM. YES TERREL COACH WITH
THE HEARING AGENCIES ON AGING.
HOW WELL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE BASS LINE FUNDING IS JUST
WAS IS TO TAKE TO OPEN UP THE
DOORS. IN A CAN BE AN AGENT THE
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO FIND. HE
KNOWS KEY STAFF WHO CAN WHO CAN
AT LEAST DO THE MINIMAL PART OF
THE JOB AND WE HAVE SOME AREA
AGENCIES. IN THIS. AT LEAST. TO
HAVE THE FUNDS TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN. THANK YOU SIR. JEFF
HEARD A KIA- I'M NOT A GREAT
ONE FOR ADVERTISING FOR MORE
ADMINISTRATION BUT AT THE SAME
TIME PROTECT ME FROM THE RURAL
SITUATION. YOU NEED TO PROVIDE
AND IN THE FUTURE BETTER
SERVICES MORE SERVICES SO I
ACTIVELY SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU
SIR SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS. SEEN NOT- THIS
DOES SEEM A VERY REASONABLE
REQUEST IN LIGHT OF A MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND INCREASING
RESPONSIBILITIES ONTO MANY OF
THE TROUBLE IS AND SO I JUST DO
THINK WITH THIS WILL HAVE TO BE
A BIG PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AS WE GO FORWARD AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENCE. ON THIS. NOW
MOVES ISSUED TO E. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ESTABLISHING THE
OFFICE OF THE PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE- THANK YOU BYE.
ALZHEIMER'S AND OTHER FORMS OF
DEMENTIA ARE DISEASES WITH NO
KNOWN TREATMENT I'M SORRY.
JERRY I'M A PATIENT REPRESENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CURRENTLY
WHEN SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
PATIENTS ARE DETERMINED BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN TO LACK THE
CAPACITY TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND DO NOT HAVE
FAMILY OR FRIENDS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS FOR THEM THAN MEDICAL
DECISIONS ARE MADE BY IN THE
DISCIPLINARY TEAM MADE UP OF
NURSING STAFF AT THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AND THE
PATIENT'S PHYSICIAN CALIFORNIA
BUT OF APPEALS RECENTLY ISSUED
A DECISION UPHOLDING THAT
PROCESS BUT- THAT PROCESS BUT
CLARIFIED THAT A PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE MUST PARTICIPATE
IN THE INTERDISCIPLINARY
MEETINGS. THE COURT ALSO
PROHIBITS THESE PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BEING PAID
FOR OR EMPLOYED BY THE NURSING
FACILITY IF THERE'S NO PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE AVAILABLE
MEDICAL INTERVENTIONS CANNOT
OCCUR WITH THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY RESIDENT THE ONLY
ALTERNATIVE IS FOR THAT
RESIDENT TO GO TO A HOSPITAL
FOR THEIR CARE IT IS IMPERATIVE
THE STATE ECONOMY
RESPONSIBILITY OF A STEP. STEM
WHEREBY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES RESIDENTS THIS TWO
PIECE AND IF THAT IS PROPERLY
AND A TESTABLE TO OUR- IN THE
IN. TEAM MEETING. TODAY WITH
ONE APPROACH TO THIS. WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
TO ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE TO
FACILITATE AND TRAIN AVAILABLE
AVAILABLE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
WITHME- IS JENNIFER SNYDER- TO
ANSWER.FOR THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. JENNIFER CENTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES AND JUST TO MAKE A
COUPLE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
INFORMATION THAT HE PROVIDED
TODAY I THINK- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A- A STATUTE THAT'S BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS- THAT.
CREATES A PROCESS BY WHICH- A
GROWING NUMBER OF PATIENTS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES HAVE
THE CAPABILITY TO HAVE SOMEONE
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS FOR THEM
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A FAMILY OR FRIEND THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM WITH
THAT. AND THE COURT RULING
UPHELD THAT PROCESS- AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO KNOW THAT THAT PROCESS CAN'T
CONTINUE I AM IT'S JUST THEY
REQUIRED TO THINGS OR AT LEAST
CLARIFY THAT TWO THINGS NEED TO
HAPPEN WITHIN THAT PROCESS ONE
IS IT. THAT THERE'S CLEAR
NOTIFICATION TO THE PATIENT AND
TO THE FRONT OR FAMILY OR A
INTO DOES IT. AND ME SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PHYSICIAN
HAS DETERMINED THAT A PATIENT
IS INCAPACITATED AND THE SECOND
PART IN THE PART OF THE REASON
THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY- IS THAT
THERE. IS A CLEAR- DIRECTION
FROM THE COURT THAT IN ALL
CASES WHEN THERE IS A DECISION
MAKING PROCESS THAT HAPPENS IN
THAT DECISION MAKING PROCESS IS
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH. THOSE
MEDICAL END INCLUDING THE
PHYSICIAN AND THE MEDICAL TEAM
AT THE SCHOOL THAT SAUDI BUT
NOW THAT THERE'S A THERE NEEDS
TO BE A PATIENT REPRESENTED
PART OF THAT. THEY ARE IN A
CERTAIN MAKER THEY ARE NOT. A
QUARTER CONSERVATIVE. ISN'T IT
SYSTEM IS SET UP IN. TEAM
HEALTH IS BECAUSE- IT'S ALL
POSSIBLE. FINE AND GET THAT
DONE SO THIS IS A PREPPER THAT.
CAN'T BE PAID FOR OR AFFILIATED
WITH THE NURSING FACILITY WHICH
IS JUST FINE IT IT PROBABLY A
PROCESS SHOULD BE THERE BUT
BECAUSE OF THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
IS GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE PATIENTS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WHICH AGAIN
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES.
THERE'S SOMEBODY THAT CAN CARRY
ON THEIR GOAL FOR THEM- NEITHER
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED NOR-
MY CLIENT CODE FOR SUSPICION
HEALTH IS LEASES WENT TO THE
IDEA THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY- WE ACTUALLY FELT THAT
MAYBE THAT THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
BE IN THE OFFICE OF THE
OMBUDSMAN THAT LOW ON BUT IT'S
BEEN COULD TAKE ON THIS. I'M AT
LEAST FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND-
OF AT LEAST THE STATE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN SEEMS HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT SO WE HAVE
PROVIDED AN OPTION- THAT WE
THINK REALLY DOES FIT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING- AND-
WE ARE LOOKING FOR. DIRECTION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION- WE'VE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HELP- AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THIS DIALOGUE
WITH THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
SINCE FOR THESE TO SPEAK
THOUSAND HAVE NOT TO SPEAK FOR
THEM THANK YOU. THE FINANCE LA.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON TO HE. JEFF
STARTED YEAH APPLICANTS
HEALTHCARE OF VARIOUS OTHER BUT
I WILL ALSO OFFER IN THIS ONE
THEY SPY MUSCLE SURVIVOR SO
WHAT MEANS IN A SENSE I HAVE NO
DIRECT FAMILY TO MAKE THAT
CONNECTION SO I WILL HAVE THAT
NEED IN THE FUTURE TO SEE WHAT
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE AND I
WILL OFFER A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE
IN THIS LAST WEEK IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HAD SOMEBODY THAT
DIED. BUT THE DOCTORS WERE NOT
WILLING TO TELL THE PERSON THAT
WAS REPRESENTING THE FAMILY.
THAT INDEED THAT PERSON WAS
DYING IT TOOK OTHERS COMING IN
AND A NURSE TO SAY GET THE
FAMILY HERE HE IS GOING TO BE
DEAD WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
BUT THAT IS THE THING THAT
NEEDS TO BE TAKING CARE OF THIS
IS THAT SOMETIMES YOU KNOW FOR
PATIENT. THE CORRECT DECISION
NEED TO BE MADE AND THE CORRECT
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE ASKED
MAY NEED TO BE SOMEBODY OTHER
THAN THE MEDICAL PROFESSION. SO
THAT'S WHY THIS OFFICE NEEDS TO
GET ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
THINK HAS IS SPEND NOTED THE
COURT OF APPEAL HAS STATED THAT
THESE ARE CRITICAL POSITIONS
THAT- SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST IN THE DECISION MAKING
AND I HAD TO ADD NOT ONLY JUST
CRITICAL BUT CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED- WE EAT WE SUPPORT
THIS- PROPOSAL AND WE THINK
THAT THE APPROACH THAT'S BEEN
LAID OUT HERE NOW ALTHOUGH
THERE IS SOME OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK THROUGH THIS AND REFINE IT
IS ACTUALLY THE RIGHT ONE THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE AN OFFICE OF.
PATIENTS REPRESENTATIVES AND
WHAT THAT WILL ALLOW IS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A TRAINED AND
PROFESSIONAL GROUP THAT CAN
ACTUALLY SERVE ACROSS STRAIGHT
ACROSS THE STATE TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. THIS FEATURE MEMBERS
RAN MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA- WE
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
THIS IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS DECISION- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE I'M AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIND THE
RIGHT FIT. I'M TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THIS PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE- FOR THEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. PLAY CAM
SENIORS COUNSELLORS SANTA CRUZ
AND SAN BENITO COUNTY IS AND
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE RIGHT FIT
FOR THIS IS EITHER WHETHER THIS
IS IT OR NOT I WON'T COMMENT
TOWARDS THAT. BUT I WILL SAY
THIS IS MAYBE THE MOST FREQUENT
POLICY ISSUE. THAT LOCAL
NURSING HOMES BRING TO ME THAT
THEY HAVE SITUATIONS WITH
UNREPRESENTED ELDERLY WHO-
AREN'T CAPABLE OF MAKING
DECISIONS ON THEMSELVES AND
THEY NEED TO TAKE. ACTION IN IN
TERMS OF MEDICAL CARE AND
LEGALLY THEY CAN'T DO IT SO- I
GET THE CALL SAYING HELP ME
WHAT CAN I DO. UNFORTUNATELY
RIGHT NOW MY ANSWERS I DON'T
KNOW NOTHING. I THINK IT'S.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOE RODRIGUEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN I DO AGREE THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR AN OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE AND AS
WAS STATED EARLIER- I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM TAKING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY ON FEDERAL LAW
AND REGULATIONS- PROHIBIT ON
WAS IN PROGRAMS TO ENGAGE IN
CIRCUIT DECISION MAKING. FOR
RESIDENTS OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND WHILE THE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE ISN'T A
SURROGATE DECISION MAKER IN AND
OF HIMSELF. WHEN PAIRED WITH
THE WORK OF THE ITT THE
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM YOU ARE
ENGAGING IN CIRCUIT DECISION
MAKING FOR RESIDENTS- WE THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AGAIN. UNDER
FEDERAL REGULATIONS IS ALSO
PROHIBITED FROM RESIDING IN AN
ENTITY THAT ENGAGES CIRCUIT
DECISION MAKING FOR RESIDENTS
SO I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND I'M NOT GOING TO I'M
SPEAKING FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE LONG TERM CARE BUT IT'S
BEEN. I WOULD HAVEGRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OFFICE BEING
LOCATED IN THE SAME DEPARTMENT
THAT WERE HOUSED WITHIN. I'M
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY OTHER POSSIBILITIES
AND- DO AGREE THOUGH THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
MARTY MOTO FAMILY MEMBER US YOU
CAN'T HELP ME DISABILITY YOU'RE
COMING ACTION NETWORK MY SISTER
WAS AN ALPHA SILLY ACTION OR
NURSING HOME. FOR BRIEF PERIODS
IN OUR LIFE AND SO AGAIN MY
FAMILY AND OTHER PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES UNDERSTAND. THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING ONE'S
RIGHTS- SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
AND- AND FOR ALL FOR ALL THE
REASONS GIVEN. NOT NOW ALSO
MEANT TO SAY I SUPPORT THE ITEM
DE ON THE BASELINE FUNDING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALCUTTA AND I'M NOT STANDING
IN SUPPORT. I DON'T KNOW THAT
I'M STANDING IN OPPOSITION TO
THE OFFICE OF THE PATIENT
ADVOCATE. BUT I DO CHALLENGED
THAT I. AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH WITH A BIT
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS. IF THIS
IS THE APPROPRIATE THING TO DO
TO CREATE YET ANOTHER STATE
OFFICE- WE WOULD ARGUE THAT
THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE
CONSERVED AND THE CONSERVATIVE
TEA PROCESS AS IT IS TODAY
TAKES TOO LONG. BUT BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM WE HAVETAKES TOO LONG
IS NOT NECESSARILY A
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE CREATION
OF YET ANOTHER STATE ENTITY. I
DO THINK THAT- THERE'S DUELING
LAWYERS OPINIONS AT THIS POINT
ON WHAT THIS COURT CASE SAYS
AND THAT RATHER THAN DECIDING.
A COURSE OF ACTION THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE A STEP BACK WE NEED TO
ASK THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THIS DECISION WE NEED TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH TO DO A CENSUS OF POINT
AND COUNT. A POINT IN TIME
COUNT HOW MANY RESIDENTS ARE WE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT WE DON'T
HAVE. I MAY BE WRONG BUT I DO
NOT BELIEVE WE HAVE A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IN EVERY
COUNTY SO WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
HAVE AN OFFICE OF A PATIENT
ADVOCATE IN A COUNTY THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A NURSING FACILITY.
WE CAME BEFORE YOU FOR SO MANY
YEARS TO GET FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. I AM I'M JUST
CONCERNED IS THIS REALLY THE
BEST APPROACH- BUT I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETHING HAS TO
BE DONE. FUNDAMENTALLY AT THE
END OF THE DAY A PERSON THAT
HAS NO VOICE AND HAS NO ONE TO
SPEAK FOR THEM IS THE MOST
VULNERABLE PERSON AND SO. I
DON'T THINK WE WOULD EVER SAY
THAT THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
REPRESENTED BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS THE BEST
APPROACH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUB COMMITTEE. AND IF I CAN I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE SPONSORS FIRST.
HAVE YOU BEEN GIVEN ANY
FEEDBACK FROM THE TRIPLE A.'S
ON WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED- ON
THE LOCAL SIDE TO THIS CONCEPT.
I CAN SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENT CALPERS DECISION
HELPLESSLY AS WE DID WE HAVE
MET WITH THE TRIPLE A AS I KNOW
THAT- THERE'S ALSO- SENATOR PAN
HAS EGISLATION SB TEN FORTY
THREE THAT'S ALSO LOOKING AT
THE PRACTICALITIES OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEY'VE BUT
THEY WERE INVOLVED IN A RECENT
MEETING- I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
TRIPLE A.'S BUT I HAVE NOT. THE
LEAST THE INITIAL RESPONSE WAS
NOT OPPOSITION TO THIS IDEA- I
THINK THE ENVISIONING IS THAT.
THIS THIS THIS OFFICE WOULD NOT
BE A LARGE STRUCTURE OF ANY
KIND IT WOULD JUST BE A-
FACILITATOR OF MAKING SURE THAT
IN EVERY. IN AREAS WHERE IT'S
NEEDED- IT COULD DEPEND ON THE
STRUCTURE OF EACH COUNTY HOW
THEY CURRENTLY HANDLES THEIR
THEIR AGING OR SENIOR PROGRAMS
THAT THERE IS SOMEBODY THERE
THAT CAN TAKE ON THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR NURSING HOME
GIVE THEM A CALL- SO- I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE TRIP LAZILY SOME.
OUR INITIAL DISCUSSIONS WE
HAVEN'T HEARD STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THAT- TO BOTH THE-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GIVEN THIS COURT
DECISION HAS THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE OFFICE OR SOMETHING.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS.
ACTIVELY CONSIDERING GOING
FORWARD. WITH YES AS OTHERS
HAVE SAID THAT THE LEAD ON THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY BECAUSE
IT INVOLVES. A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THE OFFICE
A LONG TERM CARE BUT SEVERAL
PARTS OF OUR AGENCY FAMILY AND
WE HAVE HAD ONGOING CREATIVE
COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW TO INTERPRET THIS.
DECISION AND HOW TO BEST
RESPOND TO AND I BELIEVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE- ANY
INSIGHT YOU CAN PROVIDE ON HOW
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING
WHICH ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE
PROPOSAL WE'RE HEARING HERE
TODAY. THIS IS ONE OF THE ONES
IN THE MIX I THINK AS AS MY
FELLOW PANELISTS HAVE SAID
IT'S- WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THE
OPERATIONAL THE LOGISTICAL
LEGAL. FISCAL IT BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY IN THE MIX IN THIS
CONVERSATION A FAIR REFLECTION
OF AND- I'VE HEARD IT ALLUDED
TO WHEN I DON'T MEAN TO ASK.
LONG TERM- BUT THE MAN TO TAKE
ON MORE RESPONSIBILITIES THAN.
ARE ALREADY BEFORE THEM AND
THEY MAY BE PRECLUDED FROM IT.
BUT I AM SENSITIVE TO THE FACT
THAT WE WILL FINALLY GAVE THEM
AN INCREASE LAST YEAR AND WILL
BE ASKING. MUCH MORE IF WE
WOULD ASK THEM TO TAKE ON THIS
RESPONSIBILITY IF THEY COULD
EVEN TO THIS AND SO- DO THINK
WE NEED SOMEONE WHO'S-
ADVOCATING AT THE BEDSIDE AND
JUST WOULD ASK- THE DEPARTMENTS
TO WORK WITH US TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE COULD DO BEST WITH
THAT. SO WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE. TO EAT OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO TWO F. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. NOW GOING TO F. CREATING
A THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM ON
DEMENTIA CARE GIVER EDUCATION.
ALZHEIMER'S AND OTHER FORMS OF
DEMENTIA DISEASES WITH NO KNOWN
TREATMENT TO SLOW OR STOP THE
PROGRESSION OF THE DISEASE
OFTEN WHEN THE FAMILY GETS A
DIAGNOSIS OF ALZHEIMER'S OR
DEMENTIA THEY'RE LEFT WITH MANY
QUESTIONS AND NOT MUCH
INFORMATION. THIS BUDGET
REQUEST A FIVE MILLION WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BY AB TWO THOUSAND
ONE WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM FOR
DEMENTIA CARE GIVER EDUCATION
IT WOULD FUND TEN SITES TO
CREATE AND IMPLEMENT CARE GIVER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. AN EMPHASIS
WOULD BE MADE ON SITES THAT
WILL SERVE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN VARIOUS GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE PRIORITY WOULD
BE GIVEN TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
LINGUISTICALLY ACCESSIBLE.
BECAUSE OF OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ARE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ARE AT HIGHER RISK
AND HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS IF WE
KEEP CARE GIVERS HEALTHY AND
SUPPORTED THEY CAN KEEP THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS AT HOME LONGER.
AVOIDING COSTLY NURSING HOMES
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEMENTIA COST
MEDI CAL TWENTY THREE TIMES
MORE. THAN THE AVERAGE MEDI CAL
RECIPIENTS. WITH OUR INCREASING
OLDER POPULATION ADULT
POPULATION WE KNOW THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA IS
GOING TO INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY
MEANING THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
CARING FOR SOMEONE WITH
DEMENTIA. IS ALSO GOING TO
INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE INVEST IN OUR
CARE GIVERS NOW- WITH ME. IS
MONICA MILLER. ATTEST TO.
PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS ON THIS
AS WELL THANK YOU. MISTER
TURNER- MIKE THE TIGER THE BOYS
SO I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- BUT
FOR SOMETHING FOR HAVING US%
TODAY MONICA MILLER AND I
REPRESENT ALZHEIMER'S LOS
ANGELES ALZHEIMER'S WHICH
COUNTY AND ALL TIME SAN DIEGO
WHO BROUGHT THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD WHEN I POINT OUT THAT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD NOT
DIRECTLY. GO TO ON ANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE
IT JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
WITHIN THE TEN SITES ON
ALZHEIMER'S IS A PROGRESSIVE
DISEASE IT GETS WORSE IT
DOESN'T GET BETTER WE FIND THAT
THESE CARE GIVERS STRUGGLE IN
TERMS OF FINDING RESOURCES
RESPITE CARE SUPPORT SERVICES
PARTICULARLY. ON AND IF THEY'RE
NOT IF IT MEANS TO HAVE SOMEONE
TO COME INTO THE HOME TO HELP
THEM SO WE HAVE A GREAT SUCCESS
WITH THESE PROGRAMS WITH ABOUT
FORTY STATE WIDE ON AND
ALZHEIMER'S LOS ANGELES OF HIM
CITY AGO AT ALL TIMES ORANGE
COUNTY REPRESENT- SEVEN
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY AND AGAIN
WE KIND OF THESE PROBLEMS ARE
VERY SUCCESSFUL WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THIS TAKEN STATEWIDE IT
WOULD BE A FIFTY THREE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD SUNSET
IN FIVE YEARS- AND THEN WE
COULD LOOK AT THE DATA AND SEE.
WHAT THE IMPACTS WERE AND SEE
HOW WE CAN HELP THIS COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THESE CHARACTERS
DESPERATELY NEED HELP WE FOUND
THAT WHEN WE DO PROVIDE THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE BETTER
SERVED QUICK TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MANAGE THE PRESS HI MAN. THE
THAT DEALING WITH. HOW TO
MANAGE. LIFE AND BECAUSE IT IS
A VERY STRESSED SO.
PARTICULARLY WHEN A CLOSE
MEMBER. HOW TO ANSWER ANY.
AGAIN THIS PART AB TWO. ONE SO
THERE IS A LOT. CA AND LET JUST
ON THE LIPS OF COMPLEX PACIFIC
RECESSED. UPON APPROPRIATION.
ON FROM THE BUDGET SO THIS BILL
WOULD NOT BE ACTED AT THE
FUNDING IS NOT APPROVED. IF
THAT HAPPENED ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MA'AM-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON TWO F. SEEING
NONE I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE WILL HOLD THIS
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO TWO G.
THAT'S OKAY.
THIRD IN THIS AREA
AND I MAY ASK- YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO STAY THERE UNTIL
ISSUE FOR BUT WE ARE GOING TO
DO TO G. BEFORE. TO JEAN OKAY
AND I GOT A HORSE THANK YOU. I
WILL BE BACK OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SHERRY DREW SO I AM THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
YOU TODAY ABOUT THIS ITEM AND
INCREASE THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING BUDGET OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A ONE TIME
FUNDING TO UPDATE A GUIDE FOR
CONSUMERS WHO MAY HAVE
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA CALLED
PARTNERING WITH YOUR DOCTOR-
WHICH IS A COMPANY AT WHICH IS
AN ACCOMPANYING BUDGET REQUEST
WITH US ONLY MEMBER LOW MOANS
BILL AB TWENTY FORTY EIGHT- BUT
FIRST LET ME ECHO COMMENTS FROM
EARLIER AND SAY HELP. OUR
ASSOCIATION IS TO THE WORK
BEING DONE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING INDIVIDUALS WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA DEPEND
ON SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER THAT BE THE
TRIPLE A.'S- THEIR HEALTH
PROMOTION WORK THE LONG TERM
CARE ON A LONG TERM I'M SORRY
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM AND THE FAMILY KERR
CARE GIVER RESOURCES AND SO
MUCH MORE- BUT IT ADDITIONALLY
AS- EVERYBODY IS AWARE- IS A
VERY SPECIAL YEAR AS THE
DEPARTMENT ENGAGES IN THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING-
COLLABORATIVE AND COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN THAT THAT WE BELIEVE WELL-
MEET THE NEEDS OF. CALIFORNIA'S
ASIAN. THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION IS A PARTOF THAT
MASTER PLAN PROCESS WE'RE
EXCITED TO CONTINUE- TO ENGAGE
IN THAT WORK AND TO ADVOCATE
FOR THAT WORK. WITH RESPECT TO
THIS BUDGET ITEM- AS MANY- NO
ALZHEIMER'S AS A DEEP IMPACT ON
OUR STATE NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS N OUR
STATE. HAVE ALZHEIMER'S- THERE
IS NO KNOWN CURE. AND IT IS
CURRENTLY- THE THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES FACING THOSE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S. IS NOT BEING ABLE
TO RECEIVE A TIMELY DIAGNOSIS.
NATIONALLY LESS THAN HALF OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVING WITH
THE DISEASE HAVE BEEN GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS AND THIS PREVENTS
THEM. FROM BEING ABLE TO CARE
PLAN- LIFE PLAN WITH THEIR
FAMILY AND CARE AND LOVED ONES
AND TO ENGAGE IN CRUCIAL
CLINICAL TRIALS THAT WILL LEAD
TO A CURE. THIS YEAR OUR
ASSOCIATION IS PRIORITIZING
POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT HELP-
MORE INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE A
TIMELY DIAGNOSIS WHICH INCLUDES
THE POLICY IN BUDGET ITEMS
UPDATED STATE DEVELOP GUIDE.
CALLED PARTNERING WITH YOUR
DOCTOR. THIS GUIDE WAS CREATED
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE BY THE
STATE'S HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
COLLABORATION WITH ALL TIMES
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION. AND IT
HELPS PREPARE CONSUMERS FOR
CRUCIAL DOCTORS VISITS IT HELPS
GUIDE PEOPLE THROUGH THE
COMPLICATED AN EMOTIONAL
PROCESS OF SEEKING AND
RECEIVING A DIAGNOSIS. WHILE WE
BELIEVE MUCH OF THE CORE OF
THIS GUIDE IS STILL VALUABLE
MUCH HAS CHANGED IN SEVENTEEN
YEARS. I IN PARTICULAR WE
BELIEVE WE MUST FOCUS ON
CULTURAL COMPETENCY AS WE
UPDATE THIS GUIDE. NOT ONLY IS
CALIFORNIA GETTING OLDER AS- AS
WAS STATED EARLIER BUT OUR
AGING POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW MORE DIVERSE. IF RESOURCES
LIKE THESE DON'T SPEAK TOWARD
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INDIVIDUALS
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
RESOURCES LIKE THIS GUIDE AND
IT WILL NOT HAVE THE DESIRED
IMPACT THAT WE BELIEVE IT CAN
HAVE. WE ARE AGAIN I'M
PROPOSING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT IN
THIS WORK A TO UPDATE THE GUIDE
TO ENSURE THAT IT IS A VALUABLE
RESOURCE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS-
AND WE LOOK TO CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ON THIS WORK AS WELL AS- THE
MASTER PLAN AN AGING PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SIR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON TWO G. LISA
CALLING WITH CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS- FUNDING
EFFORT IS A WORK DETERRENT FOR
US IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE IT'S
ALLOWING THE- PERSON TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND GET THEIR-
AFFAIRS IN ORDER SO THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO HAVE WHATEVER
OFFICE OF WHATEVER WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY EXPRESSED THEIR WISHES
SO WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MA'AM- FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING AND FOR DEAL LAUGH IS
THE UPDATING OF THIS GUIDE BOOK
POSSIBLY SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE DONE OR ABSORBED WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES. THAT WHAT I
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE DIRECTORY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ANY ALZHEIMER'S
DEDICATED STAFF WERE
COMMUNICATIONS DEDICATED STAFF
SO WELL WELL WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THE VISION I WOULD HAVE
TO SOME MORE WORK ON THAT GREAT
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWO G. OPEN AND RETURN TO TWO
WAY IF WE MAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
POWER CAN. YEAH. NO WAY. SAFETY
FIRST RIGHT. THEY WERE LIKE MY
EXCITEMENT. WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THE POPULATION OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS EACH SIXTY FIVE
HAS GROWN BY OVER 40% TO FIFTY
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS WILL GROW BY
ANOTHER 60% AN OLDER PEOPLE
REPRESENT MORE THAN 20% OF THE
CALIFORNIA POPULATION. IS THE
AGING POPULATION IT HAS GROWN
IT IS ALSO BECOME POOR 49% OF
CALIFORNIANS OVER SIXTY FIVE
ARE LIVING BELOW 20% OF THE
FEDERAL SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
LEVEL. ECONOMIC AND SECURITY OF
OLDER ADULT HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASES WITH AGE
JUST TO SENIORS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE SERIOUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
PHYSICAL OR COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT THEY ARE LESS ABLE
TO AFFORD THE SUPPORT OF INNER
INTERVENTIONS THAT WILL KEEP
THEM STABLE WITHOUT SUPPORTS
STRESSORS ILLNESS RELATIONSHIP
BOSS ISOLATION CAUGHT IN JULY
THE CLUB IN A BIG BILL CAN
STABILIZE THEM PUTTING AT RISK
FOR REPEAT REALIZATION. NURSING
HOMES AND HOUSING LOSS AND
HOMELESSNESS AND NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING PEOPLE
HOME IT OF OUR HOSPITALS IF
POSSIBLE. THIS IS WHY SENIOR
HOMELESSNESS IS ON THE RISE A
LARGE AND GROWING POPULATION OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION ARE
OVER FIFTY AND HOMELESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME. COMMUNITY BASED
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ADDRESSES
THE STRESSORS FOCUSING THEIR
HIGH TOUCH APPROACH ON ISSUES
COMMON TO LATER LIFE STAGES.
FOR EXAMPLE INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE HELPS PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO START OR
HOW TO FIND SERVICES OR
SOLUTIONS. CASE MANAGEMENT
SUPPORTS PEOPLE WITH COMPLEX
ISSUES IT COMPLEMENTS MEDICAL
CARE CONNECTS CLIENTS WITH
PUBLIC AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES AND HELPS BUILD TO
RECONNECT NETWORKS OF FRIENDS
AND FAMILY. SENIOR CENTERS KEEP
PEOPLE CONNECTED TO COMMUNITY
BUILDING FRIENDSHIPS AND
PROMOTING LEARNING LAUGHTER IN
INTERACTIVE DISCUSSION. THROUGH
MEALS HEALTH EDUCATION
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE
CLASSES AND AFFINITY GROUPS.
VISITING PROGRAMS REDUCES
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION ANXIETY
AND LONELINESS. ADULT DAYCARE
PROVIDE SAFE WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENTS AND MONITORING OF
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS AS
WELL AS STIMULATING
SOCIALIZATION AND THERAPEUTIC
ACTIVITIES. OFTEN IT ENABLES
FAMILY CAREGIVERS TO WORK. SB
GIVES FAMILY CAREGIVERS THE
BREAK THEY NEED TO RECHARGE AND
TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN HEALTH.
LEGAL ASSISTANCE DEFEND THE
SENIOR RIGHTS PROTECTS ASSETS
IN ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS BITES EVICTIONS
RESTRUCTURES LEANS. MEDIATES
TENANTS SITUATIONS AND SUPPORTS
FAMILY UNITY. CALIFORNIA HAS
PROVIDED ZERO FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM FOR A DOZEN YEARS THEY
EXIST BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT HAS REMAINED
MOSTLY FLAT THIS IS CONSTRAINED
LOCAL EFFORTS TO GROW CAPACITY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
GROWING AGING POPULATION. BUT
IN AMOUNTS TO ANNUAL REDUCTIONS
AS THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
CONTINUE TO RISE. WELL SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE STEPPED
UP TO AUGMENT GROWING FUNDING
GAPS LOCAL FUNDING IS NOT
ENOUGH TO INCREASE CAPACITY TO
MEET THE NEED. IN FACT THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS SERVED
BY THE CASE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
DROPPED FROM NINETEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND 721-100-0100
THIRTY NINE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
FOR ADULT DAYCARE. I WANT TO
INTRODUCE TWENTY PETERSON FROM
THE ALAMEDA SENIOR SERVICE
COALITION WHO WILL SPEAK ON
THIS BUDGET ASK. HEARD OF THANK
YOU. I NEED HELP- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
I AM- I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- IT IS OUR OUR-
I WON IT EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
FOR- HER SPONSORSHIP OF OUR
BUDGET REQUEST. AND IT'S A REAL
HONOR TO BE SITTING NEXT TO HER
TODAY- I JUST WANTED TO
ELEVATE- ONE POINT WHICH IS WHY
IS THIS SEEMINGLY SIMPLE. SO
THE PROGRAM SO CRITICAL- AND I
THINK THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPOKE TO THAT BUT I WANTED TO I
WANTED TO POINT OUT TO YOU YOU
HAVE A- GRATEFUL ORDERS THAT
WERE HANDED OUT EARLIER- YOU
KNOW WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
THE HOUSING CRISIS RIGHT NOW
HOUSING AND SECURITY IS
INCREASINGLY A SENIOR CRISIS-
AND A LARGE AND GROWING PORTION
OF. THE POPULATION OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE IS OLDER- IN OUR REGION
OF THE BAY AREA PEOPLE AGE. IN
SOME CITIES AT LEAST PEOPLE AGE
FIFTY PLUS MAKE UP- ALMOST HALF
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION AND
PEOPLE SIXTY PLUS MAKE UP
FOURTEEN OR MORE PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL POINT IN TIME COUNT- AND
THE MOST HOLY IN FACT I THINK.
IS ABOUT ALL THREE QUARTERS OF
FOUR TO SIX ONE QUARTER OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. SO IN YOUR
FOLDER YOU'LL SEE THEIR THEIR
PROFILES OF OLDER PEOPLE WHO
WE'VE MET IN THE COURSE OF
STUDY IN THIS PHENOMENON IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND MANY STAKEHOLDERS- AND I
WANT TO POINT TO A GRAPHIC- IN
THE PACKET THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
A MAP OF THE- OLDER ADULT
HOUSING CRISIS IT SHOWS THE
UNDERLYING ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS. THAT MAKE UP. THAT
THAT REALLY MAKES SENIORS
VULNERABLE. AND THE STRESSORS
THAT CAN HIT A NEAT MAY
DESTABILIZE A PERSON AND
WITHOUT INTERVENTION CAN LEAD
TO DISPLACEMENT- HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND ALL TOO OFTEN
HOMELESSNESS. WELL THE CDA
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY ARE EXACTLY
EXACTLY THE PROGRAMS THAT CAN
INTERVENE IN THIS PROGRESSION-
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
POOR ENOUGH YET- TO QUALIFY FOR
PUBLIC PROGRAMS THEY OFTEN
REPRESENT LIFELINES FOR OLDER
PEOPLE WHO ARE ECONOMICALLY
INSECURE- BUT NOT POOR ENOUGH-
AND ISOLATED. OF THE ADDRESS
THOSE STRESSORS- WITH IT WITH A
HIGH TOUCH APPROACH- ELLAND.
THEIR ABILITY TO STABILIZE AN
INDIVIDUAL IN A FAMILY- AND
KEEP THEM FROM DISPLACEMENT
AND- AND HOMELESSNESS IS
PROFOUND. SO WE REALLY NEED
SERVICE CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- AND- THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA INVEST IN THE-
DEPARTMENT ON ANSWER QUESTIONS.
BERMAN FINANCE L. L. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON TO A. YES IT HAS A
WORK DETERRENT FOR US KEEPING
PEOPLE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS SAFE AND IF
IT IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE THAN
IT'S A JUST A DOUBLE WIN ALL
THE WAY AROUND SO WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN SHANNON I'M
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SENIORS AND
OAKLAND WE ARE NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATION SERVING
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
THROUGH FREE LEGAL SERVICES
MEDICAID HOUSING AND COMMUNTY
EDUCATION. OUR ATTORNEYS AND
ADVOCATES WORK WITH OLDER
ADULTS IN CRITICAL AREAS
INCLUDING HOUSING HEALTH LAW
PUBLIC BENEFITS AN ELDER ABUSE.
FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR PUBLIC
BENEFITS DEPARTMENT WE
REPRESENT OLDER ADULTS AND
SOCIAL SECURITY APPEALS TO
FIGHT THE LOS OR REDUCTION OF
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
RETIREMENT OR SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY BENEFITS. WHICH FOR
MOST OF OUR CLIENTS IS THEIR
SOLE SOURCE OF INCOME. IN OUR
ELDER ABUSE PRACTICE WE
REPRESENT OLDER ADULTS
EXPERIENCING PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
OR FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE IN
OBTAINING A RESTRAINING ORDERS.
ACCORDING TO RECENT JUSTICE GAP
STUDY IN CLIFORNIA ONLY 28% OF
OLDER ADULTS RECEIVED HELP FROM
LEGAL PROBLEMS EXPERIENCE IN
THE LAST YEAR. PRESERVING OLDER
ADULTS OR SECURITY BENEFITS
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE PREVENTING
AN EVICTION AND A POOR
OBTAINING A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST AND USER ENABLES AN
OLDER ADULT HER MAIN SAFELY IN
THEIR HOME WITH INDEPENDENCE
AND DIGNITY. THE IMPACT OF
THESE REALLY COOL SERVICES ON
OLDER ADULTS PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
AND FINANCIAL WELL BEING.
REALLY CANNOT BE OVERSTATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. HI
THIS IS ROBERT TAYLOR- WITH
SENIOR SUPPORT PROGRAM BASED IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE SERVE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
SENIORS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND-
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM A
BUDGET- BUDGET MENTION HERE-
YOU KNOW I'M HERE TO SPEAK JUST
QUICKLY ON TO PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE FREE PROGRAMS TO OUR
CLIENTS- IN THAT IS FRIENDLY
VISITING AND ALSO CASE
MANAGEMENT- WITH THE FRIENDLY
VISITING PROGRAM WAS MENTIONED-
PREVIOUSLY- BUT BUT A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM WE MATCH VOLUNTEERS
WITH SENIORS. AND CLASSY IT'S
MAINLY SOCIALIZATION- BUT THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS THAT THE THAT
OUR VOLUNTEERS DO WHILE THEY'RE
IN THE HOME WITH THE SENIORS
THE REALLY ADD VALUE TO THE
PROGRAM THAT CAN BE ANYTHING
FROM JUST DISCUSSION ON. ON
EVERYDAY TOPICS TO ACTUALLY
GOING ON A WALK OR MAYBE- EVEN
SOME SHOPPING ERRANDS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE BUT IT
REALLY DOES ADDRESS THE
ISOLATION ISSUE THAT TO THAT WE
FACE NOW. AND THERE WAS- THERE
WAS A STUDY COMPLETED WHAT FOR
BE. HAS THE SAME. AS SMOKING
SIX FIFTEEN A DAY PHYSICALLY
MENTALLY AND EMOTIONALLY SO IT
HAS A VERY TRAGIC- CONSEQUENCE
FOR THOSE THAT ARE ISOLATED IN
THIS IS ONE PROGRAM THAT CAN
HELP ALLEVIATE THAT- CASE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IS VERY
SIMILAR- DOES HAVE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS WERE
ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER A CARE
PLAN FOR THE SENIORS BASED ON
THEIR IMMEDIATE NEEDS. AND THEN
HELPING THEM MOVE FORWARD AND
BE UGH YOU KNOW ONCE AGAIN A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY BUT IN BOTH CASES
WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE FRIENDLY VISITING
PROGRAM AND THE CASE MANAGER
PROGRAM IS HELP SENIORS REMAIN
HEALTHY WELL AND SELF
SUFFICIENT AT HOME WHICH IS THE
REAL GOAL OF THIS PLAN AND OF
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS A WHOLE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. HI BRANDON
RENFRO CASE MANAGER LIFE ELDER
CARE ALAMEDA COUNTY- AS A CASE
MANAGER WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF
SENIORS WHO HAVE UNMET NEEDS.
THEY DON'T A LOT OF OUR SENIORS
DON'T HAVE FAMILY FRIENDS
SUPPORT CARE GIVERS ANYONE TO
HELP THEM WITH THEIR- WITH GAPS
IN THEIR CARE. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE COME IN WE ARE JUST TOLD
PRODUCT- CASE MANAGERS WE DO IN
HOME. ASSESSMENTS AND WE DO-
FREQUENT VISITS ALWAYS CHECK ON
THEM AND SELL THEIR NEEDS ARE
MET. AND WITH A LACK OF FUNDING
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF SERVICE THE-
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SERVICES
LIKE THIS FOR THOSE WITH
MEDICARE ALL. A LOT OF TIMES I
HAVE CLIENTS WHO MISSED MEDI
CAL BY FORTY DOLLARS IN INCOME
OR THEY THEY MEET THE
REQUIREMENT INCOME BUT- THAT
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND SAVINGS
OR- OR ONE NOT SO WE COME IN
AND WE HELP. THE LOW INCOME
MANY THAT SUPPORT. AND ANYWAY
WE CAN WHETHER STREETS ROTATION
MEALS FINANCIAL RESOURCES IT'S
ANY HAVE A GAP IN THE CARE WERE
THE WERE THERE. THEY CAN
ALWAYS- COLLISON WILL COME SOON
AS POSSIBLE- ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES I HAVE IS ONE OF MY
CLIENTS HAS MEALS ON WHEELS WHO
CALL. EVERY DAY TO SAY SHOULD
NOT RECEIVE HER MEAL AND- SO WE
AS A WE WAS ASKED ME IF I WAS
GOING HOME AND CHECK ON THE
SITUATION. NOT ONLY DID SHE
FORGET THAT SHE RECEIVED A MEAL
SHE FORGOT TO EAT AND- THE
SCHOOL HELP LEAD TO HELP THE
CLIENT. HAVE BEEN SAID TO CALL
NINE ONE ONE GET ARE NOW SHE'S
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT JUST A
HARD DEADLINE I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CRISIS SUPPORT
SERVICES OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF A MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER MY
AGENCIES IN HOME SERVICES FOR
OLDER ADULTS INCLUDE VISITING
SERVICES THIS MIGHT BE BECAUSE-
AND WILL FOCUS ON INDIVIDULS
CONSIDERED AT RISK FOR SUICIDE
BUT WHO CAN'T ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES. THIS MIGHT BE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE I'LL BUT STILL THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE COST OF CARE
OR THEY HAVE MOBILITY
CHALLENGES OR THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES SUCH A SEVERE
ANXIETY OR- POSES A BAY TO HELP
SEEKING SIDE HOME OFTEN CLIENTS
HAVE SOME MAJOR LOS OF A LIFE
PARTNER CHILD EMPLOYMENT OR
OTHER NATURAL SUPPORTS LOS
OFFERED THROUGH ITS PAST LOSSES
AND FEARS ABOUT THE FUTURE AND
AS A TIME OF CRISIS. FOR THOSE
WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
EMOTIONAL OR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO RECOVER. OUR
PROGRAM WORKS TO CONNECT OLDER
ADULTS THAT OUR OWN RESILIENCE
AND BILLS OUR CAPACITY TO COPE
WITH MULTIPLE STRESSORS. A
RECENT CLIENT LOST A FAMILY
MEMBER TO HOMICIDE SHE WAS
DEPRESSED TRAUMATIZED AND IN
DESPAIR IMMENSELY WORRIED ABOUT
THE FUTURE WE FOCUS TREATMENT
ON PROVIDING A SPACE FOR HER
GRIEF ANGER AND HELPLESSNESS.
WE WORKED WITH HER ON ENSURING
HER SAFETY AND COLLABORATED
WITH OR TO IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS
AND SYSTEMS IN HER COMMUNITY.
THAT COULD BE SOURCES OF
STRENGTH DURING THIS TIME.
REDUCING ISOLATION IS AT THE
CORE OF HOME VISITING SERVICES
AND A TOP CONCERN AMONG ELDERS.
INCREASE FUNDING WOULD REDUCE
WEIGHT LESS AND MAKE TIMELY
INTERVENTION POSSIBLE I URGE
YOU TO APPROVE THE REQUEST THAT
THEY DO THIS MEANT TO SUPPORT
THE- SAVING WORK. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KAREN GRAHAM SUCH AND THEN
THE ADMINISTRATOR OF EIGHTEEN
FAMILY SERVICES FOR THE CITY OF
FREMONT WHICH IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST CITY IN THE BAY AREA.
CASE MANAGEMENT INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE IN SENIOR CENTER
ACTIVITIES ARE THE FRONTLINE
SERVICES I PROVIDE TO CONNECT
OUR OLDER ADULTS TO SERVICES
THAT PROMOTE. POSITIVE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. THESE
PROGRAMS ALLOW. US AS A CITY
GOVERNMENT TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE WHO
NEED THEM I'M TALKING ABOUT
OLDER ADULTS WITH FUNCTIONAL
LIMITATIONS. AND MULTIPLE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. THE CITY
CONTRIBUTES SUPPORT GENERAL
FUNDS TO SUPPORT 70% OF THE
BUDGET BUT I AM ABLE TO
LEVERAGE OTHER FUN SUCH AS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. TO
BE ABLE TO SERVICE ANYONE WHO
CONTACTS AS IN OUR CITY. SO I
HOPE WE CAN STEP UP AND REALLY
MEET MATCH FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
MAKE THIS REAL. BECAUSE NOW'S
THE TIME TO INVEST IN THE
PUBLIC SERVICE APPROACH NOW
BECAUSE 2% OF OUR HOMES. ARE
OLDER ADULTS. NOW BE. THE MET
SO. IS THE ENDING ON CAN BASED
NETWORK. TODAY TO PREPARE AN
INNER AND CONNECT WITH ALL
RESIDENTS IN MY THE- AND NOW
BECAUSE- THE INCREASE. IN LEVEL
A CUTIE THAT WERE FACING THIS
FRAGILE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE
COULD COLLAPSE WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. CAROL SPORTSCENTER
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
THE COMMISSION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST THANK
YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS JASON
MATTHEWS I AM THE PRESIDENT OF.
ADULT DAY CARE FOR PEOPLE
ALZHEIMER'S DEMENTIA. AND A LOT
OF OR FUNNY DO COME FROM
TRIPLE A AND THE IMPACT OUR
COMMUNITY IS HUGE WHAT WE DO.
THE PERFECT EXAMPLE OF AS MY
BEST FRIEND A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
HE'S- CAME AND HE AGREED WITH
HIS DAD. DELL WAS HOMELESS FOR
THE MOST PART. AND WITH THAT
HIS DID HE HAD TO TAKE IN HIS
FATHER. AND LIKE MANY PEOPLE
WERE IN THE IN THE WILL BE
CONSIDERED THE SANDWICH
GENERATION HE HAD TO FIND OUT
SERVICES AND HEALTHY DO. WHAT
HE DID WAS THROUGH THE ROOF
WITH THROUGH THIS PROGRAM AS WE
PLAY HIS DAD IN. IN OUR
SERVICES FOR ADULT DAYCARE HE
IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO
EMPLOYED NUMEROUS PEOPLE TRACK
COMMUNITY. SO INSTEAD OF HAVING
HIM BURIED JUST WORRY ABOUT IF
HIS DAD FALLS OR HAVE ANY NEEDS
OR ISSUES WHAT IS ALLOW YOU TO
HAVE IT HAVE PEACE OF MIND
WHILE HE HELPED SUPPORT HIS
FAMILY. IS SUPPORTED THE
COMMITTEE WITH HIS BUSINESS AT
THE SAME TIME INVESTMENT THE
GROWTH IN EVERYTHING THAT HAVE.
IS BY THE- WE HAVE. HOPE ALSO.
NOW WITH THE PROPER FUND WE
HAVE IS IT MAKES IT HARD FOR A
US TO GET TO GIVE THE SIR T. IN
OTHER IN. AND ALL KNOW AGING IS
GOING TO UNIT CREASED AS WE
HAVE YOU SEEN THE WAVE OF BABY
BOOMERS HAVE HAPPENED SO WHAT
WE'RE ASKING YOU FOR PLEASE
HELP INCREASED BECAUSE IF NOT
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO START POPULAR HELP. TO
ENSURE WHICH IS SO HAPPY A
WHICH PEOPLE NEED WHEN YOU HAVE
MEMORY LOSS WITH THAT BEING
SAID THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN A WHILE THE HEART
WELL IN EUROPEAN CALIFORNIA WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL BROUGHT BY OUR
PARTNERS AT THE SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THIS A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IS
REALLY JUST ONE PART. OUR ONE
PIECE OF A LARGER TEMBLOR
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO KEEP.
SENIORS IN THEIR HOMES IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE KNOW THEY
WANT TO BE SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. NOON I'M SHARON
CORNELL IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ST MARY'S CENTER-
IN WEST OAKLAND SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE WE HAVE BEEN
SERVING US SENIORS AND PRE
SCHOOLERS- TODAY I LEFT OUR
BLEACH BRIGADE IN THE- SHELTER.
A BECAUSE YOUR WORK IS MORE
IMPORTANT TODAY- AND I WANTED
TO FOCUS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
CASE MANAGEMENT A SERVICE THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO RENAME.
BECAUSE THE NAME DOES NOT
CAPTURE THE RELATIONSHIP THAT
ISFORGED BETWEEN OUR SKILLED
KNOWLEDGABLE EMPATHETIC WORKERS
WHO ARE ABLE TO WORK WITH
SENIORS TO MOVE NOT ONLY TOWARD
SELF SUFFICIENCY. BUT TOWARD
SELF DETERMINATION AND TO HELP
SOMEONE COME THROUGH.
HOMELESSNESS TRAUMA
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND GET ON
WITH THEIR LIFE AND BE THE
PERSON THAT THEY WANT TO BE.
THIS IS A CRIME LIAM SERVICE I
BELIEVE THAT IT HAS NOT SEEN
SIGNIFICANT IN PEACE. SINCE IT
RECESSION STANDS IN SHAME- IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SSI ANOTHER
PROGRAM IT WILL CONSIDER LATER
THIS AFTERNOON WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. TO SEE
THERE'S WHO HAVE CAN DID. RICH%
ROBUST VIBRANT UNITY WE LIVE. I
URGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
EVERYTHING FOR YOU AND THANK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND THE
COALITION FOR INVITING TODAY.
THANK YOU. MR CHAIR MEMBERS
MILLER REPRESENTING COUNTY
PARTICIPER. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. CLAY CAMP REPRESENTING
BOTH THE SENIORS COUNSELLORS
SANTA CRUZ AND SAMITY DON'T
COUNTIES AND SEE FOR A- AND
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
ECHO EVERYTHING EVERYONE ELSE'S
SAID A COUPLE THINGS TO ADD
JUST TO EXPAND ON WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH THIS PROGRAM IT
IS RECEIVED ZERO STATE FUND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE. SO
IT'S NOT A MATTER FLAT FUND
IT'S A MATTER ZERO FUNDING ALL
FUNDING WAS ELIMINATED IN THAT
CRISIS THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO SAY IS TITLE THREE B.
PROGRAMS ARE THE OST FLEXIBLE
DOLLARS THAT ARE OUT THERE. AND
THAT ALLOWS TWO THINGS TO
HAPPEN IN THE HOUSE THE
SERVICES TO BE CUSTOMIZED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL LOCATION SO WE MAKE
SURE THEY'RE BEING USED IN THE
MANNER THAT THAT COMMUNITY MAPS
NY. AND MAY IT EXTREMELY. IN
SIR THIS CALL US SAME SORT OF
REASON AND THE PART ABOUT THAT
I WANTED JUST OKAY IS THE
BASEMENT PRINT DOT HOURS FOR
BETTER BUT I'M GONNA COME
BROUGHT UP. IT ALLOWS US IN.
CASES TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AND- BETTER WAITING TO BE. HAVE
THERE WAITING TO HAVE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINED SO WELL
THAT PROCESS IS GOING ON. THOSE
OF US THAT HAVE THREE BE
SERVICES CAN STEP IN
IMMEDIATELY AND KEEP THAT
PERSON OFTEN OUT OF A HOSPITAL
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS. OUT OF
WHATEVER CRISIS THERE IN WHILE
THE PROCESS FOR BEING ELIGIBLE.
DETERMINED THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON TO A I'LL BRING IT
UP TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE YOU KNOW
I WILL ASK FOR THE SPONSORS-
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED HOW YOU
WOULD EVALUATE OUTCOMES- FOR
THIS INVESTMENT. FOR YOU'VE NO
WE HAVEN'T OR ACTUALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT CA- TO THINK ABOUT
THIS I MEAN THERE ARE- SO
MEASURES IN PLACE THEY TEND TO
BE A ABOUT UNITS OF SERVICE-
AND THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO
MEASURE SO WITH THAT I MASS THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- ON HOW
THIS INVESTMENT MIGHT WORK AND
POTENTIAL TOOLS FOR EVALUATING
THE IMPACT FOR THIS
AUGMENTATION- WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE TWO WAY OPEN AND
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
PRESENT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY. CHOI
AND WE HAVE PERMANENTLY. TRY
THAT AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTERCHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER TROY ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. HI DEBBIE
THOMPSON- DEPUTY DIRECTOR ADULT
PROGRAMS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SERVICES. YOU KNOW FOO
INTRODUCTIONS GREG- GAMELY GOOD
FARM FINANCE. CHECK THE REST
HERE ELIA GREAT BEGIN PLEASE.
I'D LIKE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
THE I'D SAYS PROGRAM YES PLEASE
OKAY SO I HSS SERVICE ARE AGED
BLIND AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
BY PROVIDING PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES IN THE HOME TO PREVENT
THE NEED FOR OUT OF HOME CARE-
WE ARE ANTICIPATING TO SERVE
ABOUT- CURLY WERE SERVING OVER
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS- BUT- OVER HALF
MILLION PROVIDERS THE-
PROJECTED BUDGET FOR THIS- NEXT
YEAR CLEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
FOURTEEN POINT NINE. BILLION A
COUPLE THINGS THAT HAVE AND IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS WITH AYE IT
JUST SAYS IS A CHANGE IN THE
FUNDING STRUCTURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW AND- WE
THAT BEGAN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
AND REBATE RE BASED COUNTY
FUNDING- HAPPY TO GIVE ANY
DETAILS ON THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN. WE DID WANT TO
SHARE JUST FOR A MOMENT ABOUT
FLSA AND WHAT THE THING THAT
FOLKS HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
OVER TIME IS FILE MISSIONS-
PROVIDERS AND HOW THAT HAS
IMPACTED THEM WITH THE
TRANSITION INTO ELECTRONICS
THAT XIN OF TIME SHE'D WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
VIOLATIONS THAT FOR ARE DOING
SO THAT HAS. TO DO COME UP. WE
ALSO I'M- CAN SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OUR PER. GROUP WE AS I SAID
WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER HALF
MILLION PROVIDERS ABOUT A
LITTLE OVER HALF OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS LIVE WITH THE
RECIPIENTS THEY SERVE ABOUT 70%
OF THOSE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS.
SEE. WE ALSO IMPLEMENTED SICK
LEAVE- CURRENTLY PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING EIGHT HOURS THROUGH
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR
BEGINNING NEXT FISCAL YEAR THEY
WILL BE RECEIVING SIXTEEN
HOURS- ONCE THEY HAVE MET THE
REQUIREMENTS TO OF ACCRUING-
TIME AND- ELIGIBLE TO USE THAT
BENEFIT WE ARE STILL STILL
SEEING A FAIRLY LOW USAGE OF
THAT BUT WE ARE- IN DOING SO
ACT OUT REACH AND ACTIVITIES
TO- INSURE PEOPLE ARE EDUCATED
ABOUT- THAT BENEFIT. ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION AS
EVERYBODY'S FAMILIAR WITH- IS
IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE BEGIN WITH
THE PILOT AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY LAST JULY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS CURRENTLY. A LITTLE
OVER 99% COMPLETED- WE HAVE
BEGUN STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION
STATEWIDE WE HAVE ABOUT 80% OF
OUR- RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY USING
ELECTRONIC METHOD OF SUBMISSION
OF TIME SHEETS WE HAVE ALSO
FOUND THAT- THE ELECTRONIC
SUBMISSION COMBINED WITH USE OF
A DIRECT DEPOSIT OR ELECTRONICS.
THEIR PAYMENTS HAS LED TO AN
AVERAGE OF THREE TO FOUR DAYS
FOR PEOPLE TO GET THEIR PAYMENT
WHICH HAS BEEN A REAL BENEFIT
TO OUR PROVIDERS IN GETTING
THEIR FUNDS. BOB PLEASE PLEASE.
THOSE ARE THE PRIMARY NEW
THINGS GOING ON HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A-
REVIEW THE BUDGET ESTIMATES AND
REYES NO MAJOR CONCERNS BUT TO
JUST FLAG- COUPLE COMPONENTS
THAT MAY NEED TO BE ADJUSTED
THE FUTURE JUST GIVE IN. A MOST
RECENT ACTUAL SUCH AS HOURS PER
CASE OUR PAID SICK LEAVE
UTILIZATION BUT AS WITH EVERY
YEAR WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS- WOULD BE REFLECTED
IN MAY REVISE JUST DEPENDING ON
MOST UP TO DATE DATA. YOU KNOW
I MADE JUST FOR THE PUBLIC SAKE
SAVE- PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
PARTICULAR ISSUES WITHIN- ISSUE
FOR BUT WILL BRING THAT UP TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ONE OVER
ARCHING QUESTION. OF THE
DEPARTMENT IF I CAN AND WELL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MY QUESTION REALLY IS ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING GIVEN THAT- SOME OF THE
LARGEST PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AFFECTING SENIORS ARE WITHIN
DSS IN AYE HSS AND SS I SS P.
HOW ARE THE TWO DEPARTMENTS
COORDINATING AND WHAT IT IS.
DSS IS FINAL ROLE IN THE FINAL
PRODUCT THAT WILL BE PRESENTED
ON OCTOBER FIRST AS WELL AS ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. HI THAT WE HAVE
HAD A VERY COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT ON
AGING THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS WE
HAVE BEEN ATTENDING THE
MEETINGS ON A REGULAR BASIS
PARTICULARLY WITH A FOCUS ON
THOSE- OF THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT
SUBCOMMITTEE. AS A PART OF THAT
PROCESS WE DID TWO FIVE
INFORMATIONAL SESSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO LISTEN
TO SPECIFICALLY TO OUR
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS SORRY.
AND GOT SOME. FEEDBACK THAT IS
BEING UTILIZED TO INFORM THAT
PROCESS AS WELL SO WE CAN WE
ANTICIPATE THAT CONTINUE WITH
CONTINUING COOPERATIVE
RELATIONSHIP. PERFECT WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE THREE OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS FOR ISSUE FOR AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH ISSUE FOR A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA.
RIGHT.
MASS THE START TO BRING
A CHAIR DOWN WE CAN FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEWSDAY I'LL GET
THANKYOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE PERMIT
RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT TO IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HOURS
HSS PROVIDES CARE TOP STATES
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS LOW
INCOME SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
THIS. SO THEY MAY LIVE SAFELY
IN THE EARLY AS POSSIBLE IN
THEIR OWN HOMES THE 7% CUT WAS
INITIALLY MADE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND HAS BEEN RESTORED
THANK YOU- RESTORED.
TEMPORARILY BUT I LOST MY PLACE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND WAS INITIALLY
MADE IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AND HAS BEEN RESTORED TO
THROUGH MCO TAX AND THE GENERAL
FUND AT DIFFERENT TIMES LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET RESTORED THE CUT
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND AND
HILL DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
TAKES THAN THE RESTORATION OF
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WELL AT APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSED EXTENSION TO JUNE
TWENTY THREE IS LAW WHERE DO.
FOR THIS TO BE RISK HERMAN.
TEMPORARY OR ANNUAL RESTORATION
OF THE 7% CUTS CREATES
INSTABILITY IN THE LIVES OF
RECIPIENTS AND THEIR CARE
PROVIDERS CUTS OF ANY KIND
FORCE RECIPIENTS TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN VITAL AND IMPORTANT
SERVICES RECIPIENTS AND
PROVIDERS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
FEAR. DO YOU NOT GOING YOU
THEIR HOURS CUT OR NOT 7% CUT
MUST BE RESTORED PERMANENTLY
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WITH ME I HAVE SOME WONDERFUL%
SPONSORS TO SPEAK AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER SEVENTY RIGHT WITH
THAT YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA- ON
BEHALF OF OUR THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND LONG TERM
CARE WORKERS RESPECTFULLY HERE
TO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL WE ARE HERE AGAIN
TO ASK FOR THIS RESTORATION IT
SEEMS LIKE WE COME EVERY YEAR
TO WORK ON THIS RESEARCH. IT IS.
WE ARE ASSN THAT YOU. MAKE SURE
THAT YOU SHOW THAT. PRIORITY TO
THE STATE- WE HAVE TODAY WITH
YOU I'M SURE READ WHO WILL
SHARE HER STORY THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING HELLO CHAIRMAN AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHERRY ARE BACK AND I AM A HOME
PROVIDER FOR RANDY WHO IS
PERMANENTLY BLIND. A LITTLE
BACKGROUND STORY MY GRANDMA
BETTY PASSED AWAY ON SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE
DIED FROM FOR STAGE LUNG CANCER.
AND SHE'S THE REASON WHY I
STARTED IN HOME CARE SERVICES.
THE IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
PROGRAM PROVIDES THEY DON'T
CARE TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
SO THEY MAY LIVE SAFELY AT AND
IT AS INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE
IN THEIR OWN HOMES. A TEMPER OR
IN RESTITUTION OF THE 7% CUT.
CREATES INSTABILITY IN THE
LIVES OF CARE REPRESENT IS LIKE
MY CLIENT AND THEIR CARE
PROVIDERS LIKE ME. NOT ONLY
DOES A 7% CUTS THEIR ENDS
RANDI'S CARE BUT IT ALSO MEANS
I AM STRUGGLING TO KEEP A ROOF
OVER MY HOME PAY THE WATER BILL
AND ALSO PAY OTHER BILLS. EIGHT
CUT TO RANDY'S HOURS PUTS US
IN. AN UNSTABLE POSITION.
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
CUT TO AYE HSS THROUGH. TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WILL BRING BACK
STABILITY OF CARE AND END THE
THREAT TO BOTH CONSUMERS LIVE
AND THE CARE BEING PROVIDED MY
CLIENT RANDY SHOULD NEVER HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT WHETHER HE WILL
NOT HAVE ENOUGH HOURS OF CARE
SO TODAY I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT.
A TRUE PERMANENT RESTORATION OF
THE SOME PERCENT CUT THANK YOU
AND HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU
MA'AM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA
ANY COMMENTS. JUST TOOK CLARIFY
WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ALL OF THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS FOR AYE HSS ISSUE FOR
AT THE CONCLUSION OF HEARING
ALL OF THE PROPOSALS AND SO
WILL ASK THAT YOU IDENTIFIED
WHICH LETTER YOU'RE SPEAKING ON
WHEN YOU COME TO. SENT NEXT WE
WILL HEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOMEZ
RAY IS ON ISSUE FOUR C. D. E.
F. AND G. WE MAY GO WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU SINCE HE'S
DOING- TO BE IF THAT'S OKAY.
SHE. IT'S QUITE KIND OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOMEZ REYES.
AND. WE. BEFORE YOU BEGIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU I MAY WANT
TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT AND
FINANCE ONE QUICK QUESTION
REGARDING- FOR A IS PROPOSAL.
IS CAN THE ADMINISTRATION HELP
US- ON WHAT THE ADVOCATES ARE
PROPOSING. WHICH IS THERE ARE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT WOULD DISCONNECT
THE MCO FROM THE 7% REDUCTION.
FINANCE WE COULD DEFINITELY
TAKE A LOOK AT CURRENT STATUTE.
I AM I UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT CONNECTED THE INFIELD
ANYMORE WHEN WE'D THIS AND- WE
DID WE DID AWAY WITH THAT CCI
CARBONATED INITIATIVE BUT UP TO
GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
BUT TO EXTENT THAT THAT'S THE
CASE COULD DEFINITELY
CONVERSATION AND- THEY'RE OUT
WAYS BECAUSE- WE ARE FUNDING.
THE 7% WITH ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO THE EXTENT THAT TO THAT
SUSPENSION DATES SO THERE IS NO
MORE SESSION ABOUT THE UNSEALED
ACT IN THAT REGARD. GREAT WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHU ON ISSUE
FOUR B. CHECK YOUR MISTER
CHAIRS AND REMEMBERS. I'M HERE
TO FOR OF ASK REQUEST TO COME
MEET HE APPROVED FLOOD REQUEST.
OF A HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND
ANNUALLY IN GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE PAID SICK
LEAVE. TO WAVER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES ONLY OR W. P. C. S.
ONLY PROVIDERS. AS YOU ALL KNOW
THAT W. PCS PROVIDER PROVIDE
CARE TO PEOPLE IN NEED OF
ADDITIONAL IN HOME CARE TO I.
H. S. S. SERVICES. WHAT THEY
PROVIDE THE SAME SERVICES
ASPECT I H. S. S. PROVIDERS
PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE ONLY THAT W.
PC SERVICES AND NOT THE I. H.
S. S. SERVICES WERE LEFT OUT.
OF TO PROVISION OF PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR I. H. EXCESS WORKERS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. THIS HAS
LEFT W. PEAS. C. S. ONLY
PROVIDER SB ONLY WORKERS WITH
ALL **** TO PAID SICK LEAVE
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW. WE ALL
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT ACCESS TO
PAY SEEK TO LEAVE IS TO BOTH
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND THE WORK
PLACES. THIS LEAVE NOT ONLY GIG
GIVE PEOPLE TIME TO BE HEALTHY.
BUT PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING
OTHERS THE WORKPLACE. SICK THIS
IS THE PARTICULAR BROTHERHOOD
ROAD RELEVANT AS WE ARE TRYING
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF THE-
OWNER BY. W. PCS AND I. HSS
PROVIDERS ARE SERVING SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PART
LESIONS. AT TO BE ABLE TO TAKES
SIX SIX TOP AND WITH. ONE OF
ALL LOSING THEIR PAY THEIR DAY.
WE CANNOT HAVE PEOPLE TRAIPSING
BETWEEN STAYING HOME WHEN SICK.
AND PAYING THEIR BILLS. THIS
IS- IMPAIR TO COME MEET KEY HOW.
EN AND IN WORKERS ARE YOU
COOLEY TO ARE HOW THE- BUT TEN
THE LONG TERM CARE TO FOR S. CI
YOU CALL OF. AND CHAT DAVIS OF
WAIVER PER. PERSONAL CARE
PROVIDER TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST. MR JR MEMBERS TO
ANYONE WITH THAT SAY YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE WORKERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL WITH
THE FOR MY TIME TO OUR W. PCS
ONLY PROVIDER CHAT DAVIS THANK
YOU. GOOD MORE GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN AND OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY MISTER DAVIS. AND
I AM A WAIVER PERSONAL CARE
PROVIDER MY CLAIM GLENN HE HE
IS. MY CLIENT GLENN IS MY CLICK
LANE IS AND WILL THE TREATMENTS
ARE. TAKE YOUR TIME BROTHER
YEAH THE TIME BUT- MY CLAN
GLENN AND HE IS QUALIFIED FOR
THE DOUBLE PS- DOUBLE PCS
PROGRAM BECAUSE HE'S
PARAPLEGIC. ANY REQUIRES EIGHT
TO TEN HOURS PERSONAL CARE
EVERY DAY. GLENN MOM GLENN'S
MOM AND- LANDMARK GLENN'S MOM
IS I JUST AS PROVIDER AND I AM
THE ADDITIONAL OUR HE RECEIVES
TO DALY PCS I HAVE KNOWN GLENN
FOR OVER TWO YEARS. AND HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING CARE FOR HIM
EVER SINCE. SIX DAYS A WEEK I
PROVIDE GLENN. WITH THE CARE HE
NEEDS TO STAY SAFE SAFELY IN
HIS HOME. THIS INCLUDES
ASSISTANCE WITH ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING LIKE TAKING CARE
OF HIS APPOINTMENTS
HOUSEKEEPING TASKS AND
STRETCHING AND TRANSFERRING HIM.
WITHOUT THE CARE FROM ME AND
HIS MOM. GLEN GLEN WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO REMAIN IN HIS HOME I
WANT TO BE AT MY BEST FOR GLENN
BUT THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
WORK TO DO IF I CANNOT CARE FOR
MYSELF. WHEN I'M ILL. GOING TO
WORK WHEN I AM SEEK PUTS GLAND
AT RISK AND MY WORK SUFFERS.
THAT THIS THAT THIS IS WHY I AM
HERE TODAY I AM ASKING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE ALLOWS MY
BROTHER AND SISTERS IN THE
DOUBLE PCS PROGRAM TO HAVE ACT
ACCESS TO THE STATE'S SICK
LEAVE LAW THAT EVERY OTHER
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA IS
ENTITLED TO. INCLUDING THE I'D
JUST AS PROVIDERS. THERE ARE
LESS THAN ONE THOUSAND DOUBLE
PCS ONLY WORKERS STATEWIDE WAR
EIGHT EXCLUDED FROM THE LET
THIS LAW. IF THE STATE DOES NOT
MAKE THIS SMALL BUT CRUCIAL
INVESTMENT. PROVIDERS WILL
PROVIDERS LIKE ME WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CONTINUES CARE
FOR OUR CLIENTS LIKE GLENN
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND
PLEASE REMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
VOTING YOU KNOW FOR THIS DOUBLE
PCS TO INCLUDE ME IN GLENN AND
JUST THINK ABOUT US THANK YOU
AND GOD BLESS. THANK YOU SIR-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA YOU.
SEEING I DON'T WANT TO FORGET
THE SS IN THIS DISCUSSION IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD. SOME
I GUESS MY ONLY QUESTION IF I
CAN IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CAN YOU VERIFY THE
COST FOR THIS PROPOSAL. WE NEED
A WORKER DSS TO LOOK AT THE
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL ON THE
ASSUMPTION SO WOULD DEFINITELY
BE HAPPY TO TALK TO TIFFANY
GROUP ABOUT THIS. I'LL JUST ADD
THAT THIS PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
OPERATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO WE DO
THE PAYROLL FOR W. PCS SO WE
HAVE SOME OVERLAP THERE AND WE
WILL WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH
FINANCE AND THEM TO CONFIRM
THAT. DATA FOR YOU. THANK YOU
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
FOR PRESENTING. WITH THAT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE FOR C.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE-
NICOLE AND CINDY. I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR
THIS AS YOU KNOW I HSS WORKERS
ARE IMPERATIVE PART OF OUR
SYSTEM AND THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO BOTH RELY ON MY
HSS ON THE AYE HSS SYSTEM AND
WHO ARE THE CARE GIVERS THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE GROWING. HSS
WERE CARE GIVERS HAVE ALWAYS
RUN INTO PREDICAMENTS WITH
LOCAL COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE
KNOW THIS PROCESS TO BE ONE
THAT IS DIFFICULT FOR THE
PARTIES INVOLVED. IN THE
200-019-2000 TWENTY FISCAL YEAR
THE PROCESS OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ONLY BECAME
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT WHEN THE
STATE REVERSED THE COST SHARING
FORMULA TO BECOME 65% COUNTY.
AND 35% STATE BEGINNING AS OF
JANUARY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT WE WERE SEND THESE CHANGES
IN ORDER TO RETAIN THE CURRENT
SHARE OF COST FORMULA.INTO THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. WITH ME. TO
TESTIFY OR- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
VERY WELL KNOWN TO THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. UGH THANK
YOU SIMPLY MEMBER- THIS
PROPOSAL SEE REALLY ADDRESSES-
THE CHANGE ADOPTED LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD FLIP THE COUNTY
STATE SURE OF BECAUSE- OF THE
NON FEDERAL SHARE FROM WHAT IT
IS CURRENTLY WHICH IS SIXTY
FIVE STATE THIRTY FIVE COUNTY
TO BE SIXTY FIVE COUNTY THIRTY
FIVE STATE. WE'RE WE'RE ASKING
TO RESCIND THAT CHANGE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE WITH GETTING ANY AMOUNT OF
MONEY INVESTED INTO AYE HSS
WAGES WILL BE COMPOUNDED
FURTHER OR WHEN THEY SURE COST
INCREASES THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THANKS FOR
YEAH FINANCE TELL YOU ECOGNIZE
CONCERNED BROUGHT UP BY OUR
LABOR PARTNERS- BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE JUST RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED L. HASN'T TAKEN
EFFECT YET- BUT WE WILL LIKE TO
AT LEAST HAVE THIS IMPLEMENTED
AND MONITOR THE CARD. ONE
HUNDRED AND TO ACCEPT THAT
THERE ARE ANY CONCERNS AND IF
YOU THROUGH A LOT OF THIS
CONVERSATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S YOU KNOW DOESN'T HAVE THE
IMPACT OF. NOTE IT TURNING A
KIND OF GLACIATION WITH LABOR
AND THE COUNTIES BUT LET US OUR
PREFERENCE WOULD BE TO TURN OUT
TO LET US IMPLEMENT THIS
PERSON. LET US MINOR. LA. IS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES OR DO LAUGH- MAKE A
COMMENT REGARDING THE COST
NEUTRALITY OF THIS PROPOSAL. I
AM THE T IS CORRECT THAT WITH
THE REMOTE BEING ANY DROP ON
IMPACT WE DON'T WE DON'T MAKE
ANY ASSUMPTIONS I FUTURE
NEGOTIATION BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT WOULD ENTAIL- SO
THAT IS CORRECT BUT- I THINK AT
THE MOMENT FOR. MAIL FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE MADE A LOT
OF INVESTMENTS AND- THE STATE
IN ITSELF HAS MADE A LOT
INVESTMENTS AND I SUGGEST WITH
MINIMUM WAGE AND- WILL CONTINUE
TO MAKE THIS INVESTMENT AS- A
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES DUE TO A
COLLECTIVE SO IF THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE A- NON FEDERAL
SHARE- SO. YOU'RE RIGHT THERE
IS. NO WE DON'T REJECT ANY
KINDA IMPACT AT THE MALL
BECAUSE OF THIS. I WANT TO
CLARIFY LITTLE BIT I THOUGHT
YOUR COMMENT WAS ON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE IT WAS REGARDING. THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE US BEING
COST NEUTRAL AND SO JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE ABOUT THAT SIR.
YES THE PROPOSAL IN ITSELF
DOESN'T HAVE ANY FISCAL IMPACT
THE LIKE THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T-
PREDICT- IN OUR MULTI YEAR
FUNDING WE DON'T PREDICT.
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND- BECAUSE RIGHT NOW COUNTIES
HAVE A SHARE OF COSTS ONE WAY.
WHEN THEY HAVE A NEW INCREASE
IN THEIR WAGES SO BUT WE DON'T
MAKE THOSE PREDICTIONS BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA.
HAPPEN WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE FOR D. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THE SAME VEIN
OF ENSURING THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AT LOCAL
LEVELS ARE HAPPENING IN A
REASONABLE TIME AND WITH GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS WE REQUESTED
COUNTIES BE REQUIRED TO
PUBLICLY DISCLOSE VENDOR
CONTRACTS ASSOCIATED WITH AYE
HSS NEGOTIATIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
IS COME TO OUR ATTENTION THAT
SOME COUNTIES CONTRACT WITH
ANTI UNION LAW FIRMS TO
REPRESENT THEM AND I HSS
NEGOTIATIONS AND THESE OF
COURSE ARE FUNDED BY TAXPAYERS
TRANSPARENCY ON THESE ISSUES IS
PARAMOUNT PARTICULARLY ONE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE INVOLVED
THIS IS WHY WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT THERE BE A MANDATE OF
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE REGARDING
COSTS PAID BY COUNTIES FOR
VENDOR CONTRACTS USED FOR AYE
HSS NEGOTIATIONS WE MUST KNOW
HOW COUNTIES OR SPEND THESE
DOLLARS. HOW MUCH THEY ARE
SPENDING TO NEGOTIATE THESE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS. THIS PAST SUMMER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
REALIZE I DIDN'T INTRODUCE
MYSELF BEFORE A CRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON- WITH YOU YOU W. ASKED
ME REPRESENTING HUNDRED SIXTEEN
THOUSAND I JUST AS PROVIDERS
AND TWENTY ONE COUNTIES I DO
WANT TO ALSO SAY THAT WE-
DIDN'T BRING OUR FOLKS TODAY
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS AROUND A
COAL BID. NINETEEN SO. YES SO
THIS ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH THE
PHENOMENON AND THIS IS IN IN
EVERY COUNTY BUT A NUMBER OF
THEM WERE THEY WILL OUTSOURCE
THE ACTUAL NEGOTIATIONS TO-
USUALLY A LAW FIRM THERE IS-
ANOTHER VENDOR THAT IS NOT A
LAW FIRM BUT- AS A STAND SIMPLY
THEY- ARE OUTSOURCING THE-
ACTUAL NEGOTIATIONS BUT- IN
CASES WHERE THESE. NEGOTIATIONS
GO ON FOR YEARS AND YEARS. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THEY'RE PAYING
ESPECIALLY TO THE LAW FIRMS WHO
CHARGE TO THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AN HOUR WHEN YOU ADD THAT UP
COMPARE TO WHAT THE COST WOULD
HAVE BEEN TO JUST INCREASE. THE
WAGES OF THE WORKERS THAT YOU
ACTUALLY DON'T FIND THAT MUCH
OF A FISCAL DIFFERENCE THERE
AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE
PROPOSING DISCLOSURE IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE FILED FOR. THE FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION ACT REQUESTS TO
ACTUALLY DETERMINE WHAT THE
COSTS ARE AND IT'S BEEN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT BASED ON
WHAT WE RECEIVED AND WE HAVE
HAD SEVERAL COUNTIES THAT
REFUSED TO SEND IT TO US- TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT THE A
LINE ITEM IS FOR I JUST AS-
BARGAINING SO WE BELIEVE. THAT
IN CASES FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
COUNTY WERE BURNING HAS BEEN
GOING ON SIX YEARS AND YOU KNOW
THERE ARE FOR THAT REPRESENT
MULTI COUNTIES. THAT THE
ACTUALLY CREW A VERY. EIGHT BIT
IS PLAN. FOR JUST TRAINING A
CON SOURCE OF INCOME BY VIRTUE
OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS JUST
GOING ON AND ON THANK YOU. CAN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TELL US WHAT YOU THINK
OF THIS PROPOSAL. HI. BUT DALY
DIFFERENT WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
POSITIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL THAT
THE TIME. DOES THE DOES THE
MANDATE ON COUNTIES WORK FOR
FROM THE STATE ADMINISTRATION
PERSPECTIVE. WHAT WHAT THE 80%
MANDATE WORK FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION. NOT QUITE SURE
WHAT I'M GETTING QUIRK AGAIN
THAT SIR- THE PROPOSAL REQUIRES
TRANSPARENCY IF IT'S GOING TO
EXCEED 80% OF THE TOTAL COST OF
WAGE AND BENEFIT INCREASES THAT
SOMETHING THE- ADMINISTRATION.
DO. I'M NOT SURE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU I THINK OF ROTH THE
MANDATE THE COUNTY TO DO
ANYTHING THERE'S A COSTS ABOUT
PEACE THERE FOR THEM TO DO THE
ACTIVITY BUT- YEAH WILL HAVE TO
GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
BUT I. CAN'T GIVE YOU A
DIFFERENT ANSWER MOM- AS WITH
THE PREVIOUS ON THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSAL THE ADVOCATES ASSERT
THAT THERE'S NO GENERAL FUND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND
SO WE JUST. ASK THE DEPARTMENT
TO PROVIDE SOME TECHNICAL-
EXPERTISE IF YOU CAN SO THAT WE
CAN TRY TO ASSERTIF THAT'S A
REALITY. I WOULD JUST BELIEVE
THAT ON WILL HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS TO BUT OVERALL I
THINK ON THE STATE THERE MIGHT
NOT BE AND BUT IF YOU'D LIKE
THAT IF YOU'D REQUIRE THE
COUNTY TO DO ANYTHING AND-
THERE WILL BE A FISCAL IMPACT
THE TO LOCAL MANDATE SO. JUST
TAKING THAT TO CONSIDERATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I'D
RATHER. PAY WORKERS THAN
LAWYERS JUST AS A GENERAL
PRINCIPLE AND SOME WITH THAT AS
A LAWYER I THINK THAT'S STILL A
GOOD IDEA. WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO MOVE ON TO FORTY PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WELL WE
DISCUSS FINDINGS TO WAKE I'M
SORRY WELL WE DISCUSS FINDINGS
FINDING WAYS TO MAKE THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
MORE FEASIBLE AND TRANSPARENT
WE ALSO MUST ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FINALLY INCENTIVIZING WAGE AND
BENEFIT INCREASES FOR OUR AYE
HSS PROVIDERS. I HSS WORKERS
PROVIDE A CRUCIAL SERVICE WHILE
SERVING OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND I HSS RECIPIENTS
THEY'RE ALSO MAJORITY OF WOMEN
OF COLOR WHO MAKE ON AVERAGE
ABOUT THIRTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
AND HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO
HEALTH AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
THIS IS LEADING TO A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF AYE HSS PROVIDERS
AROUND THE STATE DURING THE
TIME WHEN WE NO THE POPULATION
OF RECIPIENTS IN NEED OF AYE
HSS IS GROWING. SOME WOULD SAY
IT IS CRIMINAL THAT THESE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO KEEPING COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
DIGNITY ARE BEING PAID SO
LITTLE. ONE HAS TO WONDER IF
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THIS
WORKFORCE FOR DIFFERENT WOULD
WE STILL BE HAVING TO DISCUSS
IN ADEQUATE COMPENSATION AND
WOULD WE STILL HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE GOOD FAITH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING SO MANY YEARS LATER.
REINSTATING XCELERATED CASELOAD
GROWTH APPROACH WILL HELP
INCENTIVIZE WAGE AND BENEFIT
INCREASE FOR THESE PROVIDERS
WHO FOR TOO LONG HAVE BEEN
DOING INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
WORK FOR LESS THAN A LIVING
WAGE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WOULD
COST THE STATE NOTHING. THANK
YOU CHRISTINE ABOUT. THIS VERY
SIMPLY JUST GETS REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS INTO THE HANDS OF
COUNTIES AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IN ORDER TO SERVER A COMMON
ARGUMENT THAT WE HERE AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE WHICH IS THEY
CAN'T WAIT. THE TRADITIONAL
EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD IN ORDER
TO GET THOSE FUNDS AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY THEY CAN'T DO
WAGE INCREASES THANK YOU. THE
HIGHER EARLY RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT PROPOSALS APPEAR FROM
ADVOCATES I DO GOT TO RAISE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL MORE FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE- CONCERN FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCES SIZZLE THIS
IS A TV A PROP PROCESS. IN
TERMS OF GETTING THE DATA AND
THE NETWORK AROUND THE SO
ALTHOUGH WE- DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THE MOMENT WE DO
THINK THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME-
NEED FOR IT RESOURCES LEASE AT
DEPARTMENT FIND SO I HAVE TO
CONSULT WITH MY- FOLKS AT
CONTROLLER. CONTROL OFFICE ON
THIS BUT THIS IS THE VERY
TEDIOUS PROCESS IN ORDER TO. BE
TO STATUS WITH THAT SO WOULD
YOU VERIFY THAT THERE'S COST
NEUTRALITY WITH THIS PROPOSAL
OR DO YOU THINK THERE IS A COST
WITH THIS IN IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE REALIGNMENT SHIFT THERE IS
NO CAN JUMP ON IMPACT AND THE
LIKE THAT IF THERE IS THIS THIS
IS ADDITIONAL WORK LOW THAT
WILL HAVE TO TAKE UPON AND THAT
FOR THE FIRST GOING BACK WOULD
BE. CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE LAG
TIME THAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT REGARDING. CASELOAD GROSS
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT-
EXACERBATES ISSUES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- MEANT WE- THERE IS A LAG
TIME TO THE HOW IT WORKS BUT
THIS IS HOW IT'S ALWAYS WORKED
FOR. A LONG TIME SINCE SINCE
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT WE
DIDN'T MAKE A CHEF. RECENTLY AT
ONE WITH THE- WE ADJUST THE
JETTA NAME A WEEK THAT THE CCI.
BUT WENT BACK TO THE OLD WAYS
OF DOING THINGS AND IF. YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE IS A LAG TIME. SO
RECOGNIZE THAT- BUT OVERALL.
THIS OUR REALIGNMENT FUNNY SO
THERE IS NO IMPACT ON. A LEASE
TO TRY AND SIGN. WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR E. OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO FOR HALF. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I JUST SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE WORKING WITH
RECIPIENTS WHO HAVE A DIVERSE
ARRAY OF MEDICAL EMOTIONAL AND
SOCIAL NEEDS FURTHERMORE EACH
COUNTY WILL HAVE A SLEW OF
REQUIREMENTS WERE EXPECTATIONS
FOR EACH IHS US FIGHTER IN
ADDITION TO STATE REQUIREMENTS
AND EXPECTATIONS WE WANT TO SET
UP OUR EIGHT AYE HSS PROVIDERS
FOR SUCCESS WHICH IS WHY WE
PASSED SB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN. AS
A PILOT PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE BILL TO PROVIDERS
TO NEGOTIATE THE STRUCTURE TIME
AND OF ACCESS TO NEW EMPLOYEE
TRAINERS IS CRUCIAL IN ENSURING
AYE HSS PROVIDERS ARE RECEIVING
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION TO
SUCCESS IN THEIR JOBS. I
BELIEVE ORIENTATIONS ARE
IMPERATIVE TO ANY GROUP SUCCESS
THIS IS WHY WHEN WE GET NEW
STAFF THEY ARE SENT OFF TO A
MYRIAD OF ORIENTATIONS AND
TRAININGS AT THE CAPITOL
INSTITUTE. OR ONE STUDENT OF
STUDENT ENTERS. A NEW COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY THEY HAVE DAYS OF
ORIENTATION IT'S BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE PEOPLE CAN'T BE
EXPECTED TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
SYSTEMS WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION AND TRAINING. THAT
IS WHY WE ARE ASKING THE
SUCCESSFUL THREE COUNTY PILOT
BE MADE PERMANENT AND EXPANDED
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES
GIVING PROVIDERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE TO
NEGOTIATION. TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE ORIENTATION NEEDS ARE WILL
BETTER SUPPORT THEM AND THE AYE
HSS RECIPIENTS IN THE LONG RUN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS OF
BASIC THIS PROPOSAL OF IS VERY
BASIC TO EXPAND THE PILOT TO
ALL COUNTIES AND MAKE IT
PERMANENT BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU. SIMILAR
QUESTION AS WE'VE HAD BEFORE
CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES OR FINANCE VERIFY THE
COST NEUTRALITY OF HIS PROPOSED.
YEAH THEY'RE BASED ON MY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE DID WITH
THE PILOT THERE IS NO COST TO
THE STATE PUTS AN END. KIND OF-
MEDICATION EFFORT WILL BE PAID
FOR BY THE COUNTIES AND PAY FOR
BY LABOR UNIONS AS THEY SEEK
BILLS. SERVICES WITH THAT THIS
IS WELL RECEIVED AND WILL MOVE
ON TO FOUR G. THANK YOU.
FINALLY THE INCREASED AS G. IS
TO INCREASE THE PENALTY FOR
COUNTY COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
IMPASSES. LAST YEAR WE WERE
ABLE OF SORRY WE WERE ENGAGED
IN LONG CONVERSATIONS
SURROUNDING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IMPASSES BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND I HSS PROVIDERS
SOME HAD BEEN WITHOUT A NEW
CONTRACT FOR SIX YEARS. HOURS
OF DISCUSSIONS IN THIS VERY
ROOM ON HOW WE WOULD BEST
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO ENTERED
TO THESE MUCH NEEDED COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS WITH THE
IMPERATIVE WORKFORCE THAT IS A
TO SAYS I HSS PROVIDERS. OUR
CONCLUSION WAS TO ESTABLISH A
ONE TIME FISCAL PENALTY OF 1%
OF THE COUNTIES I HSS MOE FOR
COUNTIES WHO DID NOT ENTER INTO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS PRIOR TO A CERTAIN
DATE. UNFORTUNATELY THE STILL
VERY LITTLE TO MOVE MOST
COUNTIES TO ENTER INTO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WHILE THE STICK
VERSUS CARROT APPROACH WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN THEORY THE REALITY
IS A ONE TIME PENALTY OF THAT
SIZE DID NOT WORK AS AN
INCENTIVE FOR MANY COUNTIES. IN
SOME CASES IT WAS CHEAPER TO
PAY THE 1% PENALTY RATHER THAN
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH. THIS
IS WHY WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
ONE TIME FISCAL PENALTY BE
SHIFTED TO AN ANNUAL PENALTY OF
7% OF THE COUNTIES I. H. S. S.
M. O. E. THIS WILL HOPEFULLY
PUSHED COUNTIES WHO PREVIOUSLY
WORKED FINALIZING THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS. TO FINALIZE THEM.
WE CANNOT KEEP PUSHING OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS FOR A WORKFORCE THAT
IS SO CRUCIAL FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE TAKE EVERY STEP TO
SUPPORT AYE HSS FIGHTERS. IN
THE IMPORTANT WORK THEY ARE
DOING. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU A- THANK YOU- AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AT EIGHTY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TAKE THIS FROM A
HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE- WE HAVE
ACTUATION SO WHERE COUNTIES
HAVE MADE CLEAR THAT THEY DO
NOT PRIORITIZE I JUST SAYS THEY
ACTUALLY BUYS THE FACT THEY
HAVE TO I AGES. DON'T BELIEVE
FAMILY MEMBERS SHOULD GET PAID
FOR DOING I JUST A SERVICES AND
THERE'S VERY LITTLE THAT WE CAN
DO TO FORCE THEIR HAND IF THEY
ARE THE MAJORITY ON THEIR
COUNTY BOARDS AND SO IT PUSHES
US TO COME TO THE STATE YEAR IN
AND YEAR OUT AND CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS I
CAN'T COUNT TIMES I'VE BEEN ON
THIS THIS I WISH THIS WAS NOT
THE SITUATION BUT THIS IS WHERE
WE ARE. WE TO MAKE IT CLEAR
FROM THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE
THAT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
RESULTING IN A WORK FORCE
CRISIS WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOT
INCENTIVIZED TO DO THIS WORK
BECAUSE THEY CAN GO TO THE IN
N. OUT BURGER AND MAKE TWO
DOLLARS MORE AN HOUR AND A
HALF. BATHS NO ONE IS GOING TO
TAKE ON THE JOB AND I JUST SAYS
WORKER FOR MINIMUM WAGE UNLESS
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEY-
DO SO OUT OF THE KINDNESS OF
THEIR HEART. AND SO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS INSURE WITH OUR
AGING POPULATION THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH FOLKS OUT THERE WILLING
TO DO THIS WORK AND THE ONLY
WAY YOU DO IT IS BY MAKING THE
WAGES COMPETITIVE AT LEAST
COMPETITIVE. WITH RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS SO THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT CREATING A
SCENARIO WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE YEARS OF DRAGGING THESE
THINGS ON. AND TO CONCLUDE. THE
REASON WE HAVE BEEN GETTING
SUCCESS IN SOME OF THESE
COUNTIES WE HAVE WRAPPED UP A
NUMBER OVER THE LAST YEAR IS
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED. POLITICAL PRESSURE.
YOU KNOW I NEED NUMBER OF ITEMS
THAT HAVE HAD TO TAKE PLACE AND
FEAR THAT WE WILL ACTUALLY GET
THIS NEW PENALTY WHICH IS
MOTIVATING THEM TO GET THIS
STUFF RESULT. YOU SHOULDN'T
TAKE BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS TO
GET TO THIS POINT THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY AND RESOURCES THAT ARE
EXPENDED. WHEN THEY COULD JUST
BE INVESTING INTO THE WORK THAT
IS FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
SOCIETY WE CAN BY PASS ALL OF
THIS. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISS SOMETHING. EIGHT
SING THEIR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN REACTION TO THIS PROPOSAL
SINCE IT DIRECTLY IMPACTS
COUNTIES- ON I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
COMMITMENT DEVICE AS PROVIDER
WORKFORCE. AND SPONSORED ALL
THESE PROPOSALS. OVERALL
COUNTIES REMAIN GRATEFUL FOR
THE NEW AND WE STRUCTURE THAT
WAS ENACTED LAST YEAR THAT
PREVENTED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF REALIGNMENT
SHORTFALL IN ANOTHER MESSAGE
THAT CAME ACROSS CLEARLY WITH
THAT WAS THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTS AND SEEN AN INCREASED
NUMBER. OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS WITH ISAF
PROVIDERS AND I'M PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT THAT IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING COUNTIES- THE OTHER.
COUNTY NARRATIVE THIS OUT THERE
THAT I'M SEEN FIRST HAND IS THE
COMMITMENT OF A NUMBER OF
COUNTY SUPERVISORS TO THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM. TO PROTECT
AND AVAILABLE RESIDENTS INTO
MOVING FORWARD- WAGE INCREASES
FOR I JUST PROVIDERS THERE'S
BEEN FOURTEEN NEW. AGREEMENT
SINCE JULY FIRST IS FAR ABOVE
THE IN STORE PASTIES ARE
AGREEMENTS AND URBAN SUBURBAN
AND RURAL COUNTIES FRESNO. THE
SAN BERNADINO. RIVERS MARIPOSA
HUMBOLDT I'M- COUNTIES- SO
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF REACH NEW AGREEMENTS IT
TOTAL COUNTIES ARE INVESTING
MORE THAN FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN CASH FUNDING
WAITING. TO GO TO TAKE EFFECT
THIS HAS ON MORE THAN SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
INVESTED. FOR WAGE INCREASES
THAT WAY THE FACT. HERE
STATEWIDE IT WENT OUT A POINT
WHERE I NEARLY NINE IN TEN ISIS
PROVIDERS WORKING COUNTY THAT
HAS A CURRENT AGREEMENT SO
WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF THE
PROBLEM THE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
MADE. I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE STILL NOT COUNTY WHERE
THERE. REMAINS. WERE SO. FULL
IN. REACH TO INITIATE BARGAIN.
BARGAINING WE HAVE SOME
COUNTIES IT TRIED TO REACH ON
IT IN ADVANCE OF HAVING AN
EXPIRED COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT BUT THE UNION WASN'T
READY TO ENGAGE AND THAT'S FINE
AND NOW THEY'RE STARTING THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL SEE AGREEMENTS THERE. AND
THEN THERE ARE SMALL LIMITED
NUMBER OF COUNTIES- WITH THIS
BEEN ACTIVE- NEGOTIATIONS FOR A
NUMBEROF YEARS AND THEY STILL
DON'T HAVE AN AGREEMENT- THAT
DOESN'T MEAN COUNTY. BARGAINING
BAD FAITH. BARGAINING IN GOOD
pSTATE WAGES OUR WAGE INCREASES
THERE DOES NOT THE OFFERS THAT
UM. THE UNION. KENYAN SO
THERE'S SOME DISAGREEMENT THERE
BETWEEN WHAT'S BEING OFF ON IT
SO. THERE IS A- FOR THAT PLAY
OUT WHAT WE KNOW. LAST YEAR
IT'S A FOR STEP. COUNTY HAS A
AN X. AGREEMENT THEY MUST GO TO
MEDIATE. FACT FINDING- THERE'D
FACTFINDER MUST YOU RECOMMEND.
MORE FAVORABLE TO THE UNION AND
THE NEXT NINETY DAYS TO REACH A
FINAL AGREEMENT. FOR COUNTIES
THAT WEREN'T ALREADY IT IMPACTS
PRIDE THE NEW. WE HAPPENED YET
TEST THIS. OR ONLY IT STEP ONE
OF FOUR. AND IS VERY. AMOUNT OF
CASH THAT MAKE THEIR- WE THINK
THAT PROCESS. HAS IT TO WORK AS
A TO. PROVIDE COUNTY. TOLD GET
TO AN ANGRY. AND WE WOULD.
STRONGLY WAS INCREASING THE PEN
AMOUNT. THE PRICE HAS. EVEN TO.
AND I GUESS THE OTHER I WOULD
SAY IS I BELIEVE THERE WOULD. A
FOR COSTS OF THIS FROM I THINK
THE ADVOCATES. INDICATE THAT
THE- OF ALL THOSE TWO IN. THE
OF COLLECTIVE. AGREEMENTS AND
IF HAPPENS EVERY TIME. COUNTIES
INCREASE WAY TO THERE IS JUST
GENERAL FOR COSCO THE STATE PAY
A PART OF THE AS WELL SO JUST
IN TERMS OF CAN. OF THE
PROPOSED WE BELIEVE VIA. ACOSTA
WHICH IS NOT A- ME. IN THIS ONE
THOUSAND TIMES I WISH NOW THAT
I'M WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION. DEPARTMENT LA
AND THEY THOUGHT. YOU KNOW IF I
pI THIS NEEDS TO AND INTO THE
COLLECT BARGAINING SPACE AND
GET US A WAVE FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT IN A- AND BORDER
SUPER AND SO WHAT ENCOURAGE US
PART. AS WE MOVED A NEW WAY WE
OUR OLD FUN THE FOR THE STATE
TO RECONSIDER THE PROPOSAL AND
THAT MAY HELP TO ALLEVIATE OF
THE CONCERNS AM. APPRECIATIVE
THAT IT TOOK. THE LETTERS WORK
THOUGH GETTING ARRESTED FOR
FRESNO COUNTY TO RECEIVE AN A
CONTRACT. BUT I DO THINK WE
HAVE TO DO MORE SO THAT
COUNTIES LIKE KERN AND COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT. THE STATE ARE ABLE
TO DO IT I AM APPRECIATIVE THAT
NINE OUT OF TEN. LACES I HSS
WORKERS ARE NOW IN CURRENT
CONTRACTS THAT IS MOVING THE
NEEDLE FORWARD FROM WHERE WE
WERE LAST YEAR- BUT WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE. FOUR G.
OPEN FOR NOW AND WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN ON ALL
PROPOSALS UNDER ISSUE FOR THIS
TIME. I'M JUST TRYIN- BE
SPECIFIC IF YOU CAN REGARDING
WHICH PROPOSAL IT'S ON. JEFF
TORTILLA I NOT RECEIVE I US
BECAUSE THERE IS MUCH PAPERWORK
TO START IT OUT. HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL IMPROVE BUT THIS NEEDS TO
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE HE
POPULATION THAT'S NEEDED THE
NEEDS ARE FAR GREATER THAN YOU
WHICH YOU HAVE THE JOB
POPULATION. THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAVE
ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT OF ALL ISSUE ITEMS
UNDER NUMBER FOUR EIGHT THREE
G. I WOULD ONLY LIKE TO NOTE-
THAT WE HAVE PUT IN A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING FOR STATEWIDE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND WHAT
ALSO NOTE THAT LASSEN IS THE
ONLY COUNTY THAT TOLD US
DIRECTLY THAT THEY WOULD RATHER
JUST PAY THE PENALTY. SO A 7%
INCREASE WOULD BENEFIT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. I WAS
THERE. AND YOUR PLANS WITH THE
ARGONAUT WILL POST A CAL.
CLEVER SPEAKING TO ITEM FOR A-
PERMANENT. FOR REST AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S ALL. AN I THE DD BUDGET.
AND ALTHOUGH THE WAS PUTS.
THAT'S A- IT'S STILL CREATES
INSTEAD. FOR P. DISABILITIES.
THERE FOR. SUPPORT STAFF. AND
THE LAST. THEY NEED IS MORE
INSTABILITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU UP MORE
MOTOR FAMILY THIS CALL
DISBELIEF YOU'RE COMING ACTION.
NETWORK MIGHT HAD I THINK I
MENTIONED BEFORE HOME CARE BUT
ALSO RECEIVE MEDI CAL AND
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES SO WE
KNOW WHAT IT IS WHEN THERE ARE
BARRIERS AND WHAT IT MEANS BUT
WE ALSO KNOW WHEN THOSE
BARRIERS TO REMOVE WHAT THAT
MEANS. ONE I'M REALLY QUICKLY
ON. JUST WANT TO. A PRAISE THE-
TEAM. BOTH SEND DEB AND
EVERYBODY THE AND THE INPUT
FACE ONE I THINK THEY DIDN'T
VERY SENSITIVE WAY THAT THEY
LISTENED I WAS PART OF ALMOST
EVERY ONE OF THOSE STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS INCLUDING LISTENING
SESSIONS. JUSTWANTED JUST
RAISE THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
MONITOR THE RIGHTS OF PRIVACY
OF THE OF THE PERSON RECEIVING
SERVICES AS WELL AS A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY OF THE WORKER AND
SPECIALLY IN FACE TO WHICH
INCLUDES REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES LAUGHING ON THE ON THE
SEVEN PERCENT. I SUPPORT ALL
THE ADVOCACY PURPOSE THE BUT
THE 7% RESTORATION- SET THAT.
BE BEAT UP PERMANENT. WE MAKE
IT IN. HARD WHEN ADVOCATES.
HAVE TO COME EVERY YEAR TO
PLEAD FOR SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
AND WE HAVE TO JUSTIFY IT AND
WE'RE STILL OFTEN TOLD NO. WE
SHOULD MAKE IT AT LEAST AS
HARD. TO MAKE REDUCTIONS.
PEOPLE MAKE IT LEASES HARD AND
MAKE AND FORCE WHOEVER'S
PROPOSAL TO REDUCTIONS TO MAKE
IT IN REAL TIME. IN THE REAL
LIFE SITUATIONS HAPPENING AT
THAT MOMENT AND MAKE THOSE CUTS
PROPOSED BE PERSON CENTERED SO
LOOK AT THE WHOLE PERSON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THE STAFF DDS I AM DAPHNE DONE
STAND AND I AM A CARED FROM
SOLANO COUNTY. I'M TAKING CARE
OF MY TWO SPECIAL INVOICE FOR
EIGHTEEN AND SIXTEEN. AND
THEY'RE BOTH ARTISTIC AND- I
JUST WANT TO. ASK YOUR SUPPORT
TO PERMANENTLY RESTORE THE 7% I
IT'S AS ARE WORSE FOR MY VOICE
BECAUSE GOT THING THIS IS AND
NOT GIVING THIS HOURS WILL MEAN
THAT MIGHT TWO BOYS WILL NOT
HAVE A QUALITY OF LIFE THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ME MAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SHERMAN AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAY
MARTINI ENOUGH FOR AFFECT AND
I'M A PROVIDED A FOR MY MOTHER
I'M HERE TO THE ASKING YOU TO
SO OUR- THE EVERYTHING IN OTHER
OUR LOW TAPE A WHOLE. DEDICATED
THE TECH CARES ARE ASKING YOU
TO SET PERCENT REST THEY ARE
ALSO FOR SEEKING VERY LATE FOR
DODD PCS WORKERS WHICH THIS
THERE THIS THE IN THE DO THIS
JOB THAT WE DO. AND ALSO I NAME
FOR THE OTHER ONES DON'T IT SO
PLEASE STOP DID. AND I HOPE I
HE THAT YOU'RE DOING IT AND I
HERE LAW WEEK I AM TODAY AND I
WOULD BE HERE BOB TIME BUTTE IF
IT'S NEED. SO I YEAH PLEASE
SUPPORT US THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. GETTING
GETTING MY NAME IS SHERRY ARE
ON FOR TO HEY MY COUNTY. AND AS
I TOLD YOU. MICHAEL PARMALEE
BLIND IF IT WASN'T FOR ME OR
ANY OF OUR CARE. MICHAEL I
WOULD HAVE BEEN OR HOSPITAL. SO
THE SEVEN PER REALLY WOULD HELP
BUT- AND ALSO CUTTING IT AND
NOT HAVING A PER RESTORE I'M
GONNA BE HOMELESS I WILL TWENTY
SO YEARS. SO IT'S- HARD FOR ME
THIS. WHICH I NEED AS OTHER
PEOPLE NAY. SO LISTEN TO WHAT
GIVE US WHAT WE OR WE DON'T WE
DON'T WANT TO BE BACK HERE IN.
YEAR DO THIS ALL OVER AGAIN
THANK. THANK YOU. GOOD I. MY
NAME'S LILLEY OF SONIC. AND I
TO HER MIND. A 7% WAS RESTORE.
IT PERMITS. TO TAKE CARE OF HER.
SO SHE CAN HAVE HER DO. AND
WHERE SHE WAS BY. RAISED AND IS
AT REST AT THE IS THIS STATE.
THIS IS WHAT SHE DID. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS A BOX IN A UP CYPRUS
DISTRICT ME REGION FIVE. I TAKE
CARE MY MOTHER IN MY BROTHER
I'VE BEEN CARE LITTLE FIFTY
YEARS WHEN WE DID CUT I'M
PEOPLE TO SEE. THEY WAS GIVING
ME FOR MY BROUGH A HUNDRED AND
NINE NOW. NAY WAS GIVEN FOR MY-
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
HOURS THEN I HAD TO MAKE A CHOI.
WHO DO TAKE CARE OF PAY TO RE.
SO THEY GAVE ME I GAVE BACK MY-
BUT I CAN'T MY- IN NAM I'M-
CONSUME BECAUSE SOME OF MY LIFE
I WILL I WILL. FULL SELF I LIAM
THEM I'M THERE ALL THE TIME.
I'VE NEVER HAD A BAKER NEVER
HAD A- NEVER HAD ALL DAY
BECAUSE THEY ALL CALM. CHEESE
LEAGUE BLIND WE ALL TO IS HE'S
MENTAL CHEN SHEETS BUT SIX
YEARS SO I HAD TO GET UP IN.
CLEAN THEM NOT FOR ABOVE HIM
DAY EVERY MORE TO GO TO HIS SON
SO I'M AT. ALL THEWORK ON
THANK YOU FOR THAT HE ME TO
SMALL. AND A PRE ONE ABOUT A
MILE I THINK YOU SIR THANK.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAY. CHEN AND
I'M FROM CUT ACROSS THE COUNTY
AND IS EVERYBODY KNOWS THE BAY
AREA ONE OF THE MOST A- PLACES.
FOR YOU TO LIVE. THAT YOU CAN
LIVE. THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT'S- SO OUR HOLD A
PRAY. THAT YOU WOULD GIVE US
THE SEVEN. I MEAN THE- WHAT SHE
WAS. AFTER CLASS THE COUNTY
ALSO AND I TAKE CARE OF MY
BROTHER WHO IS BLIND AND ALL
SOUL ARTISTIC. AND I NEED TO
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU GUYS KEEP
RESTORED THAT 7% PERMANENTLY
BECAUSE WE NEED IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
WHITE STEAM ON BEHALF OF%
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
TOO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
CUTS- WHAT I'D LIKE TO ADD IS
YOU KNOW- PROVIDERS ARE
PROVIDERS- REALLY ARE THE
LIFELINE FOR- THOSE THAT THEY A
SYSTEM PROVIDE CARE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE REALLY. AND I THINK-
YOU KNOW WHEN WE THINK ABOUT A
STATE BUDGET IT DOES REFLECT
OUR PRIORITIES- WHAT WE PAY AT
PEOPLE UP REFLECTS HOW MUCH
VALUE WE PLACE. ON THEIR LIVES
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO ASK OURSELVES AS A
STATE DO WE VALUE THESE
PROVIDERS- IN INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
BEFORE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
PROVIDERS ARE LOW INCOME.
PEOPLE OF COLOR- WOMEN MOSTLY
AND SO I REALLY THINK THAT WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW- I THINK THE
TIME IS NOW- AS MO- THOSE
BEFORE ME WHO SPOKE YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT OR ASKING FOR THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THESE
CUTS AND YOU KNOW SOMETHING HAS
GOT TO GIVE AND HOPEFULLY WILL
DO THE RIGHT THING THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR BUT
REALLY YOU ON BEHALF YOU W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THREE NINE
THIRTY AND ALL OUR PROVIDERS
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY DUE
TO TAKING COVE IN. NINETEEN
PRECAUTIONS WE ARE IN STRONG.
OF ALL THE AFRICAN PROPOSED A
THREE G. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DANIEL ROBISON I AM A HOME
CARE PROVIDER AND THEM ORGANIZE
OF THIS YEAH YOU. AND I LIVE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IS A VERY
SPECIFIC COUNTY- CALLS LIVING
IS HIGH. IS THAT CLARA ON
PLEASE RESTORED A 7% THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
HAPPY ONE MY NAME IS TINA
LANDAU FROM SOME CLARA COUNTY.
I HAVE A WONDER HOW MANY TIME I
COME HERE TO THE LOBBY PARKING
Y. HACEN AYE HSS PROVIDER.
BECAUSE TO ME KEEP FIGHTING AND
FIGHTING ARE FIGHTING FOR OUR
LEAVING. I REMEMBER- AND TOOK
CARE OF MY SON HE HAVE A-
MENTAL PROBLEM. AND I REMEMBER
WHEN WE HAD A BARGAINING TEAM
WHEN DAY THE FIRST TIME THEY
YEAH CORRECT. I'M RUNNING
BECAUSE THEY'RE A SOCIAL WORKER
GAVE ME GAVE A MY SON. TONY
FINE. ONE OH ONE HOUR OF
MONTHS. HI WHAT HARDER BECAUSE
I JUST TALKED TO TELL WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HIM. BECAUSE HARM
PHYSICALLY HE OKAY BUT THAT'S
THINKING THE PROBLEM THE MENTAL
THIS YEAR ON A FAR FOR ME. I
WORKED MANY MANY ACTUALLY HOURS
I AND PAY THIRTY FIVE ONE A ONE
HOUR COMMENTS. AND TODAY. MY
BROTHER AND SISTER TALK A LOT
ABOUT THE CUT SO TODAY I WANT
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE SICKLY.
PAST VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
IMPORTANT TO US AS A HOME CARE
PROVIDER WE SOMETIME GET SIX WE
NEED TO REST WE NEED TO GET UP
FOR. DOT BECAUSE IT IS SAFER.
FOR US AND SAY FOR OUR CUSTOMER.
AND IS A VERY IMPORTANT X. YEAH.
AND NOT EXPANSION LEE IN THIS
TIME RECORDING WIRESS SEIJI
MUST BE PRIORITY AND WE HEAR
FROM WE GOT SIX POSSIBLY GET
PAID NOW AND I'M- I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE W. B. C. S. WALKER.
TO GASTRIC SLEEVE TO THEY WORK
AND THEY DESERVE A TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'VE BEEN SITTING
HERE SINCE MORNING. SO WHAT. I
LIKE TO SAY- IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE ON CAPITOL HILL AGAIN
MY NAME IS IT BURNED ON A-
MEMBER ORGANIZER AND A HOME
CARE WORKER FOR LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA.
OF WHAT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY IS RESTORING THE 7% I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS TYPE OF WORK
NOW FOR OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND ON CONSTANTLY UP HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL TO FIGHT ONE THING
OR ANOTHER BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
IS ALWAYS UNDER TURMOIL. IT'S
ABOUT RESPECT FOR WHAT WE DO.
AND I THINK IS THAT TIME I
THINK IT'S TIME THAT PEOPLE GET
THE START RESPECT. IS ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT I'VE MET THROUGH
ORGANIZING A GREAT WONDERFUL.
GOD BLESS FOR PEOPLE. IS NOT
EASY TO DO THIS AND GO THROUGH.
THE TRIBES ANGELES OF LIFE AND
THE THINGS THAT OUR CLIENTS ARE
GOING THROUGH WHICH IS PART OF
OUR LIVES TO. SO WHAT DO ALL
THE EIGHTEEN YEARS. NOW WE'RE
AT RESTORATION OF 7% AND
LOOKING TOWARDS ANOTHER YOU
KNOW TIME WHERE IT'S GONNA
POSSIBLY BE IN JEOPARDY. IT'S
TIME TO STABILIZE THIS. MAKE
THE STABLE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
DO THIS TYPE OF WORK IT'S ONE
LESS THING THERE WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IN OUR MINDS AND WE
CAN DEAL WITH OUR CLIENTS ON A-
MUCH BETTER LEVEL. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME GOD BLESS. HAVE A
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HEARING US MY NME IS ELLEN
ROLLINS I'M A HOME CARE
PROVIDER FOR MY DAUGHTER WHO
SUFFERED A SPINAL CORD INJURY
SECONDARY TO A DRUNK DRIVER-
HITTING HER VEHICLE SHE WAS
TWENTY FOUR SHE'S FIFTY FIVE
NOW I'M NOW. SEVENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND I'M STILL
WORKING FULL TIME HER NUMBER OF
HOURS ARE FIFTY THREE UNMET
NEEDS WITH THE FULL RIDER IHSA
AS THEY ARE ELEVEN WAIVERS BUT
THEY'RE NOT SHARED ACROSS THE
STATE TO MAKE THEIR COORDINATED
CARE- I JUST WORKERS AND THAT
INCLUDED. IN SOCIAL SECURITY
INSURANCE WHICH THEY SHOULD
HAVE THOSE BENEFITS- THEY THEIR
INCOME NEEDS TO BE IN THE HANDS
PERMANENTLY WITH THE 7% GIVEN
BACK- THE MINIMUM WAGE SHOULD
BE A LIVABLE WAGE AND YOU NEED
TO KEEP THESE WORKERS. OUT OF A
SYSTEM THAT KEEPS THEM
IMPOVERISHED BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT JUST DOMESTIC WORKERS I'M A
RETIRED NURSE AND I'M HERE WITH
MY DAUGHTER BECAUSE IF SHE
DIDN'T WHERE SHE WASN'T ABLE TO
CALL NURSE ROLLINS HOME. SHE'D
BE DEAD BY NOW WITH THE QUALITY
OF CARE THAT YOU PROVIDED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHEN SHE
CALLED ME BACK. AS I SAID I'M
SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD I STILL
WORK FULL TIME IN MORE THAN
FULL TIME. AND EVERY WORKER
SHOULD HAVE. PAID SICK LEAVE.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GO TO
WORK SICK AND MAKE THEIR
CLIENTS SICK WITH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS
RENEE THEN I'M FROM CINEMA
COUNTY WE NEED THE 7% SO THAT.
OUR CLIENTS GET THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED. WE WOULD HAVE NOT
GIVEN THE BEST CARE IT IF THEY
LOSE THEIR HOURS AND PROVIDERS
NEED THE HOURS. BECAUSE WE MAKE
VERY LOW PAY AND WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PAY OUR
RENT HAVEFOOD FOR OUR CHILDREN
AND WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO KEEP
OUR BILLS PAID SO WE NEED TO
MAKE 27% PERMANENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARGARET PAULSON AND- I'M
FROM SONOMA COUNTY THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN HERE BUT I
ALSO KNOW ABOUT I HSS I'VE BEEN
IN THE MEDICAL FIELD FOR YEARS.
MY WHOLE INTO ADULT LIFE I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY. WE NEED TO
DO THE 7% PERMANENT RESTORATION
FOR AYE HSS WORKERS BECAUSE
THIS IS THE HARDEST JOB I'VE
DONE THROUGH MEDICAL THAT I'VE
DONE BEFORE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I'M GOOD A GOOD EVEN
THOUGH MY NAME IS CARL VINSON I
REPRESENT A SOLANO COUNTY I AM-
I AM- THERMAL COUNTY I TO
ASSESS AND PUBLIC ALREADY- OF.
THE BATTERY CAN YOU DESCRIBE
MANKIND NUMBERS OKAY ALL RIGHT
THAT'S ALL OF HIS GARAGE ALL
RIGHT- GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY
I'M A NAME IS CARVED INTO THE
REPRESENT A SOLANO COUNTY AND I
SERVE ON S<c.cyan>COUNTY I</c>
JUST SAYS AND PUBLIC ALREADY-
BOTHER COMMITTEE AND I'M ALSO-
SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
ASSOCIATE MEMBER AND I SERVED
ON THE CONTRACT- BARGAINING-COMMITTEEFOR TWO YEARS FROM. A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN- AND THIS WAS
A BATTLE WITH OUR COUNTY. AND I
WAS ONLY ONE AFTER WE FIRST
STARTED IN THIS- TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT I WAS ON THE ONE ON THAT-
BARGAIN COMMITTEE. THAT STAY
THERE YOU KNOW WHAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT WE WANT BETTER WE
WANT TO DO BETTER. AND THE
THING IS I BELIEVE THAT I WAS
THERE FOR MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND FOR THE RECIPIENTS.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE CHANGE IT
WE HAD WE GOT THE CONTRACT-
WITH A WITH ANOTHER TEN YEARS
NOT TO GET NO REYES AT ALL AND
ALSO TOO IF WE HADN'T GOT THE
CONTRACT. SACRAMENTO WHEN I GOT
THE CONTRACT. YEAH AND WE ABOUT
FORTY FIVE MINUTES RADIUS FROM
THERE. AND REYES OFTEN IT
BEFORE YOUR BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IN LIBERTY I DON'T BELIEVE IN
IN HOME BUYING. AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD GET 7% OF A
RESTORATION AS WELL AS- PAID
SICK LEAVE AND I'M ACTION YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT THIS AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US. AND YOU HAVE
A GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT CULP I
LOVE TO DOCK BY WHICH IT UP WE
ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE DISABILITY
LOBSTERMAN THIS A BILL I HAVE
DISABILITY- SO PROCESS SHOULD
BE RESTORED. THEIR WAGES SHOULD
GO UP. AND THE I AGREE WITH
SOMEBODY THAT SAID THAT THEY
COUNTIES DON'T AGREE A GO TO
THE BARGAINING TABLE THIS YEAR
SAMPRAS SAID CUT. MAY COME UP
MAKE IT WILL GO TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE. AS SENATOR
PAN SAID LAST WEEK THAT ONLY
PROGRAMS THAT GET CUT
AUTOMATICALLY OUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. SO THAT SHOULD
NOT HAPPEN. I MEAN THERE SHOULD
BE SOMEBODY THAT SAYS. THE
THERE THE BILL THE PAIN WHEN
THEY MAKE THE CUT SHOULD NOT BE
AUTOMATIC THEN THEY GET CUT
AGAIN. THANK YOU SIR. CAROL
SPORTSCENTER CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING THE
COMMISSION SUPPORTS ISSUE A THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
REDUCTION DIET JUST AS AN ISSUE
BE- SICKLY PARITY FOR WPC S.
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU MA'AM.
JUST GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I KNOW
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE UP
THERE FOR ONE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER POLLS BUT ALSO ON
TO PROVIDE COMMENT ON ISSUE
THREE AND ONE OF THE OTHER US
STICKLE TO PROPOSALS ON ISSUE
THREE OVERRIDE SS I JUST WANT
TO. LET YOU KNOW THAT KIND OF
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW EMILY AS
OFFICIALLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE FROM CONVENE A WORK
GROUP TO DETERMINE THE COUNTY
AMOUNTS TO HOST ANY TRAINING
FOR COUNTY STAFF STATEWIDE. AND
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- IN A CLOUD OF
NATURE IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING
THE NEW EMILY. I'M ALSO GOING
TO GO ON RECORD IN OPPOSITION
TO A PROPOSAL DE THE ONE
RELATED TO- DISCLOSURE OF
VENDOR CONTRACTS CRISIS
NEGOTIATIONS WE'VE LOOKED AT-
THE YOU KNOW COUNTY IS THAT
UTILIZE OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS FOR
NEGOTIATIONS AND KIND OF
NOTICED A COUPLE THINGS ONE
THEY- TEND TO REACH AGREEMENTS
AT ABOUT THE SAME PACE AS
COUNTIES THAT DON'T SO I'M NOT
SURE THAT'S- EVIDENCE OF THE
KIND OF SHOW THAT THAT'S A
MAJOR HURDLE IN TERMS OF
REACHING AGREEMENTS- THIS IS.
YOU KNOW UNLIKE ANY OTHER SORT
OF REQUIREMENT ANOTHER SORT OF
BARGAINING AND THEN- OFTENTIMES
IS A COUNTIES THAT ARE USING A
CONSULTANT COUNTY WIDE FOR
NEGOTIATION SO WITH ALL THEIR
BARGAINING UNITS DOES NOT
NECESSARILY THEIR HIRING
SOMEONE SPECIFIC DIET SAYS TO
CERTAINLY EXAMPLES OF THAT BUT
THERE'S ALSO. A VARIETY OF WAYS
IT CAN IS UTILIZED AS
CONSULTANTS AND SO WE OPPOSE
THAT PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. HOW HOW GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HARMING THE SANCHEZ.
AND I COME FROM NAPA. COME
THAT'LL THAN UPPER. A AND I A
WAR. TWENTY TWO YEARS WE MIGHT
DARTING CHEESE PRESSEN THERE'S
CHEESE- INTERPRETAR DEAN HAS
SIDE. YEAH AND- I KIND CHIU
THAT SACRAMENTO I SAY COME IN
FLUORIDEHOPES. FOURTEEN YEARS.
FOR TALKING ABOUT THAT RIGHT.
THEN MY CLIENTS SAN. AND I
DIDN'T AND I SUPPORT EVERYTHING
AND I WANT SCHOOL- SO POOR THAT
SEVEN FOUR SAN. 6% SEVEN FOUR
SEN BECAUSE SAM IS A HALF HOUR
OKAY CONTINUOUS BAN ANGER AS A
SPARE KEY PROGRAM BY THE K.
SUPPORT CANNELLA SEE AT THE
FOUR CIENTO CARE AND THE LESSOR
ASKING LARA KNOWN AS A HIM
PERMANENT THINKING ON THE SAME
PROVIDED THE PUT GET ELASTIC
PLUS YOU OWN THE LEVY THAT CARE
MOST BASS WE HANDLE. MORE KIND.
HE NOR SAYS WAS YAK AT THE BE A
POOR I SEE THE MEAN. YES WE
LONG TROLL THE OTHER WAS ASKED
TO SOME. REFERENTES DE YES SOON
I TOLD US THAT ASK IT GET
ANIMALS THAT IT WILL NOT BE
THAT MAY HOLD THE KILEY THAT
AND MY STAFF MEDIA. BUT I KEPT
WAY THAN. THE VEHICLES MASS LOS
OTROS. THING THEM WILL SUPPORT
YOU. THE WILL STAY THIS CASE.
AND UPON TOLL CAN ALSO ASKS
ORDERS WENT THING. FOUR K. AS
HOST. OKAY THIS GOOD ASSISTANCE
I'M I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- IN THE FOR RESTORATION
OF THE 7% BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING IS JUST GOING HIGHER AND
HIGHER. AND OUR BILLS. KEEP
COMING IN AND- I AM ONE OF MANY
PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT THAT ARE
DOING THE EXACT SAME WORK THAT
NEED THAT SUPPORT THAT NEED
THAT FOR RESTORATION OF THE 7%
AND- AND SO I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR. WILL HOLD
ISSUE FOR OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FIVE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR SS I SS P. PROGRAM.
OF THE SS I SS P. PROGRAM IS A
VERY NICE OVERVIEW IN YOUR
AGENDA AS THERE WAS FOR I JUST
SAYS BUT OUT OF TOUCH ON JUST A
FEW THINGS IT SERVING- ABOUT
ONE POINT TWO MILLION PEOPLE
STATEWIDE. THERE HAS BEEN AN
BUCK CONSISTENTLY STUDY SLIGHT
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT ARE RECEIVING SSI AND S.
P. IN THE STATE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED- A FEW DIFFERENT
REASONS ABOUT SO CURRYING AGAIN
THEY'RE COVERED IN THE AGENDA
BUT PEOPLE BEING BABY BOOMERS
BEING MORE FINANCIALLY STABLE
IMPROVEMENTS IN MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY. HEALTHIER
BEHAVIORS- THE ASSET LIMITS OF
THIS THE SCIENCES P. HAVE BEEN
THE SAME FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AND FOLKS BEING ABOUT THOSE
THRESHOLDS. THE SS I SS BUDGET
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
ESTIMATEDAT NINE POINT SEVEN
BILLION WHICH IS. THE SAME AS
IT WAS FOR NINETEEN TWENTY-
THE- ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION OF
THAT AS- SSA. ADMINISTERS THE
S. S. P. PROGRAM BEFORE I FOR-
FOR US FOR THE STATE AND THAT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
MILLION A YEAR THAT WE PAY FOR
THAT ACTIVITY THE- PAYMENT
STANDARDS ARE ARE SHOWN IN IN
YOUR AGENDA. AND ANY OTHER
INFORMATION THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LA. REVIEW THE BUDGET
ESTIMATES AND REYES NO MAJOR
CONCERN BUT AS YOU CAN SEE ON
PAGE TWENTY NINE- WE DID JUST
FLAG THAT CASELOAD TRENDS WHILE
THEY ARE DECREASING JUST BASED
OFF OF MOST RECENT ACTUAL- THEY
MAY BE JUST SLIGHTLY HIGHER
THAN WHAT'S PROJECTED IN THE
BUDGET BUT AGAIN. AS WITH ANY
YEAR WE WOULD EXPECT- THE MAY
REVISION ESTIMATES TO REFLECT-
ESTA ART TO REFLECT PROJECTIONS
THAT ARE BASED OFF OF ACTUAL.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND ONLY ON
ISSUES NOT OTHERWISE- COVERED
IN ADVOCACY ADVOCACY REQUEST
WITHIN THE SUBJECT. HELLO
AGAIN. I'M STILL FRANCIS SMITH
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR RETIRED AMERICANS. IN THE
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER WAS
TRYING TO BALANCE HIS BUDGET
AND ONE OF THE WAYS HE DID IT
WAS TO TAKE THE CALL IS AWAY
FROM EVERYBODY ON SS I SS BE.
THESE WERE NOT PEOPLE WITH IRIS
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO COULD
GO OUT AND GET A PART TIME JOB
TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE.
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE SINCE THEN. THANKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL WHERE THEY
GOT EIGHT DOLLARS AND THIRTY
FOUR CENTS A MONTH IN THEIR
PAYCHECK A FEW YEARS AGO. BUT
THAT HAS NO WAY KEPT UP WITH
INFLATION. WE KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE MONEY THAT GOES INTO THE
RAINY DAY FUND EVERY YEAR.
pWHO GET SSI AND S. S. P. KARA
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH. ADDED TO THE
S. AS HE PORTION OF THE GRANT
FOR EACH BENEFICIARY AND THE
COAL ON THE S. IS PEOPLE ARE
XIN. FULLY REINSTATED IF WE
WANT TO ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE
HOMELESSNESS HEALTHCARE HUNGER
AND MORE IN THIS STATE WE MUST
START BY HELPING THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR STATE. WE FOR
THIS WILL BE TAKEN CARE OF IN
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
CURRENTLY IN PROCESS. BUT WE
URGE YOU TO DEMAND THAT NO NEW
BUDGET BE APPROVED. UNLESS THIS
INCREASE IS PART OF THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR AND IN THE YEARS
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THEY ARE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
SAID- ONE HUNDRED FOR ONE
HUNDRED WE NEED A HUNDRED
DOLLAR INCREASE BECAUSE- RENT
IS GOING UP FASTER THAN THE-
UP. OF RENT- IF THIS IDEA GRANT
INCREASES THAT ARE ON FEDERAL
PORTION. EVEN WHAT AB FOURTEEN
DAY TO PASS LAST YEAR. MONEY
BROUGHT A COUPLE OF LONG TO
SEVER GO SHOCK WAS SECOND LEVEL
ORGANIZED COMMUNITY. DOC BUT WE
SAY YEAH BY POVERTY NOT THE
POOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION ISSUE
SIX A WILL BE THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL FOR INCREASING THE
GRANT AMOUNTS AND JUST WANTED
TO. MAKE SURE PEOPLE WERE DOING
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENT THE RIGHT
TIME SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE SIX WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE ARE SORRY
ISSUE FIVE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ISSUES SIX A- AND WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AROUND A LOT
AND AS YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THE TIME A COMMITMENT TODAY AND
MANY DAYS HE PUT INTO THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES. ON BEHALF OF
MANY ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME WITH. JOIN WITH ME TO
RESTORE THE ASKED TO HAVE THE
CUTS RESTORED THEY ARE MADE TO
THE STATE'S SHARE THE SOCIAL
SECURITY INCOME AND STATE.
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT GRANT. AND
I WANT TO START BY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT AT THE YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD
YOU'VE BEEN. RIGHT THERE AS A
CHAMPION OF THOSE THAT RELY- ON
THIS CRITICAL. GRANT AND OF
COURSE YOUR LEADERSHIP OF A
LEAD TO THE- THE CASH OUT THE
SUCCESS OF THE ISSUE REGARDING
THE CASH OUT WHICH HAS BEEN A
GREAT HELP TO SO MANY OF OUR
POOREST SENIORS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY FELLOW CHAIRS THIS ON
THE HUMAN SERVICES AN AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE TWENTY
COMMITTEES. SOMERS RAISIN IS
ERIN- AND THE NINE OTHER
MEMBERS WHO JOINED ME IN THIS
REQUEST. AS YOU ALL KNOW
EFFORTS TO RESTORE THIS CUT
PROCEDURE OUR TIME IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT HAS BEEN. AND
CONTINUES TO BE A PRIORITY FOR
MANY- SINCE OUR ARRIVAL. I
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE OBVIOUS BUT
THIS ISSUE. IS IMPORTANT FOR
ALL FOR US ALL TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE LAST
MAJOR CUTS THE STATE MADE
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
THAT WE HAVE YET TO RESTORE. AS
EACH YEAR PASSES THE IMPACT OF
THIS CUT. COMPOUNDS ON ITSELF
MAKING IT MORE MORE DIFFICULT
FOR SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
AFFORD TO LIVE BUT TO SURVIVE.
RECIPIENTS FIND FAR BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL AND FACING
SERIOUS AND LIFE CHANGING
DECISIONS ON HOW TO PAY FOR DAY
TO DAY LIVING EXPENSES RENT.
FOOD MEDICATION ELECTRICITY AND
SO ON. IN FACT SS I SS BE
RECIPIENTS WERE ALREADY NEAR
HOMELESS BEFORE THESE CUTS WERE
MADE. AND THIS CUT IS ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE ARE FACING A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS TODAY
ESPECIALLY AMONGST OUR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN SB GRANT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL CONTINUE
TO FACE A GREATER RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS AND FACE
HUNGER AND POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES. WE SHOULD NOT WAIT
CANNOT WAIT HAS BEEN MORE THAN
TEN YEARS. IT IS TIME TO SIX
NEVER CAN STEP RESTORE THE
STATE'S SHARE THE SS I SS P.
AND NOT ALLOWED TO BECOME AN
ACCEPTED REALITY OF THE BUDGET.
I UNDERSTAND THE COST RESTORE
THIS CUT LOOKS INSURMOUNTABLE
BUT WE CANNOT WALK AWAY WITHOUT
TAKING STEPS NECESSARY TO
RESTORE THE STATE'S SHARE THE
S. I. S. S. P. THANK YOU. A
MISTER CHAIR- AND STAFF OF MY
CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
ISSUE AGAIN IN FRONT OF YOUR- A
COMMITTEE- AND YOU KNOW WE
SUPPORT EVERYTHING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALLER JUST SAID
WE THINK IT IS LONG OVERDUE TO
RESTORE THESE CUTS- AND SO- I'M
GONNA KEEP MY ROOMIES. MY
REMARKS BRIEF VIKINGS GET THAT
OUT BY REMARKS BRIEF WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. A CLIENT A
RECIPIENT- ACTUALLY FROM YOUR
CITY OF FRESNO A DOES MARTINEZ
WHO'S WITH WE ARE NOT VISIBLE
AND SHE'LL BE GIVING THE
PRINCIPAL AMOUNT OF OUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
HELLO AND MY NAME IS DOES
MARTINEZ I AM FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
APPROXIMATELY TEN YEARS AGO I
HAD A SPINAL INJURY DUE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I WAS PUT ON
DISABILITY AND ONE MOVE BACK TO
CALIFORNIA I WAS PUT ON SSI. I
HAVE BEEN ON SSI FOR SEVEN
YEARS. ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO I
BECAME HOMELESS. I HAVE
RECEIVED A T. BRO WHICH IS THE
HOMELESS VOUCHERS THAT IS PAID
FOR BY THE FRESNO CITY. I WAS
PUT ON THAT VOUCHER IN TWO
THOUSAND DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN. DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. MY RENT
INCREASED WHICH I CANNOT
AFFORD. AS SO I HAD TO END UP
MOVING AGAIN. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MY SS I WAS ALSO TAKEN
AWAY BECAUSE I WASN'T PAYING
THE RENT. I WASN'T PAYING RENT
BECAUSE I WAS HOMELESS DURING
THAT TIME. I'M STILL FIGHTING
TO GET THAT IS A SITE BACK
TODAY. SINCE MY EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS I BECAME AN
ACTIVIST AND AN ADVOCATE TOO
MANY LIVING ON THE STREETS AND
IN POOR LOW INCOME HOUSING.
MANY OF THESE BEING ON SSI. I
HAVE WORKED WITH AROUND FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR ABOUT TO BECOME
HOMELESS OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS OF MY ADVOCACY. AND I
WOULD SAY ABOUT HALF OF THEM
ARE ON SSI. IF I GET MY AS A
SIDE BACK HIM FOR THE PEOPLE I
WORK WITH IT WILL HELP US WITH
BASIC NECESSITIES SUCH AS FOOD
TRANSPORTATION AND MEDICATION.
THESE ARE THINGS WE ALL NEED
BUT MANY OF US ARE GOING
WITHOUT. AS OF TODAY I AM
RECOVERING FROM SURGERY I HAVE
FIVE DAYS AGO THIS WAS BROUGHT
ON BY HEART ATTACKS. I HAD
THESE WITHIN THE LAST YEAR. I
HAVE MANY MORE TESTS TO
COMPLETE IF I GET. I AS A SIDE
BACK PLUS AN INCREASE OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS I CAN POSSIBLY
PAY AND CATCH UP ON MY
COPAYMENT FEES AND GET SOME OF
THE MEDS THAT I HAVE NOT EVEN
BEEN PICKING UP. AS OF APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY I WILL BE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AGAIN
NOT BECAUSE I WANT TO. BUT
BECAUSE MY RENT INCREASE FROM
SEVEN SEVENTY WHICH IS MY
VOUCHER. TWO NINE SEVENTY FIVE.
WHICH MY VOUCHER DOES NOT COVER.
SO I'M JUST ASKING YOU GUYS TO
INCREASES THEN PLEASE HELP.
MYSELF THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
OUT THERE HOMELESS THE ELDERLY
THAT ARE OUT THERE HOMELESS- WE
NEED THIS INCREASE AND I'M JUST
ASKING YOU GUYS TO RAISE IT.
PLEASE. THANK YOU HONEST GOOD
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE EL AL. WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SIX SAY. GREETINGS CHAIRMAN I'M
JEFF HARDY GEAR AND AS WE COME
BACK TO THIS IS THE ONE HUNDRED
IS NEEDED TO THE COAL IS
NEEDED. AND MAYBE YOU NEED TO
LOOK AT A LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY
SO YOU GET IDEAS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE SSI AND THE
FACT THAT YOU ALL WILL KNOW
THAT THEIR RENTS HAVE INCREASED
TO SUCH AN EXTENT THAT EVEN SSI
DOES NOT HELP OUT. SO PLEASE
I'M ALSO THE HORTON ALMOST
COORDINATOR HERE SO I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW CARS HOPE IS
TO FIND BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO BE
THE LAST ELEMENT THAT SOMEBODY
HAS BEFORE WHEN THEY CALL
BECOME HOMELESS. BUT ANYWAY SSI
ALL SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
MARTY MOTO FAMILY MEMBER OF
SOME CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SENIOR COMMITTEE ACTION NETWORK
STRONG SUPPORT. THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE INCREASE- TO YOU-
EXERCISES P. DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THAT POPULATION ACTUALLY COVERS
THE WIDEST RANGE OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AN OLDER
CALIFORNIANS IT WOULD ACTUALLY
MAKE A STEP TOWARDS- ADVANCING
THE- MASTER PLAN OR AT LEAST
THE EFFORT ABOUT LOOK
ADDRESSING ISSUES CONNECTED TO
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. BOB
SECONDLY I JUST WANNA QUICK ON
ON EVEN IF YOU HAVE GOT TO
MENTION ONE THING AGAIN
PRAISING DEPARTMENT FORCE PHASE
ONE IMPLEMENTATION BUT THERE IS
AN ISSUE- HOPE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL CIRCLE BACK IN APRIL. TWO
FOR- LOOK AT- THE DEPARTMENTS-
DECISION MAKING ON THE ISSUE OF
THE TWENTY NINETEEN AUGUST.
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REGARDING LIVE IN
PROVIDERS AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN BE IN- EXEMPTED FROM
IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE AMONG MANY AYE CHICEST
RECIPIENTS AND UP THE
DEPARTMENT- SAID THEY WOULD BE
CONSIDERING THAT DURING THE
LISTENING SESSIONS AND WE JUST
WANT TO SUBCOMMITTEE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
APARTMENT. IN APRIL I THINK
THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE HOLDING
ANOTHER HEARING THAT MAY TOUCH
ON A I E. V. V. AND CIRCLE BACK
AND SEE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS DECIDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR AND
YOU'RE CORRECT ABOUT APRIL.
FRED MAIN REPRESENTING CAL
PACE- IN ORDER FOR FRAIL
SENIORS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF REMAINING IN THE
COMMUNITY AND- GETTING SERVICES
FROM PACE THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO LIVE SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT MEANS THE ABILITY TO
HAVERENT AND FOOD. AND THE
SSI- GRANT IS VERY- CRUCIAL TO
THAT HIGH AND SO AN INCREASE-
AND A COST OF LIVING WOULD BE A
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THANK. THANK
YOU SIR YOUR NAME IS REFILL
SOME ROOM FOR CA I'M ON AS A
SIDE AND- I HAVE A HARD TIME-
MOSTLY BECAUSE- IF I GET A JOB
THEY WANT TO CUT MY AS A SIGN
HAVE. AND MY RENT IS- ALMOST A
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THAT'S
ABOUT BUT MY CHECK IS. EVERY
MONTH. SO THE EXTRA HUNDRED
BUCKS MIGHT MEAN- A- COUPLE OF
NOT MUCH BUT A LITTLE BIT.
BETTER AS PAYING FOR MY TOTALLY
TREES ARE MY HYGIENE OR MY- BUS
TICKETS OR WHATEVER.
TRANSPORTATION SO IF YOU'D GIVE
IT CONSIDERATION ARE AT I SURE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO GOOD EVENING IN A WHILE
THE HEART WELL A. R. P. JUST
WANT TO ASSERT OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR- THE SS I SS P.
BOTH THE INCREASE AND THE COLOR
RESTORATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. FRANK MECCA WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR. REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT TEN THOUSAND SOCIAL
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO WORK WITH THIS COMMUNITY-
TODAY WE WERE HOPING TO HAVE
MORE RECIPIENTS WITH THIS BUT
OF COURSE THERE CORONAVIRUS AND
THOSE FEARS BUT IT JUST
HIGHLIGHTS HOW VULNERABLE THIS
POPULATION IS. AND I'VE BEEN
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA'S PRESS
AS I COALITION FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND YEAR AFTER YEAR WE'RE
HERE TRYING TO GET THIS
RESTORATION- AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT DOES HAVE A BIG PRICE TAG
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
IT'S A HUGE PART OF- THE
HOMELESS- YOU KNOW THE
SITUATION AND IF WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT- ATTACKING THAT PROBLEM
WE REALLY NEED TO RAISE THESE
GRANTS. THANK YOU MA'AM. SO I
SEEM ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR BEVERLY
ON BEHALF EDIE W. ASKING LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND WESTERN- CENTER LONG
POVERTY FOR BRING THIS PROPOSAL
FORD WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
TO ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DON'T FALL- DEEPER
INTO POVERTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AURORA CO OPEN A SECOND
HOMES OR YOU I CAN MAYBE. I
THINK ASH KALRA THE CORRECTED
FOR THEM AND THE LADY SAID SIT
NEXT TO. I FEEL SORRY FOR BUT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT FOR
EVERYBODY THAT ARE HOMELESS.
AND I'LL BE HERE NEXT YEAR WE
HAVE TO IN THE YEAR AFTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU. CAROLS CAROLL
SOURCE LANDER A CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI GOOD
EVENING I'M CHANTE PER SIDE
WITH- CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS- I WANT TO FIRST-
SEND MY- APOLOGIES ON BEHALF OF
MY COLLEAGUE UNDER SHANE HE HAD
TO GO HOME TO BE WITH HIS SONS.
WITH THE SUN FOR HIS TO
CELEBRATE HIS SEVENTH BIRTHDAY-
AND BE A DAD- I'M ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF- CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES- CALIFORNIA
HUNGER ACTION COALITION AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI- IT ALSO
WANTED TO MENTION THAT SHERRY
WHO FROM FRESNO WHO JUST SPOKE
WITH A FOSTER KID IN THE
SYSTEM- SO. I THOUGHT THAT WAS
AN IMPORTANT POINT- I'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT MY MOM- BEFORE- BUT
BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA OF
POVERTY I HAVEN'T MENTIONED ALL
OF THE DETAILS ABOUT MY MOM
LIVING IN FRESNO ON SSI SO I
WANTED TO SHARE A BIT ABOUT
THAT- MY MOM AND THE LETTER WAS
THE FIRST IN HER FAMILY- THE
ONLYONE OUT OF FOUR CHILDREN A
FARM WORKER IMMIGRANT PARENTS
CEMEX SOME MEXICAN MOTHER AND
OF FILIPINO GRUBHUB FATHER. TO
GET A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AT THE
AGE OF THIRTY FIVE WHEN SHE WAS
A SINGLE MOM I WAS THREE- MY
DAD WAS IN COLLEGE AT THE TIME-
SH BUT SHE HAD THYROID CANCER
AND SHE ALWAYS HAD TO- STRUGGLE
WITH HER ENERGY LEVEL BECAUSE
SHE HAD HER THYROID TAKEN OUT
AND DEAL WITH THE TRIAL AND
ERROR OF- HER MEDICATIONS- AND
WE WERE ON ALL THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. OF THAT WE COULD
QUALIFY FOR AND SHE WORKED PART
TIME ON AND OFF SHE GOT ON SSI
WHEN SHE WAS ABOUT SIXTY- BUT
AFTER HER TRAILER HOME BURNED
DOWN SHE BOUNCED FROM RENTAL TO
RENTAL HAS HER HEALTH
DETERIORATED- SS I CUTS. DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION MADE IT A
LOT WORSE- MY DAD AFTER
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE HELPED
HER GET HER SECTION EIGHT
THROUGH- AND WHEN WE HELPED HER
MOVE OUT I WAS LIVING IN NEW
YORK AT THE TIME WE HELPED HER
MOVE OUT- I'LL NEVER FORGET
WHEN SHE ANSWERED THE DOOR THE
LOOK THE LOOK ON HER FACE AND
THE TRAUMA OF. POVERTY ON HER
FACE SHE WOULDN'T LET ME INTO
HER ROOM BUT MY AUNT TOLD ME
LATER WHEN SHE WENT TO CLEAN IT
OUT THAT IT WAS IN VESTED WITH.
AND MAGGIE. I HAD I WILL NEVER
FORGET. THAT AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA OF POVERTY THAT THIS IS
IT. THANKFULLY WE GOT OUR TO
SENIOR LIVING SHE WAS ABLE TO
LIVE THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
OF HER LIFE- IN RELATIVE PEACE
SHE PASSED AT AGE SIXTY NINE IN
TWENTY ELEVEN- WHEN SHE BROKE
HER HIP AND COULDN'T HANDLE THE
SURGERY- WITH HER LACK OF
THYROID AND HER HEART ISSUES.
PLEASE RESTORED THIS GRANT THIS
YEAR FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD EVENING. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARCHAND TAB AND I'M
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO MY RANT
FULL BANG. ALSO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA FOR SSI CALIFORNIA
HUNGER ACTION COALITION. AND I
SPEAK FOR THE PEOPLE BECAUSE I
AM THE PEOPLE- I'VE DEALT WITH
THIS POPULATION- FOR A LOT OF
YEARS FROM OUR OLDER COMMUNITY
TO PEOPLE WHO HOMELESS AND TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FULLY
SECURITIES. ONE OF THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR THAT I HAVE SEEN IS
WHAT DO I PAY FOR DOT PAY FOR
FOOD. DOT PAY FOR MEDICATION
DOT PAY FOR RAN. DO I PAY TO
PUT CLOTHES ON MY BACK SO I PAY
FOR HYGIENE PRODUCTS. ME AS I'M
DEAD TIRED OF LIVING IN THE
STATES SO WEALTHY. WHERE FIGHT
AND FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE A
HUNDRED DOLLAR INCREASE UP IN
THAT. WAS THERE BUT WAS TAKEN
AWAY AND NOT RESTORED BUT YET
WE'RE STILL THE FIFTH BIGGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. I MEAN WESHOULD BE SAYING FOR SELF
SPECIALLY WHEN WE COME IN HERE
YEAR AFTER YEAR FIVE FIFTHS OUT
THERE THAT CAN BE DONE TODAY.
PLEASE RESTART OF THIS. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING LISA
COLEMAN WITH CAL COMMA. AND WE
GO BACK TO WE'RE GOING TO PAY
FOR THIS ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AT THE
I'M ASSOCIATION IS VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE PATCH. WHEN WE
ARE ASKING PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE- ASSISTED LIVING
SERVICES. AT THE NON MEDICAL
OUT OF HEALTH POCKET BUT A
THOUSAND SIXTY NINE DOLLARS A
MONTH. WE ARE ENCOURAGING
FACILITY ADMINISTRATORS TO CUT
CORNERS WE ARE ENCOURAGING THEM
TO SKIRT PASSED THE LAW. WE
WILL ULTIMATELY FIND THE SAME
RESIDENTS AND SKILLED NURSING.
STILL ON MEDI CAL BUT AT A MUCH
HIGHER RATE OF REIMBURSEMENT.
IT IS EXPENSIVE THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE BUT I GO BACK TO YOUR
POINT BEFORE WE WILL PAY FOR
THIS ONE WE ARE ANOTHER
ENCOURAGES TO LOOK AT THIS IS
THE IDEA OF RESPECT AND DIGNITY
AND INCREASE THE PATCH. THANK
YOU MA'AM SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE SIX. I
WILL BRING IT BACK FORWARD AND-
AGAIN WANTS TO APPRECIATE DOES
MARTINEZ FOR COMING TO SHARE
YOUR STORY AS MANY. PEOPLE HERE
OF SHARED YOUR STORY- I BELIEVE
LAST TIME I SAW YOU WE WERE AT
MY CHURCH TGETHER AND-
SPEAKING ON A HOMELESS PANEL-
BEFORE THE ACLU SO. JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE YOU FOR TAKING
TIME. I DID WANT TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF I
COULD JUST TO PROVIDE SOME
FEEDBACK ON THE PROPOSAL- AND
IT ANY SUGGESTIONS YOU MAY
PROVIDE. HOUSE AT THE AMY
DIFFERENT FINANCE AS WAS
MENTIONED THIS IS A VERY.
COSTLY PROPOSAL- EVERYONE
PERCENT INCREASE THIS AMOUNT TO
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS. AND
GENERAL FUND COSTS. SO NO JUST
STATING THE FACTS ENTRANCE OF
THE FISCAL IT THAT WHERE WE ARE
AT THE MOMENT WITH THE
SITUATION- BUT IF TO ACCEPT
THAT THAT IS A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE. HAPPY TO
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
I'M I GUESS TO ADD MORE
SPECIFICITY TO THE QUESTION
WE'VE CURRENTLY- PUT IN.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT THE
COAL- FOR S. S. P. IS TO START
IN TWENTY TWO. TWENTY THREE AND
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS ARE ARE
WE ADEQUATELY BUDGETING FOR
PARENTS FOR THAT- AND- WHEN
WOULD THAT NEED TO BE REFLECTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND-
SO. THE LANGUAGE SO IT SAYS
THAT SUBJECT IN PREPARATION SO
BASED OFF OF OUR CURRENT BUDGET
ARCHITECT WE DON'T MAKE ANY
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT- FUNDING TO
ANY KIND OF COAL IS AT THE
MOMENT- ORGAN AT THE WEIGHT
AND- TELL THEM TO SEE WHAT THE
REVENUES LOOK LIKE. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE IS A CAPACITY
WITH. REVENUES TO DO SO WILL
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS. I'M I
BRING IT UP BECAUSE I'M QUITE
SENSITIVE TO THE COMPOUNDING
NATURE OR THAT THE LACK OF THE
COAL- HAS HAD IN TERMS OF
CONTINUING TO GROW THAT DIVIDE
AND. BUT WANTED JUST TO MENTION
THAT- THIS COMMITTEE IS TRYING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
ESTABLISHING THE COLA- WITH
THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX A
OPEN AND APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALL FOR
BRINGING UP FOR. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIX BE. THANK.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS HIS
PROPOSAL MY NAME IS GONNA SEE
LEGACY- CRANKS AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF GRIFFIN STEVENS AND
THE CONSULTING WHO REPRESENTS
THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW A STATE ME
ADMINISTER ITS OWN STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT OR ENTER
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
FEDERAL SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PAYMENTS AND PAYMENTS ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE. IF SSA
ADMINISTERS THE PROGRAM THE
STATE MUST PAY PER TRANSACTION
A FEE THAT IS ADJUSTED ANNUALLY
AND INCREASED FOR INFLATION FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE IS TWELVE
DOLLARS AND FORTY ONE CENTS PER
TRANSACTION THIS MEANS THAT
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY PAYS A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. ENTER THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA. AUTHORIZE THE
STATE TREASURY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC WELFARE TO
ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
PROCESSING THEIR OWN S. S. P.
PAYMENT PROGRAM. THE PAYMENTS
WERE PREVIOUSLY AS ME
ADMINISTERED BY SSA. THIS HAS
BEEN A COST SAVING MEASURE TO
THE STATE AND NOW BASED ON ITS
SUCCESS THEY ACTUALLY HAD A
LEGISLATION PASSED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AUTHORIZING THE STATE
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT IN
PENNSYLVANIA TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS WITH OTHER STATES.
THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA IS TO
WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OFFER
THE SERVICES AND PROVIDE THE
ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO SAVE
MONEY BY HAVING THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA ADMINISTER THE SS
BE PROGRAM. SO WHAT THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE ARE BRINGING
FORTH WOULD BASICALLY. CHANGE
CURRENT LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW
UNDER EXISTING LAW DSS HOUSE TO
CONTRACT WITH THE UNITED STATES
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO MAKE THE PAYMENTS.
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE ARE
PUSHING FORWARD IS BASICALLY
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD SIMPLY
AUTHORIZE BUT NOT REQUIRE DSS
TO CONTRACT WITH EITHER AS A
STATE OR ANOTHER STATE THAT IS
CAPABLE OF ACTUALLY HANDLING
THE SERVICE. THIS AUTHORIZATION
WOULD ONLY COME INTO PLAY IF
THE STATE MADE THE
DETERMINATION THAT CONTRACTING
WITH ANOTHER STATE WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO CALIFORNIA AND TO
THE BENEFICIARIES OF THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. DSS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LA PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE SIX
BE. SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT
BACK- FOR THE SPONSORS IF I MAY
CAN YOU DESCRIBE WHAT EFFECT
THIS WOULD HAVE FOR RECIPIENTS.
WELL ONCE IF CALIFORNIA DECIDED
TO PURSUE THIS TYPE OF A
CONVERSATION WITH THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA PENNSYLVANIA WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE MORE OF AN
ANALYSIS AS TO THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION THEY WOULD NEED AND
CARRY FORWARD BUT THE IDEA
WOULD BE THAT THE ACTUAL-
TRANSITION WOULD SEEM BE
SEAMLESS AND THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA WOULD ASSUME ALL
UP FRONT COST. AND TO JUST MAKE
SURE AGAIN IF THIS IS IT MOST
OF THIS IS DONE ELECTRONICALLY
SO IF ALL OF THAT IS FIGURED
OUT THE IDEA WOULD BE THAT ONCE
PENNSYLVANIA FOR EXAMPLE HOUSE
ALL OF THE ACCOUNTS AND
DEPOSITING INTO THAT. TO THE
BANK ACCOUNTS NOTHING WOULD
MOVE FORWARD UNTIL TESTS WERE
RUN TO ENSURE THAT THE
BENEFICIARIES WOULD NOT BE
IMPACTED. I THINK MY QUESTION
IS REGARDING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD RECEIVE ONE CHECKER
TOO. THEY WOULD RECEIVE TWO
CHECKS THEY WOULD BASICALLY
RECEIVE ONE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ONE. FROM
CALIFORNIA. SO PERCEPTION FROM
THE RECIPIENTS MAY BE THAT
THERE- THAT THERE THAT IT WENT
DOWN BUT THE REALITY BEING TWO
CHECKS WOULD TOTAL THE SAME AS
WAS BEFORE THAT IS CORRECT.
BASED ON THIS DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OR FINANCE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS REGARDING THIS
PROPOSAL. NOT AT THIS TIME I
KNOW WHAT YOU'E NOT ANALYSIS
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT WE'RE
TALKING TO FOLKS BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO SUGGEST AT
THIS TIME. YEAH GIVEN THAT
IT'S- POTENTIAL STATE SAVINGS I
MAY ASK. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE- AN APPROPRIATE ANALYSIS
FROM. BOTH DEPARTMENT SO THAT
WE CAN- AND SEE IF THIS IS A
WAY WE COULD. HELP TO REINVEST
IT WOULD BE APPRECIATED SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIX BE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
OUR
BEING JOINED BY ANOTHER MEMBER
OF OUR STAFF JUST GIVE US A
CALL OKAY. WE SHOULD HAVE
ENOUGH CHAIRS FRANK IF YOU
WANNA COME FORWARD. THIS OKAY
I'M WITH THAT I AM HERE TODAY
TO ASK THIS COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE A HUNDRED MILLION IN
STATE FUNDS ON AN ONGOING BASIS
FOR THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM AS WE HAVE
HEARD THE AGING POPULATION IS
GROWING IN THAT HAS HAD A
DIRECT IMPACT ON LOCAL APS
PROGRAMS THIS POPULATION COMES
WITH COMPLEX HEALTH NEEDS NOT
ONLY ARE THEY OLDER THEY ARE
ALSO VULNERABLE DUE TO
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURIES AND
DEMENTIA AND A GROWING NUMBER
ARE HAVE BEEN FINANCIALLY
EXPLOITED. COUPLED THAT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S UNPRECEDENTED
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE RESEARCH
OUT OF UCSF BY DOCTOR MARGOT
CRUCIAL SHOWS THAT ADULTS OVER
AGE FIFTY ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING COHORT OF HOMELESS
ADULTS WITH NEARLY HALF
BECOMING HOMELESS AFTER THE AGE
OF FIFTY. CLEARLY CALIFORNIA
HAS REACHED A BOILING POINT IN
OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND WE TRULY
NEED A MULTI FACETED APPROACH
AND ONE THAT BUILT ON OUR
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS LIKE A PS.
THIS APS PROGRAM HAS A PROVEN
RECORD OF SUCCESS IN SERVING
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION AND
THIS PROGRAM HAS EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE KNOWS HOW TO
WORK WITH OLDER ADULTS WHO HAVE
COMPLEX NEEDS. AND WORKS WITH
PARTNERS ACROSS DIFFERENT
AGENCIES INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN. THIS PROPOSAL HAS
THREE COMPONENTS WHICH WILL BE
DESCRIBED IN MORE DETAILS BY
OUR PRESENTERS. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING. MY NAME IS PAUL DONE
AWAY AND I'M THE DIVISION
DIRECTOR OF ADULT NEEDING
SERVICES AND SONOMA COUNTY
WHICH IS A PART OF THE HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND A COALITION OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO REDUCE OLDER ADULTS
HOMELESSNESS BY EXPANDING AND
ENHANCING THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM. WE ARE
REQUESTING A HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING STATE FUNDS. THIS
PROPOSAL TARGETS FUNDING IN
SEVERAL KEY WAYS. INCREASED
STAFFING WILL ALLOW FOR LONGER
TERM CASE MANAGEMENT AND FOR
CASE WORKERS TO INTERVENE
WHETHER MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS AT AN EARLIER POINT
HELPING TO AVERT SOME OF THE
MORE DIFFICULT AND MORE COSTLY
CRISIS SITUATIONS. DOLLARS
INVESTED IN A HOME SAFE
PROGRAMS WILL DIRECTLY SERVE
THOSE IN OUR PROGRAM WHO ARE
FACING HOMELESSNESS. IT WILL
ALSO HELP ALL COUNTIES TO
CREATE CROSS SYSTEM TEAMS THAT
WORK CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS TO TACKLE THE MOST
COMPLEX CASES. AT THE TIME THE
APS WAS ESTABLISHED OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE OLDER ADULT
POPULATION WASN'T WHAT IT IS
TODAY. IN CINEMA COUNTY OLDER
ADULTS MAKE UP. MORE THAN. ONE
QUARTER OF THE TOTAL POPULATION.
IT'S PROJECTED THE CALIFORNIA
OLDER ADULTS OLDER ADULTS WILL
SURPASS THOSE OF MINORS IN THE
YEAR TWENTY THIRTY SIX. THAT
HAPPENED IN CINEMA COUNTY IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND THAT'S
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AHEAD OF THE
PROJECTED TIME FRAME. AND I
KNOW THAT SONOMA COUNTY IS NOT
ALONE. THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
ARE SAYING HAVE MORE COMPLEX
NEEDS AND NEED MORE HELP THAN
WE CAN GIVE THEM. THE CURRENT
FUNDING WHICH IS MOSTLY COUNTY
REALIGNMENT DOES NOT COVER THE
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN
POPULATION WITH GREATER
COMPLEXITIES. WE'RE ALSO IN
CONSTANT COMPETITION FOR THIS
FINITE RESOURCE. LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND REPORTS OF ABUSE TO
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. CINEMA COUNTY HAS
SEEN A 46% INCREASE BETWEEN THE
YEARS OF TO THOR TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND THAT'S JUST FIVE
YEAR TIME. THE COMPLEXITY OF
CASES CAN BE MEASURED IN THE
NUMBER OF ALLEGATIONS. CINEMA
COUNTY SAW 37% INCREASE IN IN
ALLEGATIONS IN THE SAME TIME
FRAME. SO MY COUNTY APPLIED FOR
AND RECEIVED FUNDING TO
ADMINISTER THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM WHICH STARTED IN JULY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN NINETEEN.
EIGHT MONTHS IN WE HAVE NOW
SERVED SIXTY INDIVIDUALS AND
HAVE MANY SUCCESS STORIES. I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOU ONE OF THAT OF
LAND. LYNN IS A SIXTY ONE YEAR
OLD DEPENDENT ADULT WHO IS NON
AMBULATORY AFTER SUPPER-
SUFFERING A DISABLING STROKE
MANY YEARS AGO. LYNN WENT
THROUGH A DIVORCE HAD TO SELL
OUR HOME AND EVENTUALLY FILED
FOR BANKRUPTCY. AFTER
UNDERGOING INTENSIVE
REHABILITATION SHE MOVED IN
WITH A FRIEND. IT WAS A PLACE
TO LIVE BUT FAILED TO MEET YOUR
BASIC NEEDS. SHE MOVED INTO A
HOTEL SPENDING HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS. OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL YEARS A. P. S. HAD A
NUMBER OF REPORTS ONLINE. AFTER
HOME SAFE WAS IMPLEMENTED LYNN
WAS ASSIGNED A SPECIALIZED
WORKER IN THIS PROGRAM. WITH A
COMBINATION OF KEY CONTRACT
SUPPORT PROVIDERS LIKE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. A BUDGET TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR LARGE EXPENSES LIKE
SECURITY DEPOSITS AND RENTAL
PAYMENTS. LOWER CASE LOADS AND
LONGER TERM CASE MANAGEMENT
HOME SAFE IS A SUCCESS FOR
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND STILL IN
ITS YEAR AND ITS FIRST YEAR OF
ACTIVITY. WHEN IS NOW LIVING IN
INAPPROPRIATE HOUSING TO MEET
HER NEEDS AND HAS A CARETAKER.
QUANTIFYING THE COST SAVINGS
COMPARED TO LAND BEING HOMELESS
MAY BE IMPOSSIBLE BUT THIS IS
ONE PERSON WHO IS OVERCOMING
SERIOUS CHALLENGES AND NOW IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO ADD THE
CHALLENGE OF BEING HOMELESS.
SERVICES IS ALREADY CHALLENGING
EXISTING RESOURCES. ONE
CONSEQUENCES INCREASED ORDERED
ALL POPULATION LIVING WITHOUT A
HOME. APS IS A KEY PARTNER IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE THIS
FUNDING WILL KEEP THAT SUPPORT
AVAILABLE AS WE CONTINUE
PARTNERING WITH OTHER SAFETY
NET SERVICES. WE BELIEVE THAT
FINDING A PS PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING BOTH THE
ISSUES OF OLDER DAHLE
HOMELESSNESS AND THE GROWTH IN
OLDER ADULT POPULATIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FACING. WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MAC AT THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR%
OF THE COUNTY WILL FOR
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I WAS
ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
AN APPOINTEE BY THE GOVERNOR ON
THIS REGIONAL COUNCIL HOMELESS
ADVISORS WE HAD WE HAD THAT THE
BENEFIT OF MANY EXPERTS TO
ADDRESS TO ADDRESS THAT SOME
PROVIDED INFORMATION TO US. ALL
OF IT SOBERING AND SCARY NONE
OF IT MORE FRIGHTENING THAN THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU
HIGHLIGHTED IN YOUR REMARKS AND
I THINK THEY BEAR REPEATING 50%
OF THE ON HOUSE TO DOUBTS ON
THE STREET ARE OVER FIFTY HALF
OF THEM GOT THERE FOR THE FIRST
TIME AFTER THE AGE OF FIFTY AND
THEY GOT THERE BECAUSE OF AN
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCE- OR A
FAMILY CONDITION NOT BECAUSE OF
A SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS THAT'S
NOT TO SAY. SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS IS NOT A PART OF THE
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM BUT THE
LARGEST GROUP IN THE FASTEST
GROWING GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON HOUSE ON THE STREET ARE OVER
FIFTY AND THAT NUMBER IS GOING
TO SKYROCKET- THE CONDITION OF
THOSE PEOPLE'S LIVES AND THE
DETERIORATION IN THE
COMPENSATION IS JUST AS
FRIGHTENING AS- DOCTOR TO SHALL
POINTED OUT IN HER RESEARCH THE
BIOLOGICAL AGE OF AN OLDER
ADULTS WHO SPENDS TIME ON THE
STREET. THIS TWENTY YEARS
GREATER THAN THEIR
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE AND HER TERM
SEVENTY IS THE NEW FIFTY- AND
THIS PROPOSAL- IS PRESENTED IN
THE SPIRIT OF TRYING TO START
TO MAKE SOME HEADWAY TO PREVENT
OR DO SOME EARLY INTERVENTION
ON BEHALF OF WHAT IS THE
FASTEST GROWING POPULATION OF
HOMELESSNESS- WE AS A STATE AS
WE THINK ABOUT DEVELOPING MORE
HOUSING AND- EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF SUBSIDIES WE HAVE GOT
TO START TO THINK ABOUT
TARGETED AND FOCUSED PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND I
THINK WE CAN START WITH
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW WORK. IN
THE PROGRAMS THAT EVERY DAY
SERVE PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER
HOMELESS OR AT EXTREMELY HIGH
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND SO WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE. YOUR CHEN.
OF THIS ISSUE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO SEE IF WE
CAN MAKE THIS HAPPEN I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED BY MY FRIENDS THAT
SCA YOU WHO ARE TENDING TO
CHILD CARE RESPONSIBILITIES IF
I WOULD- HIGHLIGHT THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE SEVEN.
THE EVENING LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALCUTTA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND COMPLAINTS
THAT WERE INVESTIGATED LAST
YEAR EIGHTY ASK THE LARGEST
CATEGORY FALLS UNDER THAT
SECTION OF THE SELF NEGLECT AND
I THINK- THE DIRECTOR SAID IT
REALLY POINT LEAD THIS MORNING.
THAT SOUTH NEGLECT IS NOT EIGHT
EIGHT AN INTENTIONAL THING IT'S
NOT LACK OF A RESOURCE AND THE
APS PROVIDERS BIG BIG CONNECT
THE DOTS FOR THESE PEOPLE AND
THIS AGAIN IT'S THAT WE'RE
GONNA PAY FOR IT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT LATER LET'S
PAY FOR IT IN ADVANCE AND KEEP
PEOPLE FROM BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND RESOURCE APS REMEMBER. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MARTY
MOTO FAMILY MEMBER CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK- MY SISTER WHEN
SHE WAS STILL ALIVE AS AN ADULT
IT WAS WAS ABUSED IN. NOT THAT
THIS SOLUTION WOULD NECESSARY
OF PREVENTED THAT BUT ANY MORE
OVERSIGHT AND SUPPORTS WOULD
DEFINITELY HELP SO RELEASE A
STRONG SUPPORT AND BY THE WAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU AS CHAIR OF
MISTER DOCTOR RANDALL AND ALSO
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF FROM BOTH
PARTIES YOU REALLY HAVE
LISTENED TO US NOT AT JUSTICE
HEARING BUT THE HEARING LAST
WEEK AND HEARING ON MONDAY IN
ALL THE OTHER HEARINGS AND I
CANNOT TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANS
AS- FAMILY MEMBERS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE LISTENED TO.
IT'S NOT IT IS ONE THING TO BE
VISIBLE AT THESE HEARINGS BUT
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO BE
LISTENED TO AND YOU'VE DONE
THAT AT EVERY HEARING THE STAFF
OF DONE THAT AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE BEEN TRY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THE URBAN COUNTIES ARE A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
THAT MADERA COUNTY SUPPORTS THE
PROPOSAL I WOULD JUST SAY DITTO
TO EVERYTHING THAT MISTER
MARCUS HEAD ON THIS REALLY IS
UP. WE REALLY BE THIS- ITEM AS
A PREVENTION ISSUE THANK YOU.
CAN GIVE THEM. SO I IT SEEM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CONNIE
DEMAND AND I AM IN A RP
VOLUNTEER. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS AGE FIFTY AND
OVER WE'RE GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
AUGMENTATION TO APS. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES THAT WILL ALLOW A PS
TO DEAL WITH POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES FOR AT RISK
POPULATIONS. MOST NOTABLY IT
WOULD LOWER THE ELIGIBILITY AGE
FOR A PS FROM SIXTY FIVE TO
SIXTY TO MATCH ELIGIBILITY IN
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT. IT
WOULD ON MEN AND EXPAND THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM BEYOND ITS
CURRENT COUNTIES AND ENHANCE
THE TOOLS TO ASSIST THOSE AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND ENACT
LONG TERM MULTI DISCIPLINARY
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES NEEDED
FOR MORE INTENSIVE CASES. AS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION OF
OLDER ADULTS CONTINUES TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE APS
SERVICE THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE TO PREMATURE DEATH%
THROUGH ABUSE AND NEGLECT. AS
WE KNOW APS WORKERS PROVIDE
FRONTLINE RESPONSE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
AND MUST BE PROPERLY TRAINED TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS ON
COMPLEX CASES. ENGAGE VICTIMS
AND THEIR OWN SAFETY PLANNING.
AND THEIR HELP THEIR FAMILIES
AND TO NAVIGATE THE OTHER
SYSTEMS FOR HELP. THIS IS WHY
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY APPROACH
INCLUDED IN THIS REQUEST IS SO
VITAL THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ARE
A CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE WITH
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH THE
GROWING NUMBER OF HOMELESSNESS
IN THIS POPULATION AS WELL AS
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES. AT THE TIME IS RIGHT
TO MAKE THIS CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS THANK YOU. YES
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. SO
I MAY I ASK IF I CAN TO HAVE-
KIM RUTLEDGE FOLLOW UP A
LITTLE- AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR ROLE AS A PS DIRECTOR WE
WOULD. WE WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH SOME TECHNICAL ADVICE
REGARDING THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS AND MAKE SURE WERE
WORKING WELL WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENT- I DIDN'T WANT TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOME SAFE IF I COULD- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE FUNDS
WERE ALLOCATED FOR TWENTY FOUR
COUNTIES- AND I DIDN'T KNOW HOW
MANY HAD APPLIED AND IF THEY'RE
IF THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
OVER PRESCRIBED OR HOW WE
DECIDED ON THOSE. INITIAL
COUNTIES FOR THE PILOT. SO THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM ISN'T%
ADMINISTERED OUT OF OUR
DIVISION BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY-
GET THAT INFORMATION AND
PROVIDE IT TO YOU. WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT FOLLOW UP IF WE
COULD. WITH THAT- I WILL HOLD
ISSUES SEVEN OPEN AND THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION. WE WILL NOWMOVE
ON TO NON DISCUSSION ITEMS AND
WOULD ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE
NON DISCUSSION ITEMS. SEEING
NONE. THIS WILL CONCLUDE OUR
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR ATTENDING.